[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
hard at work at the American Cup in St
Louis with the elimination bracket
taking a rest the Champions bracket
faced off to punch their ticket to the
penultimate round thirteen-year-old
Alice Lee an eight-time U.S women's
champ Irena Crush move on after deathly
dispatching their opponents in the
women's section Hikaru Nakamura remains
unscathed advancing to face Wesley so
after the latter survived a thrilling
playoff against Fabiano caruana the
brackets are set who will survive and
who will go home day 5 of exhilarating
chess coming up next
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day five of
the 2023 American Cup held at the St
Louis chess club yesterday I showed you
where the players are staying during the
event at the Chase Park Plaza today I am
going to take the long walk from the
hotel to the plane it's been a fantastic
event so far let's see what the players
have in store for us today let's go to
the studio and start the action with
Jovi and yasu
we welcome you to St Louis Missouri the
capital of Chess in America this is day
five of the 2023 American cup from the
Saint Louis chess club
foreign
welcome from the Saint Louis chess club
Studio my name is Ivanka houska and it's
a great pleasure to be here calling all
the action on this very special day five
with the one and only Grandmaster yasa
sarawan Jovi has been my pleasure
working alongside you and Christian has
really been a lot of fun thank you thank
you thank you hello everyone and Welcome
to our live coverage of day five day
four was fantastic everything about
yesterday I truly loved the classical
games that Hikaru won over Lanier that
Alice Lee won over Naji they were great
and the playoffs were simply outstanding
I'm expecting further Highlights today
but first let's start with the ladies
and their brackets yeah let's delve
deeper into those brackets and as yasa
mentioned it was an eventful day
yesterday where the top seeds were just
dominant we saw Arena Crush simply
overwhelmed tohenjo novas to offenses
and she made it through to the next
stage and in the second match between
najibai's kids and a 13 year old Alice
Lee Alice Lee came to the board in a
fighting mood and she just played
fantastic chess to dispatched by the
kids are down to the elimination bracket
and if we check the elimination bracket
and do that these players will be
playing a very fast time control but
they are playing for survival anyone who
loses now gets sent out of the
competition and we have naughty pakiza
she will face off against Tate
abrahamian whereas token Genova will be
playing against the newcomer atusa
percussion for everything to play for
there will be a winner today easy for
you to pronounce that last match and in
the Open Bracket yeah and in the Open
Bracket I mean what a day of Chess as
well we saw Hikaru Nakamura come to the
day with a plan and that plan was to
feed Jenny Dominguez in the classical
portion which he did with the black
pieces and then we saw this epic match
between Wesley so and Fabiana caruana
Wesley so wanted in the tie breaks and
sent Fabiano caruana down to the
elimination bracket where guess who
awaits him with open arms tell me no
other than Lavon aronian I mean that is
a huge matchup and then we also have
lania Dominguez against Sam Shanklin and
our format to remind everybody about the
double illumination yes it is a double
elimination bracket tournament no draw
offers and the tournament has kind of
separated into two we have the Champions
bracket a male playing at a very sedate
leisurely classical 90 minutes plus 30
second increment no second time control
in the elimination bracket things are
getting spicy there because they are
playing two rapid 25 minute games plus
10 second increment per move wonderful
and this remaining schedule for today
yeah well you know in the Champions
bracket they're simply playing one game
to set the pace to set the mood so to
speak but the action is going to be fast
furious in the elimination bracket
because there will be a decider there
will be a winner today to play two games
and if there is still a tie then of
course these will be decided in playoffs
and tie breaks wonderful and we're very
fortunate to have in Studio Grand Master
Christian carrilla Christian yesterday
it seemed like a highlight reel there
was just highlights going on all the
time what can our viewers expect today
good to see you guys well yesterday the
elimination bracket had a rest day and
finally today they will be rejoining the
tournament so we have all sorts of
clashes but of course in my opinion the
highlight of the day is the beginning
meaning of the finals in the Champions
bracket and let's take a look how our
finalists got where they are today and
we're going to start with the ladies
section the one Grand Master in the
ladies event that is Grand Master Irina
Crush has just simply been dominant in
this event 2-0 against out of abrahamian
after that she started off with a
crucial victory in her match against
begging to visionova with the white
pieces and with the black pieces
yesterday I have to say she was never in
danger to get beaten and potentially go
to a playoffs she easily taken advantage
of her opening preparation and defeated
beginova with a one and a half to a half
score and right now she's in the finals
against Alice Lee the young Phenom only
13 years of age she has been impressing
us throughout this event last year as
well she made it to the finals where she
was defeated by Arena crashed well in
this one she disposed of atusa
percussion 2o and yesterday's game
against Naji paikiza the two-time U.S
women's champion was just a masterpiece
she was able to find that move Look to
create such an incredible move and after
that swiftly defeated her very
experienced opponent she will be facing
Irina Crush in the finals of the
Champions Bracken and let's take a look
at their a lifetime matchup as we are
entering this final stage of the event
two wins for Irena Crush zero losses and
three draws but Alice Lee said well
she's going she's looking forward to
take on Grandmaster Irina Crush in
today's matchup and let's take a look at
what's happening in the Champions
bracket in the open section we have
Hikaru Nakamura the rating favorite
going into this event he's in fact the
only player in the open section that won
not one but two games two classical
games up to this point in the event he
disposed of Sam Savion one and a half to
a half and of linear Dominguez also one
and a half to a half but that crucial
Victory came with the black pieces
yesterday in a wild Kalashnikov Sicilian
today he will be facing one Wesley so
and let's take a look at his results so
far well he is definitely showing his
class in the shorter time controls in
the rapid M Blitz format he won the
match in the playoffs against Sam
Shanklin two and a half to a half and
won the match yesterday against Fabiano
caruana also in the rapid playoffs two
and a half to one and a half and let's
take a look at their head to head as we
are entering this critical stage of the
championship in classical one win for
Hikaru four losses wow this is
bewildering to me 19 draws in the rapid
match up 21 wins for Hikaru 13 losses
and 59 59 draws these players have paid
so many times in their careers they know
each other so well and I mean today's
matchups are going to be simply
explosive wow quite the contrast between
the classical score and the rapid score
between our two Champions bracket finals
impressive stuff I I was going to say
that today however we have a really
something really heartwarming it's a
great story a special guest a bell
ringer uh Jovi yeah it really is
something quite unique and as yasa said
heartwarming because Colin Graham is a
17 year old from California and a big
chess fan who is sadly battling cancer
Colin was contacted by the Make-A-Wish
Foundation and his single wish was to
come to the Saint Louis chess club to
watch the American Cup Tournament and
meet some players and here we can see
Colin meeting the players getting his
wish and you can just see the smile on
his face
it's wonderful it truly is a rexing
field there on the right there's uh
Colin uh when you when you think about
America and how Sports on America is
dominated by basketball football you you
know you just don't expect the
Make-A-Wish Foundation to reach into the
Chess World so this is really really
special and a big welcome to Colin and
his family hey
there's no hugging in chess I mean what
about the respectful handshake
now that's the respectful handshake Joy
Bray uh the chair uh woman of uh the the
the the chess
campus campus here in St Louis so Chris
bird I mean it really is by the way big
shout out to Chris bird he corrected me
uh I had expected I had explained
yesterday that
Wesley should have offered a made a draw
claim here we go sorry
thank you
can I just have your attention real
quick
um just a couple of quick announcements
before we start Champions bracket I'm
sure your way you just play one game
today we'll see you tomorrow for game
two of your match elimination
games at three o'clock
Saturday
if necessary a singles applying with
their office
um
we'll check all that fun stuff uh start
in the round today we have a special
guest Colleen Graham uh which Make A
Wish Foundation pick which kid Colin's
wish was to come St Louis chess club
[Music]
come on
foreign
once again Colin could have chosen
anything uh from the Make-A-Wish
Foundation and it's just marvelous that
he chose chess and they're off again
we're going to have Rapids going on
simultaneously with the classical games
um shall we start with the Rapids
because they are often running as we
could see there uh with uh Sam and
Lanier
and this one I have
this I have Wesley this is Wesley's game
it was the opening E4 against heat car
yeah hikara will be playing with the
white pieces because in these match
situations the higher rated playoffs
always begins with the white pieces but
when it comes to the playoffs they
switch they switch the colors right
and uh Wesley pausing
is that a surprise not at all no E4 E5
has been Wesley's go-to defense for
quite some time as we see Colin in the
background getting a chance to visit the
playing Hall
it's very exclusive by the way they
don't even let me go up there uh the
playing Hall very exclusive only the
players Arbiters staff yeah no visitors
visitors yeah and yes sir I feel if I
put in a good word for you I might be
able to get you would you mind would you
mind doing that I mean I might be able
to get that 100 sure
I I have just one small wish
as uh the play is underway but again I
think just because it is an elimination
we may be seeing Fabiano our defending
Champion is got us back to the wall if
he doesn't if he doesn't produce today
he will be eliminated
so let's just check in on that game it
was this um
English with C4 and E5 this floor
mckennis variation in the English one of
the lines that I really really liked as
white I'm frankly I'm unfamiliar with
this position this is uh they're playing
it with Bishop F5 and they're getting
these uh strange lines just having a
look at the statistics on the day and
the opening database it wasn't it wasn't
it's not really a surprise why you're
unfamiliar with this type of position
because there were very few games in
database I mean you're looking at a
handful at the most and I think they've
already branched off into novelty
territory Christian that that's right
and if you remember that game I think it
was named Silva versus startev right
earlier in the event and we were
discussing this type of position because
they did play a very similar situation
as well Bishop to F5 is by far the best
move in the position is not the most
played move in the position Bishop E7
and Visually it makes the most sense to
go for Bishop E7 and go for Castle and
things of that nature the problem with
Bishop to E7 is that it immediately
allows this move a D4 and you don't have
a time to bring the setup to the defense
of the Knight on e4 so for example you
go C5 Bishop to D3 and now I'm sort of
forcing you to take on C3 and I played
D4 in one move keep that in mind
for example after Bishop to F5 the main
line is D3 and after D3 take on C3 take
on C3 C5 or Bishop to E7 and now White's
main option is to play once again D4 but
you spend two tempies to get to this
position so obviously this is an
improved version for uh black this one
is quite an important distinction in
this particular variation and after
Bishop to F5 he decided not to go for D3
it's all about this one tempo right I
want to meet whenever you're going to go
C5 with D4 in one move that's why he
waited he played this waiting move
Bishop to E2 if you do play the move C5
then I can have ideas of D4 challenged
upon on C5 in one go so this is a very
very important distinction D4 was
levon's Choice Knight takes E4 Bishop
takes E4 and we have a D3 in the
position Bishop to C4 get this bishop
out first and after that only play the
move a D3 is the main line but looking
at the engine D3 is the proposed moves
this is how this players train right
they take these Sidelines and they go
deep as deep as they can with the engine
with the help of their seconds as well
and they find wrinkles in the position
very very distinctive wrinkles and this
is exactly what we're seeing but we also
know Levon plays this with the white
pieces as well he's a well-established
English player C4 he loves it we've seen
how powerful his opening preparation is
in last year's event as well I'm
reminding myself of this match between
himself and Ray Robson and Rey somehow
tried to play the move C4 in fact
himself with the white pieces he got
demolished he got demolished I think
Levon finished with more time than he
actually started with so he's a very
very proficient player when it comes to
this type of imbalance structures
imbalance positions and he knows his
theory as well so let's find doubt what
Fabiano prepared at home and let's find
out how Levon will answer to those
challenges well after Castle's Knight C6
Bishop came to F4 and that's actually a
novelty on our uh screen we've actually
seen a2a3 in the past with the idea of
B4 but Bishop F4 and that was a game
between topalov and Hikaru Nakamura in
2017. by the way A3 is not the best move
Bishop to F4 seems to be the computer's
uh Top Choice as well H6 and now the
question is is black actually preparing
to go G5 perhaps G5 yes he is and that's
why he played this move Bishop to G3
right because now after G5 I can stop
you from playing G4 with the move H3 so
the position well perhaps you weaken
your oppon structure a bit too much on
the king's side he decided against it he
actually no he just played G5 he just
played G5 it's on the board right now
the computer doesn't like it the
computer really doesn't like this move
G5 but it is
he knows what he's doing so perhaps this
is the right direction Knight to E2
seems to be the best way now that you
don't have enough attackers on the pawn
on E5 to be able to capture it
immediately and I'm getting ready to
blast open the king side with the move
F4 that's why I played this move Knight
to D2 followed by F4 potentially try to
weaken the king side my guess is that
black is going to try to Castle
alongside absolutely we're going to have
to wait and see these players are
speeding towards some sort of position
that they both seem to be aware of what
they need to do in and uh yeah this this
is going to be a big fight okay great
stuff I mean who's better prepared I
mean because H6 G5 is is definitely
throwing down the gauntlet that's a
challenging uh approach by Lavon with
the black pieces in the first one not
not not warming up but just immediately
I've noticed that about lavon's games in
these last few years especially when it
comes to these rapid time controls and
Blitz time controls he's not afraid to
play in a very creative way and somehow
you get the touch that you know he's
perhaps looked at this position but
maybe it's kind of more divine
inspiration some freestyling going on
and saying to the opponent hey you know
right I I'm gonna play confidently I'm
going to play quickly and I roughly know
what to do with my pieces it's not only
that but he's enjoying himself in the
past few tournaments and I've been
talking to him as well over dinners
breakfast in tata steel we were staying
at the same hotel and he was saying that
look they pay me to do something that I
would do regardless so how can I not
enjoy what I'm doing and how can I not
enjoy playing chess and playing this
type of creative moves on the board he's
enjoying himself and whenever Levon is
enjoying himself he's a dangerous man I
can tell you that wonderful I've got to
ask the question after the move G5 can I
play Queen A4 oh you can definitely do
queen A4 and but how are you going to
respond to H5
I was hoping it wasn't uh an issue over
there so I'm thinking Queen A4 you're
thinking H5 let's go wow okay so
understand H4 right probably you have to
respond with H4 H4 and then after G4 I'm
guessing and now you're uh borderline
lost I will take on H4 I'm borderline
lost yes you've got very precise to
survive this one really wow this 1
D5 is a force of nature in the position
look at it like this Knight takes H4 I
go Bishop to E7 and you're very happy
because you get your knight to F5 close
to my king you get a check on G7 very
disruptive right H4 forget about it H4
followed by H3 and once this long
diagonal opens up and you're going to
have to open it up by force almost after
the move H3 also I can try to go to G8
Target The Pawn on G2 first and then go
to H3 this one is not looking I mean
look at this yeah my king is you have to
show it right right we have to show the
Checkmate in the position H3 you try to
sidestep that with G3 and H2 a checkmate
with a pawn so you you don't see that
very often in so H5 is actually a very
serious threat especially when I'm
moving my queen away so between A4 is a
bad move yeah probably remarkable as
Christian has highlighted you need to
resolve the tension
92.92 maybe can you go Bishop F3 because
you've been kind of like banging on
about how wonderful this lovely Bishop
on D5 is why not trade it off yeah
Bishop 3 is also an idea but once again
Knight D2 stops the move H5 at least
momentarily uh and and that's quite
important by the way we do have on the
board Queen A4 no no no no oh that's it
oh yeah you're right Queen
yes don't be jumping on me I'm just the
messenger don't get upset
or he didn't play H5 he played Bishop G7
well that's surprising that's utterly
surprising I have say queen to A4 H5 was
a golden opportunity he played Bishop G7
yeah but this Knight takes porn in the
air like well thank you I mean I'm just
I'm just anxious to grab the pawn as
well Knight takes
uh D4 I'm I'm confused and if you play I
don't know H5 I'm I'm ready to sync my
uh Knight
I have to say
so this is what I'm thinking
please he's looking at Knight takes D4
Bishop takes G2 yes yes Knight F5 no 95
I can take on F1 right yes that's
permitted I get two Bishops for no just
one yes you get two but I get the Knight
back right
yeah
yeah then that's probably fine it's fine
for black because I have this D4 square
right you try to open up the position
with F4 at the end I have Queen D4
exchange to Queens and enter the end
game I'm happy with that so the king
takes Queen takes D4 yeah yeah and now
you can just move the
Queen we have some problems with E5
perhaps long Castle no
okay and uh I've been anxious to put my
then the force of nature yes
oh this is looking super dangerous
dangerous yes but it's unclear whether
you get that much after the move Queen
to B6 right okay yeah well we'll we'll
this is definitely a game that we want
to keep a an eye on let's just check in
on the game of Arena Crush it's always
fantastic in any sport when number one
plays number two and that's what we've
got for you guys today in the game
between Arena and
um Alice Lee oh this is right out of our
Playbook it is the car okay and I I was
thinking about it I was thinking because
in the 2022 matchup Arena was opening
with C4 and Alice was going to E6 maybe
C6 and I was thinking you know if I were
if I were playing against Alice I might
punt this move E4 yes and see you know
how well does she know her character
exactly uh this I actually got out of a
Playbook of svenes are gligarich and I
started to play this as white myself uh
against the Karo Khan but
normally speaking I did it in a
different move order as black Alice Lee
could have captured Alice could have
simply recaptured the pawn on D5 but she
did play the move G6
which well
invites white to try to hold on to the
problem with Bishop C4 so Bishop G7 this
is like a major Mainline stuff and the
way I played it is as white as I try to
bring my knight to to E2 and the Knight
to F4 to hang on to the pawn
um
okay
um interesting uh approach for both
buyers I wouldn't have guessed this
opening in today's game
yeah I was I suspected it but I didn't
think that Alice would uh played G6
because like you say this is actually
very theoretical at the minute and we do
need to know the plans you can't whereas
Knight takes Knight F3 is very more
conventional it is you can freestyle it
a little bit more G6 sorry you need to
know your stuff you need to know how
you're going to react to what its plans
as you've highlighted well let's see if
uh Arena who by the way has really been
enjoying some great opening prep uh in
the tournament let's see how she handles
her business today uh jumping to the
other classical game that's going on I
mean wow Hikaru and Wesley just kind of
zip their way from the opening through
the middle game right into some kind of
an ending I mean this happened really
really fast so the Berlin with D3 Bishop
C5 again I've always been taught that in
these positions you have to play C3
because the move Knight D4 is an
equalizer I've always believed to be
true and so does Wesley so he did play
Knight D4 he did manage to trade off two
sets minor pieces and now the Queens
and Hikaru must believe that he has a
little something something because he's
playing E4 versus D6 like literally if
you take those two pawns off the board
it's a very even position and I don't
know but to my eyes this is
too little okay I mean White's advantage
of the first move should give you more
than this I think if it if this is all
you get
you know white still has a niggle as we
say you know and a small little
something to make Black's life
unpleasant wow white hazardous what is
that okay so first of all I like what
hikarus has done you move A2 A3 A3 okay
so brilliant kind of kind of gets out of
the way that if the Rook doubles up I'm
not gonna get to play rookie too and
then you know once once that Rook F1
comes on the board okay you know what
I'm going to be suggesting I'm going to
space it just the moves like G4S you
know try to get as much space as
possible obviously I need to prepare it
okay I'm aware of that and um maybe at
the right time
okay so let's just go let's say I play
Knight D7 the idbi Knight D7 rather
self-evident I want you to play Bishop
takes E6 yes I think if you play Bishop
takes E6 well both pretty much agree
that yeah the advantage is gone
Rook af1 I'll go castles
so again I'm inviting you to capture my
bishop and trade all the bits yes and
that's why I have to come up with a good
move to stop
exactly so probably D4 D4 what else
right and this is where we kind of get
to know each other
oh I was I was hoping to keep that
tension I didn't want to have to resolve
it myself now it takes because now if I
play Rook ae8 that does oh excuse me I
do have a
the pawn on B2 of course of course it's
also clear now I see the light yeah
yeah I mean it's I
I'm just saying I I feel the equality is
closer than the advantage let's put it
like that and uh let's go to the
elimination bracket in the open section
and we haven't seen the game between
Lanier and Sam Shanklin
whoa this is one of those Sicilians Sam
Shanklin
maybe he's encouraged after uh
witnessing the open Sicilian that
ikaru played yesterday Sam playing the
Sicilian as well today
Bishop E6
um excuse me where is the novelty here
all of this stuff looks pretty
straightforward to my eyes
Knight takes C6 no that's got to be a
move
apparently 96 C6 is not a popular move
is it if it's been played before it's
her and not that many games I have a yes
please say it say it this one doesn't
look like it's
fiery what I'm so much more exciting
than the current games
Bishop F1 what a beautiful retreating
move and I'm just I'm just looking at
other games and I'm thinking let's go
let's go there okay where would you like
to take I like to see Christy again very
excited about one game and I've also got
that position up on my screen am I yeah
I am getting very excited
it seems like the two-time U.S women's
champion
has gotten a winning position out of you
take a look at what's happening in this
one and it's going fast in this position
tatev after the move Knight to D2 played
C5 decided to blast open the center or
at least create this tension and Naji
was like yeah sure I'll take it I'll
take on D5 you're going to get the
hanging pawns but you don't have time to
stabilize the hanging pawns because take
a look at this move Knight to C4 that's
targeting the bishop on D6 at the same
time increasing the pressure on D5 so
this is basically a double attack in the
position which forces D takes C4 was
played in the game Bishop takes B7 Rook
to A7 Queen takes D6 sure give me that
one as well and gift me another Pawn
right now the vacuum has arrived in the
position I'm going to take this Pawn I'm
going to take the pawn on C4 and at the
end of it that's like two pawns up right
that's a winning advantage and it
doesn't seem like white or black excuse
me has any sort of compensation in the
position I'm uh
yeah I mean that was an it was an
oversight padef must be devastated right
now because with the black pieces she
didn't even get to play any moves in
this game and already got a losing
position Knight C4 uh the position
between Fabi our defending champion and
Levon blowed up reminding everybody they
are in Rapid shafts right they're uh
when we left it remember we looked at
Knight takes D4 my first
try failed miserably was Knight F5
Bishop takes F1
on the other hand check this out Knight
E6 ooh
forcing the cat yes forcing the capture
now you've lost a castling privilege
privileges after Bishop H5 check King
went to E7 Queen A3 check King to D7
King takes Bishop takes E5 wow blacks
came in the center and Levon says I
don't mind
is he right though I mean this sure
looks
I mean it looks really really dangerous
not that my king is that greatest shakes
either
what's her impression at first at first
blush
kiss
the dangerous I mean
okay Knight takes four okay so let's go
obviously to bring another piece in you
gotta defend it kind of right queen of
six can I
Upsy Daisy and over
that's one way also do you think
something else yeah I was also thinking
removed before but I mean probably you
can do it now D4 just between C3
Queen C3 oh that's a nasty oh that's a
that's a bad one yeah that's really bad
shame on me so I have to move back with
them yeah
I tell you what I was thinking please so
instead of Rook A1 I was thinking D4
let's go if you go yeah backwards I go
again
I'm not gonna go for that one guess who
picked up on the same thought processor
you just had uh Jovi uh our defense uh
defending Champion Fabiano and yes also
like shaking his uh head oh he doesn't
like it well he knows he's busted well
where else am I supposed to move the
night the Knight can't go to C4 this is
this is the standard double attack
um so I played Knight C6 and
I'm gonna have to say
like I will
give you the porn
not seizing anything look to D1 the only
thing you're seizing is five comes
immediately I'm seizing a handshake huh
yeah
Knight C6 D5 this looks devastating this
is actually just simply over
um like One Missed go back a few moves
what he missed was Knight to E6
this was the critical move okay the
critical Intermezzo not King takes G2
but Knight to E6 now you have to take on
E6
and I'm not going to take on G2 I'm
going to throw in a check first right
that's the problem by the way he took on
D5 we're going to see most likely Bishop
to G4 check keep the king in the center
do not allow it to go to B8 right and if
you manage to do that and you are
managing it to do that then the game is
pretty much over because all of my
pieces are and look at Levon how is that
King ever going to say I don't think
it's not I think it's not I don't think
I've ever seen Lavon have his King on
these open highways right out of the
opening you just don't see this in his
games he because as black he's super
solid against one E4 and when he's
playing D4 or against the English he's
usually playing E5 his King never gets
stuck so here what you've got to go King
E8 that's the only legal move in the
position Rook Shack doing fun here
yesterday exactly and well nothing like
a good King hunt uh early in the morning
because get the juices flowing right by
the way yes is linear just simply a
piece up now oh oh okay okay we're gonna
switch we think Lavon is busted but also
Sam Shanklin is busted right now oh
completely busted when we left it we
just saw the move Bishop F1 Bishop to G5
and this is where I really interrupted
you and said the story it was raining
nothing happened
guess what this Knight is just simply
trapped that's it game over
I believe this is what he missed so he
assumed he forgot about the B6 Square he
said that the bishop has to go maybe to
C5 okay what's wrong with that I have
Rook to d8
this is what he missed and The Rook
doesn't have where to go if you go
Bishop to D3 then you lose contact with
the Knight on H3 gotcha he forgot about
the B6 Square simple as that
because the move Bishop B6 stops the
counter play that you've just pointed
out and well Sam said If You're Gonna if
I'm gonna lose a piece I might as well
get a pawn for it he's played the move
Knight F4 Lanier said give me that
I definitely want that a piece for a
couple of Pawns I'll take that any time
of the day
yes I was curious about the time like
we're half an hour in the state of play
yes and we're seeing already like two
last positions at least like what yeah
in the Elimination Brackets it's like
somehow other
shocking something into the water yeah
it really is because some of the
openings that the players have prepared
for this American Cup have been really
scintillating and on point you don't
expect these blunders uh out of the
opening uh Lavon we left him shaking his
head that still well we didn't see
Bishop G4 yet by uh by Fabi again these
these two players uh well those two
games I want to say are in the
rapid uh and we've got the two classical
games uh in the Champions bracket uh
what's the most uh I want to say
clinical kill here for Fabi Christian
well Bishop G4 was played yes King E8 on
the board King E8 is on the board it
does seem like Bishop to H5 is
so we go back to D7 and now Queen to H3
instead of Bishop to G4 really this
seems to be the best way at least
objectively according to the engine King
D6 and rookie one and keep the bishop on
H5 so that you control Rook to E8
there's no more Challenge on uh the E
file and now it's very very difficult to
hide the key queen to F6 is going to be
met by Queen swings back to the other
side of the board take advantage of the
dark squares on the a3fa diagonal and
now that I have control of the E file
there's no marking to E8 so after Bishop
to G4 King to d8 now I can just simply
go Rook to D1 set up my cannons on the
middle files and uh yeah this one is
just pretty much over you're playing
without the recording h8 The Rook on A8
the king is in the center with no Escape
path so this one is pretty much busted
if he finds Queen to H3 wow uh that's
remarkable because I was really eager to
play the move Bishop G4 and F4 frankly I
was thinking that I would you talk about
the canons and I I basically wanted to
open up the
e-file as well as the file with with
which is completely winning us also okay
Queen to F3 okay all right Queen F3 Let
me refresh my board that will that was
a surprise yes very good move as well a
very good marriage as well as well yeah
well he's just threatening Bishop H well
he's threatening I'm terribly uh crunchy
Levon needs to make a moves fast because
right now his only chance in the
position is put pressure on the clock
yeah if he manages to get Fabi down to
his last couple of minutes with a
complicated battle even if the engine is
saying that it's plus six plus seven but
with a very narrow path to get to the
king then he has a chance if he doesn't
uh take him down to his last couple of
minutes Fabi is going to have enough
time to find the PATH forward and uh
yeah that's going to spell Doom for now
not that I believe it at all but my
first
hope would be you know like to play a
move like Rook H7 so I at least I can
protect myself I'll give you a check and
this is what I think he wants to do with
this move Queen to F3 he wants to give a
check on you want ah I check on the E1
yes yes I mean I can also go now that
you put the Rook on H7 I can in fact go
Bishop to H5 and then queen queen
comes to sc8 that's fine
foreign
looks pretty it's good wow lots of lots
of uh pass to Victory let's jump to the
elimination bracket uh for another game
that we haven't seen uh begum versus
atusha well this
thankfully is a little bit quieter I
mean we could catch our breaths on this
one but uh
I thought everything was nice and chill
Queen takes what has bacon done
do it first of all there's a king on G1
instead of a rook on F1 there's just a
and she's a pawn down
uh something she has a nice night on her
face and black is still a few moves away
of being able to get her Rooks into play
for example Rook to C8 is met by Knight
to E7 Rook to d8 for the moment is
unavailable because of the bishopone H4
so there's some compensation and as
you're mentioning uh guys you have to
get the Rook on H1 into play yes with
the move King to each she plays B4 well
the nice that seems to only help black
certainly
Knight back to E7 well I mean right back
to E6 Knight back to E6 most likely
we're going to see I guess what she
wants to do is pick up F3 right
either that or pick up the pawn on E5
with Rook to E1 yeah I was thinking that
F3 I would be very happy to drop by
night
can come in
to d77 wanted okay
fair and I would love to trade nights
will you be agreeable
check yeah I don't think king of two or
as you like yeah as you like yeah yeah
and here I was thinking like I I want
I want to bring my Rooks into play but I
don't want to play Rook C8 and allow
Knight E7 so that was why I was aspiring
to trade nights and I probably have to
do that right
you don't have to you don't have the
trade-off night you can go 97 okay maybe
even 96 and then I kind of like 96. yeah
96 results I like 96 as well keep
control so nicely wait a minute all I
need to do now is play Rook d8 and to
play Bishop G3
okay
rook d8 and yeah we exchange I go back
to C4 and well you have F6 this is good
this is good for for black for sure okay
uh intriguing uh moment but when we left
it Tata had blundered upon likely
blundered the second Pawn but
something happened yeah she's Queen she
got herself halfway back into the game
right
and the pawn is on B3 that's that's good
news for Tatas for fans I mean she's got
something to look forward to over here
is this is as clear as it was a moment
ago Christian
um it doesn't seem like white has made
any clear mistakes so white is still
doing very very well objectively winning
objectively after the move that she just
played The Rook fd1 very simple just
centralized the Rooks get the Knight to
D5 or start playing E4 E5 destabilize
your opponent's pieces and the pawn on
B3 look it's beautiful yeah the bishop
on B2 is doing such a tremendous job of
stopping that right defending the pawn
on A3 there's no entry squares on the a
file once the Knight moves from C3 that
long diagonal opens up towards the king
okay it's it's still looking very
promising for white okay fair uh right
I'm just going to go to the classical
game between number one Arena crash and
number two uh Alice Lee the seated
players uh they've been kind of slow
playing it I guess uh what has happened
after Bishop G7 let me just uh refresh
my board for a moment I apologize yes we
did see Knight ge2 castles castles and a
lot of my opponents would in this
position play the move Knight D7 I would
play D3 they would play Knight B6 to try
to win back the pawn and I would play
Queen B3 and I would make it as awkward
as I possibly could uh for them to win
the pawn back on D5
it's a very reluctant opponent who would
ever capture the bishop on C4 because
after D3 takes C4 I would remain a pawn
to the good so that's why I was saying
that this is a this is a key moment now
for Alice another possibility is
actually a kind of a funny word yeah
Knight A6 instead of bringing the Knight
to B6 you put the Knight on C7 and then
you try to play B6 or A6 and B5 and to
take the pawn that way
key moment here for Alice
again we'll keep an eye on this one uh
Christian where would you like to take
us well I was still looking at this uh
games in the lady section ladies
elimination bracket because atusa did
seem to have made a mistake with this
last move Knight to C3
after the move P4 because after Rook to
E1 I don't see a clear way how you can
defend this Pawn on E5 you can go Knight
to D3 but then I go Rook to E3 there's
no Rook to d8 and I think this is the
critical idea behind uh uh White's
compensation you can go E4 but then I
can try to go F3 and Target The Pawn on
e4 so I would assume this is sort of the
direction that we're going towards and
F3 does make a lot of sense in the
position once again it's all about the
fact that your Rooks cannot get involved
into the game yet otherwise you would
just be a pawn up and probably having a
winning position as black but so far it
seems like maybe Knight to C3 was not
the correct move now the question is
what if you just go back to D7 right
defend the pawn from that square the
problem is Rook to E3 and how do you
continue the game if you go Knight to D5
Rook to D3 you might have some problems
not only that but I also have this idea
of Rook to G3 and start looking at your
G7 Pawn right G5 does work because I
just simply take on H6 and take on G5 so
you have to go G6 but now finally I got
my Pawn back at the same time I still
have the dark Square Bishop which I
think is going to be quite crucial in
this game so
very intriguing end game is this battle
between the extra pawn and the jumping
Knights against uh the weakness of the
fact that you cannot introduce your
Rooks into the game and the idea of
white or potentially uh shifting its
attack path towards the king via the E3
and G3 squares very interesting end game
I have to say and it's all going to come
down to their last final minutes because
right now atusa down to her last 8
minutes 12 minutes for begging Tokyo
Nova big fight ahead of ourselves yeah
thank you
thank you Christian for that turning
quickly to our Champions bracket the
classical game between Hikaru and Wesley
Hikaru hasn't had to play any playoffs
whereas Wesley has played two we left it
just a bit the this moment where I was
basically saying I didn't feel like
Hikaru had really achieved anything out
of the opening
um for me it was a bit of a surprise
Bishop takes E6
I would have thought F take C6 maybe he
was afraid of E5 because of black gets
in E5 himself it's a dead draw and
Bishop takes E6 was met by Rook takes E6
Knight F3 and we have D5 we're all
caught up with the players and
um well again I I still feel that the
balance is there I don't see it myself
for white if you if you allow this I'm
not unhappy at all as black so it's got
to be based on E5
and then Knight D7 and it's you gotta
play D4 and now is the time to chip away
yeah F6 I think it's pretty balanced to
Maya yes I don't know
but for those of you who are joining us
late should we look at the brackets just
to remind everybody where we stand is
we're in day five we are in daytime
which day is this and uh yeah we are in
a crucial stage in the Champions bracket
it is a big matchup between Hikaru
Nakamura and Wesley so and they are
playing a classical game of 90 minutes
plus 30 seconds for them everything will
be decided tomorrow but in the
elimination bracket this is where things
are going to get fast furious fun and we
see that there are some very crucial
matchups we have Fabiana caruana facing
up against Levon aronian whoever wins
will progress to the next stage whoever
loses leads the competition and we saw
that live on aronium playing with the
black pieces is in terrible trouble
lenia Dominguez has the white pieces
against Sam shankland and it also seems
that things are also taking a turn in
linear's favor
but everything to play for if it's all
tied we're going to see tie breaks
playoffs and for the ladies and in the
Champions bracket as yassan mentioned it
is number one against number two Arena
crash against a 13 year old Alice Lee
and Arena does have the white pieces
again they're playing a very classical
time control 90 minutes plus 30 seconds
increment per move but all the fun is
happening today in the elimination
bracket because today is the day when we
will decide who stays in the competition
who will go home Naji pakiza and Tata
abrahamian they're on their last chance
whoever wins will progress the next
stage and then we have a very close
match between tohenjo Nova against otusa
nice uh surprising to to my eyes I had
expected a handshake uh long ago I
thought Lavon was toast as King was uh
terrible conditions it still is the case
but it's not the handshake that you
really really wait one second yes
there's no count pieces I know there's
an extra piece for white yeah but okay I
actually thought it was going to be mate
that's true
an extra piece should be enough I
understand that level but there's a big
difference between Checkmate and an
extra piece right I didn't have finally
got your king to safety after so many
moves your king goes to A7 you escape
congratulations
European style I know
look look look look
give me some good news
the only good news is that your king is
not getting checkmated that's what
that's the only thing you're looking
forward to in life in this position yeah
okay well I mean it's those small things
it's harsh but it's reality at this
point by the way the move Queen takes G5
strangely enough came with another
threat of actually taking another Bond
rip takes D5 like for example A4 Rook
takes D5 Rook takes D5 Queen takes D5 uh
would actually just snare another pawn
and just say oops uh
no no don't do that yeah sir Rook takes
F7
at the end I have Queen G5 queen queen
G5
boys and girls is why you don't resign
that's right we're we're there's life
There's Hope right uh Rook takes F7 oh
oh oh oh oh you're probably still
winning I understand but it's again
that's not what you want the check made
and it's not the extra piece that he
currently enjoys what he does he did do
Lavon pardon me he did play Queen C2 by
the way that was a very crafty little
trick true he could have tried right hey
how about you take on D5 another Pawn
exactly
and in this case
I guess the problem is F2 or
why can't you try to take on but how do
you The Rook takes D5 so I take back you
take back with the queen only move
yeah and it looks like he just wants it
it it's not yeah the the easiest yes
it's not great but it is a piece right
yeah it is a piece
yeah no here I would probably just
Retreat the bishop and somehow I expect
my opponent to resign I don't know
uh okay well keep an eye on this linear
is also a man who's a piece ahead at
least when we left it uh just here is
when we left it and this one feels
on a different level yeah he's a piece
up but you know likes Pawns
pretend to be menacing okay can somebody
help me out here he played Rook D2
followed by Rook D6
finger fail
like did he drop the Rook on D2 on its
way to D6 that's surprising uh okay
there are three connected pass bombs on
the king side
and the two Bishops are stunted yeah
Bishop takes and Bishop D4 on I mean
this should be winning for white but uh
it all depends on how dangerous is the F
Pawn Yeah
he wanted
Rook D2 threatening threatening Bishop
F2 and in case of Bishop takes F2 then
we'll fix G5 into meso check King G7 but
isn't the king better
than it is on GA it is my friend
so why would I put thinking on a that's
a square like help me a king G7 Rook D6
uh still winning uh I would say but okay
uh we'll keep an eye and Christian what
do you have Kicking and Screaming
definitely it's Sam Shanklin right now
it's not over yet right King pardon me
Ruto F6 Rook F6
so how do you how do you do things right
now I would be just tempted to grab the
opponent A6 run with the a pawn
how about this idea why don't we go
Bishop to d8
Bishop to David a that's going to stop
well that that stops me from pushing me
and now E5
I'm trying to get the bishop to F6
so that your F Pawn is not supported
from behind by a rook but but is it so
dangerous I mean you can park the bishop
on okay I understand yeah no I know okay
sir no he's going first E5
similar idea where I mean where are you
going to move the Rook is the problem
well if you go to F5 I go Bishop to D3
G6 directly okay so he's basically
saying Bishop go ahead and take my Rook
which you say yes
because the bishop the bishop is got an
eye on it on F2 yes yes
well I'm expecting H5 G4 F3 go ahead
take the Rook make my day well oh pardon
me Rook D7 yeah no he's going for H5
on H6
uh-huh yeah no he he has to go for H5 he
does he does
I I suddenly realized that after for
example H5 Jack King Rook it's a kind of
a zoo song you can't push the Jeep on F
Pawn is hanging you can't move the Rook
Rook G7 Rook here or Rook H7 made so
it's like
you're stuck you're just stuck and uh
well you can get Bishop G three he's
done H5 but Rook check and Rook F7 looks
like uh Bishop to G3 yeah Bishop G3 is
possible Bishop to G3 is possible yeah I
think that's my one move now you know
it's actually really funny because I I
really did want to play Rook takes F4
and it was the only move to stop
your hand accidentally found the one way
to stop me from carrying out my thread
that's a very nice move Bishop G3 and
yeah well
again where there's life There's Hope
right
three
that age part okay let's try to finish
the game somehow I know I mean yeah go
ahead all right let's go Bishop C5 right
yeah I'm going to try to take both of
your Rooks well this is actually a very
nice line too right yes precisely so
who's first wow it doesn't matter you're
gonna have to give up everything that's
okay
I'll have to do it uh H3 keep going H3
keep going
somewhere I run away from you
yeah but then you go f hey because I
hate queen look at this nobody said he's
going to be pretty
yeah one that's a lot of Pawns though
well
okay okay uh we'll keep an eye on this
one but let's go to the classical game
between uh Hikaru and Wesley because
that game is actually headed towards the
draw it looks like it's you know
accelerating as fast as possible which
is ironic because these two are the only
only ones and obviously in the open
section playing a classical game exactly
and they're the ones finishing first
right okay we did see this whole D4
business F6 we anticipated the F6 and
there was a massive uh uh trade trades
of and they just accelerated themselves
to this night upon an ending
and uh
yeah well I mean a draw really just
feels inevitable at this moment so not a
big not not a big attempt by uh Hikaru
today with the white pieces you know
what I reckon I think they're going to
decide it all in in tie breaks well when
we saw that graphic of how they match up
in classical uh Hikaru said I don't like
my chances in the classical let's let's
take it to the blitz we've seen them do
this countless times you know they
prefer to and here's the graphic that
yeah you can see Christian actually and
in the classical matchups you know when
these two play you can see that there's
been one win for Hikaru four victories
for Wesley so but in the rapid matchups
I mean so many so many drawers but also
a lot of points scored
I was about to say I mean you you have
these books you know the hundred best
games these two guys could write two
books based on Siobhan their all their
games and and I bet you they've been
really really good they're going to be
looking for a three-time repetition no
question about it let's jump back to the
game of Fabi and Lavon for just a moment
because our defending Champion
um was up a piece and let's see we left
it at Queen C2
we left it at Queen C2 King went back
Queen E5 Queen A4
wow I must say with this trade of queens
that kind of made things a little bit
easier I want to say for uh Fabi so A4
is that he's just trying to put the pawn
on
well on B5 like Rook day C4 what what do
you do author
I was about to say Rook takes E4
certainly has my attention what I mean
that was the first movie
also pawns can you not just start
lifting your age Pawn okay he takes his
Pawn these guys are greedy yes yes they
see upon the snatch it yeah absolutely I
mean okay isn't it isn't it time
it's probably time to go yeah H4 is well
maybe you could be like super careful
that's what I'm thinking
protect your little guys
Rook before that might be a little bit
over but I was thinking like I can turn
the uh to turn my attention not B3 yeah
protecting the little guys it seems you
are also very greedy
[Laughter]
well she's been sitting uh beside me for
the last four or five days
it's really taking over it suddenly you
know I must capture the fawn
I don't know but that actually you
appeal to my base Instinct asset yeah so
yeah good no this is hopeless 30 seconds
I just wanted to make sure
just just just wanted to be you should
return the conversation yes exactly
somehow about B3 that's a great move
b2b3 uh protecting uh the little guys
this this looks like uh Bobby is
cruising he will win and let's see that
game with
um Sam and look at this uh H5 check Rook
F7 linear just picked right up Bishop G3
and Lanier said look give me that Rook
but okay this the game can continue
right after age four
uh we're up to date H4 yeah
you don't actually just to go back to
yes I don't think you should be if you
want to keep the game alive
yes then the pawns all fall and he's
reaching for his H1 as we expected him
to he has played H4 so can you take on
G3 what are you going to take with
if you take with the age point I think I
have check and then Rook H5 and that's
going to pick all the pawns up that is
the problem right you have to take with
the F Pawn I think yes it's a first move
it's a forced capture which is
but do you have a similar idea of being
able to I don't have the F5 Square for
my Rook to get to that g Pawn so that's
sort of a problem but the the pawns are
they're frozen yeah so we can just make
maybe make a beeline towards them I I
think that's a very good idea King C1
King C1 and if you go Rook to d8 to try
to stop me well then The Rook takes E6
Rook takes and now we're on the same
page about take that a pawn and run your
a pawn up the board take the E Pawn and
run the e-pawn up the board so King C1
an extra Rook this looks like curtains
for Sam Shanklin let's jump to the
ladies and how is uh tatapp doing we she
blundered upon out of the opening she's
fought her way back to this position
well she just captured the e-pawn that's
a good sign
rookie two capture the V3 one Pawn down
but uh
yes yeah that's a problem that's huge
also her time right now what is one
minute against four minutes for Naji
okay not encouraging
correct because she was facing Rook CA
check Queen takes F7 well there's Queen
takes Queen takes F7 and Rook C8 right
yeah yeah the question is what do I like
more the exchange or the Queen the queen
I think you like that that's the Queen
the queen just kind of
who is the lead player you you reminded
me of this Kanye West uh from the
pandemic uh you have a choice you have
to stay with your family your choice a
as you stay with your family for six
months and you can't leave the house B
the Queen the queen
give me the queen Rick Rook C8 check is
uh yeah what we're expecting
nice so she's paying for it yeah for
sure
um
and we do have uh not unexpected news of
Wesley and Hikaru repeating yes we're
expecting a draw to go and what happened
in etusha versus vegan I think we're
going to see a flurry of results
actually because
taking a look at the games I'm expecting
Fabiano and Levon to also end
oh look at Naji yeah capturing a pawn
but night at seven maybe
and uh here is the first result it was
indeed a draw between Hikaru Nakamura
and Wesley in their first classical
encounter
and so tomorrow they will trade colors
and they will do it all again and if the
match is still tied after two games then
we will see playoffs where time is gets
shortened they'll play with two 10
minutes plus five seconds and eventually
there will be a winner yeah I was about
to say that naji's move Queen takes G6
was so nice because it actually learned
it forced the the threat of Knight F7
mate forced tatv to bring her Rook back
and now when she played Rook CH she
actually even gained a further Tempo
against the rook and she's picking up
this Pawn on H6 so it's really curtains
for tatv here what was happening in
begum and
etusha whoa whoa whoa whoa uh White
suddenly well white got her Pawn back
well to begin with but look at this
beautiful night on C4
keeping that rook and whoa whoa whoa
down to her last night that's what it
looks like right three minutes to 19
seconds on the top of the board I can
just so the question remains how do you
H4 deliver the final blow H4 well to
accommodate the Knight that that that
makes sense well
yeah and we do hear that Naji has beaten
tattif it takes an early lead and this
leaves tatv in the next game she has to
win with the white pieces nothing for it
and G3 H4 G3 okay I mean I would be so
eager to play my Rook on D6 so that I
could attack that pawn on B6 but begum
is slow playing it she's driving the
knights back first and now about to play
Rook to D6 how big an advantage is this
for your pupil it seems to be a decisive
Advantage but this one is over Fabi has
taken the first game in his uh battle
with his close friend lebronia
and uh how is begum doing uh
Advantage right definitely Advantage
yeah that one seems to be a decisive
Advantage but it's not that easy to find
the final blow in the position right
why not you could try to continue
pushing the knights back Rook to D6 is
also an option
she's played it but you know she's
played it there's another piece playing
on the board the clock and take a look
at a tooth so she's got 30 seconds she
gets 10 second increment but it's very
difficult to defend this type of
position exactly but once again how do
you get to that B6 Pawn well you don't
need to do it immediately you just make
some random moves you can move your
Bishop right yeah this recalls to me the
game where uh Fabi doubled his Rooks on
the a file to defend upon on A6 yeah and
he definitely Rooks on the v file
seizing the defensive well Rook D3 I
like this this is a very nice and Simple
Plan let me play Rook to D7 trade one
pair of Rooks uh very clever to defend
against that threat and then bring the
other Rook to D6 Knight G6 to uh f8 but
there's nothing Rook D7 there's no good
Square for that night so perhaps Knight
to E5 Knight of C6 now yeah you go
backwards I go forwards I love that
expression by the way
every move has its consequences I love
Christian's idea
or maybe just you know slay a very
classical game and do what every single
coach tells you to do in the end games
the coaches the king in the center King
is an important piece in the end game
use your you remember those uh type of
advice devices no I never got this stuff
I mean I I got stuck with pawns don't
move backwards
I didn't get beyond that one that was
tough uh King King G2 it makes sense
because Brad doesn't have any moves
right wow okay uh yeah this kind of slow
plays I mean again I would be like can't
I play Rook C6 and Rook D6 but I guess
the idea of giving the night free
passage to C5 is she's going for that C6
Square not bad Knights love Outpost
protected with squares
I like that move okay uh we'll we'll
keep an eye on this one and I just
wanted to check with Arena and Alice
because yes I think we should stay with
this one just because there's only a few
minutes left in this one and okay
irina's will go on for a while and I am
expecting actually some
to resign pretty soon I mean lenya has
found a very good way to neutralize the
advance of the pawns what did you do I
think some might have resigned
King season
no never mind
no pawns are still the ponds are still
marching
the capabilities that's the problem and
I'm expecting uh is Lanier by the way in
its habitual time travel
yes he's under a minute
did you have to ask that question yes
exactly but Rook to G5 wait a minute
there's isn't there some cheaper
potential here for Sam H3 Rook takes G3
H2 I don't think linear likes this
I wasn't expecting that I was expecting
him to move his work to E3 and then you
know just continue with C Pawn he should
put his Rook to e uh for I think uh yes
E4 you cannot play H3 anymore because I
take and then go Rook to E1 exactly that
and also maybe Christian's rule the
chicken in the middle of the board put
your king in the middle okay the king is
coming in after H3
H3 ah so the idea is that after age two
we just go Rook H1 ah
no G2 for you no not today yes
no no Jam I actually saw we saw the cafe
by the way no soup for you
uh King E3 in that case that is
absolutely uh smashing that is just a
very very good move the pawns are frozen
next turn King G4 pawns are completely
Frozen and we're a rook ahead expecting
resignation coming up
uh shortly definitely some less than a
minute on the clock
and nothing really to do on the board
apart from maybe move his King but great
defense from linear Dominguez
nice nice very nice
and uh let's go back to the game of
begum for just a moment because that's
this game really feels like
there's a lot going on here I mean the
other game uh
we just what the night did get to C6
this is where we left it and I got the
C6
and it's all about the time though right
now right so 40 seconds for peg game
against 17 seconds for atusa atusa has
been
on very few seconds for a very long time
now
okay my game decides to exchange one
pair of groups well especially get the
king yeah I was about to say especially
now with one pair of Rooks off the
chances of some some massive accident
happening to the king is no longer there
I would love to I think she's just going
forward going for the age Pawn she wants
to take that pawn you you must be proud
yeah I'm proud I don't know about
Christian but I know I'm proud I I I
don't know about not playing without the
king but
[Music]
isn't that one of those Immortal pins
where you never get out
or to d8 not only that but look to B8 is
coming exactly that as well oh I like
that no I mean forget about your H Pawn
I'm not no longer tempted I like this uh
beep on much more and the Sea and uh
okay she's reaching
for sure the rook and I am for sure
she's going to play Rook d8 no she's no
agreed for a lack of a better word it's
good man's noblest emotion
Rook takes H but F6 and etusha says well
maybe I I have to get back yeah here I
don't like allowing Rook to be a
vegetable to D7
and by the way Lanier has won his game
yes
Bishop to D6
from going Knight to E5 I think this was
a master plan try to go to E5 that is
such a powerful looking Bishop I mean it
just radiates energy on all the
diagonals from the c85 yep and now the
problem is oh no 97 97 Shaq is forking
this might be the game yeah that's a
clincher that's a clincher 97 check well
fork and there goes the Rook
a simple Retreat of the bishop open up
the defile get to d8 Knight and that's
it okay
I mean isn't the king just completely
stuck in a cage
there's no way out this is it this looks
this is overwhelming
overwhelming forbidden and that means
atusa will be forced
to win the next game exactly continue
the playoffs she's got her back to the
wall as well
and
Let's uh check out the results so far
well it was a decisive day bloody
rounded me Elimination
it was like a free-fall but here wow
hikara Nakamura and wesiso did start the
classical match with a draw tap it drop
yes but uh we'll see what happens
tomorrow when they face off against each
other in the decider and then between
Naji paikitsu and tatif abrahamian that
ended in a decisive result for Naji
tatev in a must win situation it's also
a must-win situation for
to serve percussion who lost
okay and also Fabiana carwana
made a rather convincing game I have to
say against Levon aronian and to start
off his quest to stay alive in the
elimination bracket and also there we
see lenia Dominguez who's also
Victorious against Sam Shanklin Sam
Shanklin now in a must win situation if
he wants to continue playing in the
tournament I think he wants and yeah
well everyone wasn't finally they came
toko's Genova she won against atusa
percussion and wow what a start to day
five yeah it sure is and as we get ready
for break uh what are our friends at Q
Boutique on offer what are you going to
show me yeah are you ready
the eye candy on the show here of cold
beverages go perfectly with this 32
ounce tumbler featuring the official St
Louis chesco
side yeah very nice and the American Cup
on the other side yep beautiful tumbler
and it's available now exclusively at Q
Boutique stl.com perfect and we're going
to see you on the other side of the
break
but before we go we've got to tell our
viewers what they can expect we asked
our we asked the players uh beforehand
how do you like this new format I said I
love it me too
the American Cup is played under a
unique and exciting double elimination
format what is fun about it in Europe
actually this is my first time here I
changed my Federation like couple of
months ago so this is a like new thing
to me and I'm looking forward to it this
is a very interesting event it's kind of
different event I would say the format
is different and also even the time
control I do really like the format it's
a lot of fun and I think the players
also enjoy that it has different time
controls it's not just classical chess
oh I like this tournament knockout
system I think it's like very first
Spectators It's a Wonderful system it's
more interesting than around robin
tournament every game is very important
and for spectators I think it's it's
it's more interesting format for us also
I like something different I'm quite
excited to play in the American Cup I've
never played in this type of tournament
before where we have mix of classical
and Rapid how I like it I guess that
depends on how I do
so I will tell you that after the
tournament yeah so I think certainly the
world has changed a lot in terms of
Chess over the last couple of years a
lot of people in terms of the fans they
want to see quicker chess tournaments
that don't go as long as they have
traditionally so when you have a match
format I think this is a little bit of a
template similar to the feed a World Cup
which is an event that's held similarly
where you have two game matches you have
Knockouts and you have an ultimate
winner and I think that when you have a
format like this where you do have a
winner at the end of the day and even if
it's after a couple of days of play
nonetheless you have someone winning
when they're playing head to head that's
certainly more favorable and I think the
fans like that so I'm pretty optimistic
about the format I think it should be a
great show for everyone I really enjoy
formats like this where you mix
classical just rapid chest and even if
it gets their Blitz chest because it's
like three kind of different skill sets
that a player has to have well I'm a
huge proponent of knockout style
tournaments in general I think that's
absolutely the best way to run any
individual sport uh just included and so
I'm delighted to be playing this
knockout event uh my big dream would be
four game classical matches and knockout
because this one does tilt quite a bit
towards Rapid and then once you've lost
you start playing rapid very quickly for
that but uh yeah I'm a huge proponent of
knockout events and I'm very very happy
to see that you know the the best chess
club in the world is is hosting knockout
events now you know now the second year
in a row and I hope it continues to be a
tradition yeah well this is my second
time playing in it and I think last year
I was pretty confused about the format
uh now I have a better idea of what it's
about
um and I enjoyed it last year yeah it's
a fun format double elimination the nice
thing is that there's a second chance so
if someone has a moment of of weakness
or an accident that happens in one of
their games there's still a second
chance like a chance of redemption let's
say it's even stronger than last year
last year he covered didn't play and now
he's he's joining and so all the best
chess players in the United States are
playing it's a genuine super tournament
I really enjoyed playing in this
tournament last year it was a lot of fun
I like the double elimination at the
World Cup which is a single elimination
and it's kind of said he lives early on
and then you have to live and go home so
I like the fact that everyone still gets
a second chance I really like the format
I think it's a it's a very interesting
format that you have a chance to come
back to the tournament after being
knocked out and the field is extremely
strong I'm happy that Hikaru is playing
this year it's always nice to see him
for me this is a kind of a special
tournament uh
for the first time I'm
playing tournaments and staying in my
house you know in St Louis
this is something that I really missed
because I think last time I stayed in my
house and played and played the
classical tournament I was 19. so
it's a special field well I kind of like
the global elimination format it's been
it's become very popular lately online
also I just finished a tournament Berlin
also's double elimination so I like the
idea that it has two lives
that each player gets two lives
um then you get another chance and I
also like the match format I'm very
excited about this format that's my
favorite thing about American Cup
because I like that we play a match this
bracket and double elimination uh format
it's it's very exciting for us players
because we get to play one player twice
and really kind of measure our strength
with that one player and if it doesn't
work out we still have like uh you know
recovery uh that we can still get back
to the tournament compared to other
tournaments where you always play uh you
know one person just like with one color
and it takes forever here if you are in
good shape like just go go no one is
stopping you and if you are not then the
tournament is over so I think it's nice
for no matter what your uh current shape
this is the only tournament I've ever
played in with this format and I really
like it because
um I think that classical chess is
definitely like a great part of like
determining
um the result of matches based on
playing instruments but rapid chest is
like super exciting to watch for General
audience it's also very strong it's kind
of like the US Championship but with the
strongest possible players and
personally for me it's uh it's kind of
like the start of the season because I
took a long break from playing classical
chess so my last tournament was the U.S
Championship which was back in October
like ages ago it feels like so this is
uh the first time that I'll be playing
classical which is nice and I'm really
looking forward to it I was looking
forward for this tournament to be honest
I love it double mentioned a lot of like
exciting moments a lot of
fun to have around and I I just like
this tournament in general it's just
like two chances and different formats
and four months in one tournament which
is great so this is one of my favorite
tournaments actually
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
we are back and fire on the board
already as we begin all the action on
day five I I feel like we've seen the
whole days of action we've got more
coming but in the Champions bracket we
know our result we do have a result in
the Champions bracket it was a very
quick draw in the first match first game
Sorry between Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley
so but where the fireworks were missing
in this game they sure happened in the
elimination bracket games didn't they I
think the other players are just leaving
it for tomorrow but in the elimination
bracket today is Do or Die day today is
where they have to bring everything to
the table and Fabiana caruana certainly
surprised nevon aronian and just blew
him off the boards to take an early lead
as did Dominguez against Sam shankland
now aronian and Sam shanken will be
playing with the white pieces and they
are in a must win situation if they want
to continue and those games will
actually begin in half an hour all right
and in the uh Champions bracket for the
ladies in the Champions Bank kids once
they're still an ongoing game absolutely
Dale definitely
tense between Arena crash playing with
the white pieces against 13 year old
Alice Lee we will find out the outcome
outcome later on today but in the
elimination bracket where the players
are of course playing at a much faster
time control of 25 minutes plus 10
seconds it was again Blood on the board
and it was a decisive round for the
white pieces Nazi paikitsa convincing
defeated tartev abrahamian with the
white pieces tattered now in a must-win
situation if she wants to survive and
cook to hear jonova against a two
separation was also a victory for the
white pieces and a Tusa is the game in
that must win situation wow so in the
Elimination Brackets it's been a
whitewash four games four victories for
the white pieces yes and there wow okay
so uh
and Christian during the break I saw
that bag of one of those last little uh
minute of advice uh what did you tell I
never get a break right no yeah of
course she she she came she wanted to
know what she should play because we had
some strategy nevertheless it very much
depending on what she was doing the
first game right what the result will be
in the first game and to be honest with
you we didn't have that much time to
look at the openings with the black
pieces early on in the morning because
you know time is very very limited but
uh we did have some ideas and I'm not
going to tell you anything because who
knows maybe somebody's watching the show
and we but we did get to watch uh and
remind ourselves of some ideas that we
looked at earlier in the tournament and
hopefully those will come on at the
board for her but now she's back to her
hotel with her laptop and maybe she's
going to come with some interesting
ideas well let's jump to number one
versus number two in the women's bracket
as Arena Crush in my opinion has got
almost the absolute ideal that you want
out of the situation I'm gonna bring the
game back not to the live position but
to the position after move 11. so in my
opinion Arena has done everything like
perfectly like just great this bishop on
C4 is nicely defended by The Pawn on D3
this Pawn on D5 is an extra Pawn first
of all and it's really cramping uh
Alice's pieces
to my mind you play the move Bishop E3
automatically here and you're not afraid
of the night coming and capturing this
bishop it's sort of like now you're a
good Pawn up and you're threatening the
pawn on B6 I just love this move Bishop
E3 and I don't understand her move d4
the move d4 actually
weakens whites control of the bishop and
really uh I didn't see the move Knight
E5 as a threat Arena had different ideas
and Alice said well actually I don't
like my position I really don't and I'm
going to break out and I'm going to play
the move B5 a b Knight B6 on the board
now again if the pawn were on D3 you
know you would be very happy to capture
this pawn and the bishop would be
defended Knight B6 on the board and I
think we're up to date now with the
players uh I'm assuming and it seems
like Alice actually equalized this
position because of that move d4 that
was such a bad move yes yeah it was
because her prep up to this moment has
been ideal help me out here
um it's all about the defense of that
Pawn C4 right yep yeah it's nicely
semantic there you're going to attack it
with the move Knight to B6 later on
after you sacrifice the pawn with P5
right but that attack is not going to
come with any consequences because my
Pawn on D3 is beautifully protecting the
bishop on C4 for a long time exactly and
and because of the move d4 B5 you said
that Alice is equalized and now she she
goes with Knight to B6 first don't take
on a B5 first that would be a worse
version right but first attack the
bishop Target that bishop and yeah
equalized I don't understand that
because surely you can put your Bishop
back to D3 okay and just say
you know hey hey ho Rook takes work yeah
let's keep going and do I want to take
with the queen or do I want to take
in order to take with the queen for
business reasons
business not pleasure yes yeah well
Bishop D3 is on the board position D3
and go ahead yeah I'm just saying grab
the pawn with
yeah I think the bishop okay let's take
with the Knight okay and now we
understand what uh business is all about
how do you defend is the question that
that's a G2 do you go F3 that's going to
weak on your position even more yeah
this is one of those
great compensation very safe King once
you see the move f2f3 you kind of say to
yourself okay I can see why black is not
suffering here
your extra Pawn is literally on B2 and
that's a long way from
being consequentially
advantageous yeah
so this is this is uh well Alice seized
her her chance oh she did indeed yeah
you you questioned uh Queen takes d8
because you're thinking maybe the the
queen should remain centralized uh
Christians I was thinking about that but
the more I look at what you're showing
me yeah sorry it just feels like Queen
288 is is the right solution not only
that you're setting up this battery but
also with this Pawn on D4 Now The Rook
coming to d8 that's going to create some
have on the D5 right right Queen is on
D1 I have the potential of playing the
move E5 as well so by the way we might
be going straight into that variation
right now
well I didn't want to use my Jedi Mind
Tricks on you there today I mean if you
were sure Bishop takes A8 was a better
but I like it I like what you're doing
yes sir I really like what you think
okay okay
uh yeah we're expecting Queen takes A8
but all right and both of them are very
similarings right Bishop takes a eight
Queen takes A8 are more or less similar
but just from a visual perspective it
feels like Queen takes a eight is uh the
stronger and more natural option
sometimes you have to play Beautiful
chess yeah and then when they say A8 is
the beautiful move yeah in this case
you're kind of making room for The Rook
The Rook it's fine on f8 but you want it
to have a much more active role I like
the idea of Rook Rook to f8 and in this
line where you were mentioning that even
there's the possibility of E5 thanks to
the fact that the Rook has already
facing off against White's queen I'm
looking at the positions and I'm asking
myself who's actually better right now
um when black manages to win backed upon
on D5 and
have active play that's where our Karo
Khan players Rejoice you know it's like
yes safe King we've got our Fortress and
we've got active play we're happy notice
that Alice is actually taking her time
here as this recapture
both recaptures are actually really
tempting uh your first instinct by the
way my first instinct is the same as
yours I think it's actually quite my
position for black but I you know I just
wanted to check you know because why
people at home will be asking well hang
on a second why does it porn up porn is
Pawn right and it's not always not all
pawns are created equal that is very
true there's Pawn on B2 is not I mean if
that pawn was was shifted and it was
sitting on a you know Square light E3
we'd all be talking like clear Advantage
no no doubts about it
and it's difficult for work to unravel
like even in this type of position
because obviously Knight takes night is
in the yes you have to probably do
something about that tension right and
probably by capturing it in fact on D5
yeah yeah and probably most tempted I
mean Bishop takes D5 we understand you
know you're hitting but the Knight on B6
will then ask yeah but coach I'm not in
the game when I'm sitting on V6 sitting
on D5 feels a lot happier you're
preaching to the choir yeah exactly
Knight C7 Bishop takes G2 still it's
looking pretty pretty good for Alice as
that move d4 really did throw away a lot
of Arenas advantage in my view
sorry I think you're not uh
wired up there uh Christian
you need to plug yourself in
try again let's let's there you go okay
yeah all right nothing personal I just
happen to have this little switch
[Laughter]
you're doing great I know what you did I
see I see I see how it is okay go ahead
sorry repeat yourself we missed it well
I think I forgot my train of thought but
I was talking about the position as
being probably the the best version uh
for Alice that she's had since the
beginning of the game she was under
tremendous pressure after the opening I
have to say Arena came up with some very
intriguing ideas but this D4 just simply
spoiled the advantage exactly
so no Queen takes let's go Queen takes a
that's that's the natural move Alice
yeah you should think about it and you
can see also on the clock if I'm not
mistaken Irena was quite a bit ahead on
the on the clock previously but after
she played this move d4 and B5 came on
the board Knight to B6 she started
understanding that her position is not
as good anymore right yeah and we've
been looking at the idea of like Queen
takes work Bishop takes porn but you
know
with the bishop Knight takes D5 we
exchange yeah we've looked at that but
you know it's also possible to capture
the pawn with a knight you can yes let's
say from this position uh so Queen takes
A8 is the most appealing yes and then
you were you're saying that in this
particular moment we can also capture
with the Knight right again it's a bit
weird I'll give you that because you're
capturing away from Santa even what's
tonight doing fell players will would
love to play Knight on F6 takes D4 in
order to open up the bishop I on the
other hand is a Karo Khan player you
know we'll probably play Knight on B6
takes D5 because I'm thinking the Knight
on B6 is not well placed on the B6
square and he's looking to go to the B4
square and open up this diagonal and how
about the Knight on F6 or are you going
to put that or you're not worried about
it yeah
this moment the kind of the jury's out
I'm not 100 sure that
well first of all if I open up the
diagonal I I'll have a square right I'll
have some choices but uh for the moment
uh this one would be so there's no
immediate threat after Knight takes D5
I'm not forced to play the move F3 but
what is the active plan for white in the
position yeah I would say my let's go
Queen B3 Queen B3 I really don't like to
see that Knight landing on B4 I
understand why you want to see it there
so I'm going to start with Queen to B3
right
okay Rook to d8 just to uh bring more
invite everybody to the party yes
I was going to say more peace and
Harmony to the board right but not
really
[Laughter]
yes only for black
um
and by the way as we wait for this
recapture uh just an announcement we
made it yesterday but there is a special
Blitz tournament coming up it's very
special you know nine Blitz rounds no
draw offers a Time control of three
minutes plus two seconds and get this it
will include players from local
universities and eliminated American Cup
participants now if you think you're
gonna rock up you know it's going to be
an easy ride yeah
we absolutely not I mean the local
University players like seriously some
of the best in the world and some of the
best youngsters in the world as well
exactly and there will be 40 players uh
playing this Sunday March 26th so if
you're anywhere near St Louis that's the
place you're going to want to
uh B and we have Christian with a very
special guest
Colin first of all welcome to St Louis
welcome to the St Louis chess club and
the American copy you opened the show
for us how was uh that experience for
you I was very fun uh ring ring the bell
uh starting the game you came from
California it was a long trip for you
who is your favorite player here uh the
same with just up we're hearing that
you're a big chess fan yeah probably
Hikaru just because I like watching his
streams uh but I played a game against
LeBron and he was really nice so that
was fun did you get to interact with any
of the players I saw that you were
chatting with Lanier Dominguez talking
with a couple before the game yeah tell
us a bit about your style you play a lot
as well are you more of a tactical
player more of a strategical player how
would you describe it
definitely
uh
uh tactical player yeah I
I'm I'm not I'm not the best
but I try
absolutely guys any questions for uh
Colin yeah I have a question yeah I just
want to know what is your favorite
opening card in
uh probably the first one I learned the
rui Lopez oh okay any nice tricks you've
learned
um
any tricks in the real Lopez uh
not not really and what's your favorite
opening with the black pieces let's say
I open up with one D4 what would you do
after that uh I usually play the England
Gambit against that
E4 I play
um that's a streamer's opening what
that's a streamer's opening a YouTube
twitch all of those things it's a fun
opening to play a lot of uh a lot of
tactical nuances right yeah yeah sir I
think you were about to say college you
play the karaoke
were you about to say that you played
the Karo Khan yeah against C4 I play the
car you play the caracon excellent thank
you welcome to the club Colin man after
my own heart well well well done
um who's your favorite in the uh you
said Hikaru uh in this American Cup
in the American Cup who's your favorite
player let's say outside who do you
expect to win you like it who do you
expect to win expect to win
um
I want to say Fabiano he's
he's just he's really good they're all
really good though
uh Wesley sews also
one of the top ones in the tournament
and did you manage to see to catch some
some of the moments from yesterday's
match between Wesley and Fabi
uh yeah yeah it was uh very interesting
I was watching most of the games on the
on YouTube yeah yeah that was uh that
was definitely a fun match guys any more
questions yeah just one I I I've just
got to ask it uh you honor us Colin by
in your make a wish wish uh to be here
in St Louis and to be uh in the Chess
World you could have chosen anything in
the world you're gonna run back a NFL uh
touchdown if you had wanted but this is
this was your wish why
uh
I've always been really interesting
really interested in chess uh and
watching all the professional games I
just like to see how the best people
play
and
I mean
I've been to Hawaii
so yeah yeah so you might as well come
to St Louis
I love it I love it Colin before uh we
let you go we do have a gift from the
Saint Louis chess club we have the
American jacket American Cup jacket for
you this is reserved only for the
players it's not up for sale but you get
one thank you so much lovely uh bring
the jacket with you for dinner tonight
and we'll get all the players to sign
the sleeves oh nice yeah that's what I'm
talking yeah they're really really nice
we'll see you later at the dinner
tonight Colin thank you absolutely thank
you Colin wow yeah make a wish make a
wish a big big big thanks to that
Foundation because of all of the great
things that they do uh this is very
special it's it's wonderful it is
wonderful and uh you know just to give
Hope just to give laughter smiles to
everyone actually because it's such a
beautiful thing you know exactly yeah
Colin wanted to play a chess and who
wants to see the best players in America
coincidentally the world
I love the fact that in the in this
American Cup we have amateur playing
happens
five in the world
yeah exactly we have a bunch of locals
right you know just local residents they
didn't have anything better to do so
shut up
the locals you know you just pick them
out of the Starbucks amateurs amateurs
and by the way for those of you who
would like to join our show they can't
tell them how they can join yeah we love
it when everyone
interacts with us asks us questions and
just sends just shares with us their
thoughts and you can do all this by
tweeting us using the hashtag the
American Cup and uh we'll try to answer
your questions and maybe feature them on
the show excellent ask the commentators
indeed and after some hesitation uh
let's be frank Alice was a little bit
unsure she did play Queen takes A8
Bishop takes B5 and like a good grunfeld
player played Knight on F6 takes D5
certainly this warmed Your Heart
Christian oh yes the bishop on G7 is
immediately introduced introduced and
after a rook to d8 reinforcing the
attack on the pawn on D4 the newly
created weakness by your own hands as
white that pawn on D4 that pawn should
have stayed on D3 right uh tell us the
evaluation and it's very balanced okay
it's very balanced but I'm not looking
that much at the engine evaluation
because this is just such a human
position right and to be honest from
Black's perspective I just feel more
comfortable with the white pieces I'm
not 100 sure what to touch do I want to
defend that pawn on G2 with Knight takes
D5 and not alone I take C3 do I want to
play F3 but that's going to weaken my
position even uh more so do I want to
play G3 open up the long diagonal that I
would I would like to play that moment
right for sure even if you cannot take
advantage immediately with like Knight
xc3 and maybe bishop to G2 because I
have or Bishop to H1 because I have F3
I don't know it doesn't look good yeah
Knight to F4 I still have that idea and
maybe I somehow survive but it just
doesn't look like a pleasant position to
play yeah they may revoke your coaching
license
I would never touch that pawn I will
also never touched that pawn however
however however
yeah it's looking better than the other
Alternatives that we've seen like like
F3 just looks yeah it's an ugly looking
move because you give up all the dark
squares and yeah but that's what I'm
sorry
after G3 just taking and we've looked at
night wage one but sorry Bishop to H1
take on C3 take on C3 take on C3 I would
be happy then because you corrected my
Pawn structure and now Bishop to G2
isn't that just winning a pawn at least
yeah now you take Knight F4 you get the
Knight to F4 but at least I restored the
material
whoa Jovi isn't done with you yet oh
whoa
that's a bit aggressive
exactly you guys get back here
uh yeah no I mean I see your point no I
mean my point was if G3 I think ugly I I
would be I wouldn't play it right unless
you you know it was the last resort but
you know having said that you know if
you can like tuck your King on H2 and
here's my problem Jeffy when you play a
move like G3 and your Bishop's not being
shadowed there all I want to do is hunt
down your light squared bishop and I
will say yeah maybe I don't mate you or
win material and the immediacy but short
term you know long term pardon me you
know the fact that I'm going to take
this bishop I'm going to play one day
Bishop G2 and do something nasty yeah
I agree with that but then then but then
we're looking at Alternatives like
Knight takes nights yes and I think
that's where we're going actually
probably I would probably include that
move and then Knight takes and then but
we're looking at these three if you play
Bishop takes
at least I've I've sidestepped both G3
and F3 at least temporarily but uh I
must say if you play Knight takes I'm
still kind of unsure
I would be happy at all no no you're
right uh you're simply right there
Christian it's easier to play Black and
in this case the times is that a factor
uh not really not yet at least 48
minutes for Irina Crush when and we
haven't seen either of these players
actually uh get trouble time travel yes
but they haven't been troubled by the
clock exactly now I think at this point
with the white pieces yes you just have
to ask yourself how do I pull the brakes
yes exactly and we're talking about this
pulling the brakes right quite often
what I mean by that is how do I manage
to exchange more pieces go towards an
end game maybe give my extra Pawn back
in the process but simplify the position
how do I simplify the position 1965 we
have to
yeah I agree with that but then I was
stuck on this point because Point Way
four let's continue
[Music]
how can I forget this
handbook you know the Jovi's chess
handbook the Golden Rule when your
King's being attacked trade the Queens
off the board that's that's the best
that's the best thing that I've heard
this tournament yeah it's a good one
it's a good one and it's still valid
after all of these years Queen A4
I like it why not and this place the
queen from this dangerous that's so
obvious right once you see
I'm in trouble
I think she's going for it yeah she's
good she's gonna go we've seen Knight
takes D5 now was she hovering yeah
Irina doesn't hover that much right
right no she goes whenever she sees the
move she plays it now you probably don't
want to take with a bishop right because
that allows Knight to F4 well that's
actually you know the moment you were
saying that and there was this hovering
Bishop takes Knight to F4 I get it I get
it it's it's it's
ugly that I'm giving up my light squared
Bishop but after Rook d8 maybe she maybe
Alice just wins her Pond back cleanly
Bishop to E3 Bishop to E3 E5 I really
don't want to give you that pawn but I
might have I was hoping that you would
take and allow Bishop takes G2 kind of
tactics but even though but even that is
super awesome you can take the knights
what do you think back yeah I I I I
think I I think I uh messed up I I takes
it and then Bishop takes Knight and if I
take your queen I'm the one facing
issues with Knight takes G2 as well as
Rook d8 I think I blowed it there that
was not good that was not good of me
apologies no but still I mean maybe not
the five right after Bishop E3 perhaps
just Knight C4 or something like that or
yeah let me conserve my Bishop if or if
I'm gonna conserve it Bishop to E4 right
and try to play for that E5 move yeah
yeah look there must be ways yes in
which black contains are enabled yes for
sure the finality of your compensation
and that is to take the pawn back and
restore the material balance and Jovi
for those of uh who have been joining us
late we've already played one
elimination game today uh the first
rapid I mean to say and the second rapid
is coming up shortly is that right it's
coming up and
three three o'clock for us but 3 30 and
here it comes here is the elimination
bracket well that is everything to play
for we're about six minutes away okay
we've been told and okay some people are
in master situations everybody
yeah well some people more than others
more people and we can see
did win her first round game against
abrahamian and so Tata abrahamian is in
a must-win situation she will play with
the white pieces so that's in her favor
and also in the matchup between talkin
Genova and percussion it was talking
Genova who managed to win and so it is a
tutor percussion who is in a most win
situation she needs to win she will also
play with the white pieces and in the
open elimination bracket and
or maybe we'll do the Champions bracket
because they actually finished their
game that's true too
um Quick Draw between
um Wesley and uh Cairo today but this is
the elimination bracket yeah and uh
today was as yes I said a white wash
because Fabiana Carona with the white
piece is utterly destroyed LeBron
aronian so he has a point lead and then
he Dominguez did exactly the same to Sam
shankland so Sam Shanklin and Levon
aronian need to win to stay alive in
this competition if they lose if they
draw that's it they are out and I wanted
to again for those players who joined us
late I really wanted to take a look uh
at one specific moment when Fabi and
Lavon cross swords today because it was
a it was a very sharp
um floor mechanism line of the English
where Lavon
courageously went uh G5 and then after
Queen A4
we were expecting this move H5
you said that this move might have given
Lavon a winning position he literally
went
to a lost position in three moves that
is right and he played it very fast also
right and queen A4 he had set this trap
up beautifully
in like a few seconds but this is the
problem when you play these sharp
positions you know you live by the sword
you die by the sword you need to know
every single Nuance exactly and you
can't be like automatically playing
with the hand Bishop G7 you have to kind
of having said push
it just forgot about it I think he he
just forgot his theory probably Bishop
G7 was happening in one of the
variations that he calculated or that he
chose during his preparation he saw
quintway for confused it with what he
looked at and played the move Bishop to
G7 now there's an idea behind this move
Queen to A4 if you do go H5 yeah and I
do think that this is what Fabi would
have done he would have played the move
E6 E6 I think so yes wow and this is
perhaps why Levon played the move Bishop
to G7 now you might be looking at this
and say like this just looks like a pawn
sacrifice but if you do take I play
Bishop to E5 I'm emptying that square
for my bishop and finally taking
advantage of the fact that the Knight on
C6 is pinned by my last move Queen to A4
so perhaps this is what uh Fabiano had
in store against H5 still I have to say
I'm Bishop G7 just play it in a couple
of seconds and after that you're in more
or less almost a losing position it's
just it doesn't feel like LaVon right
right one of the nice you were showing
as if you don't mind one of those nice
variations where I the desirable H4 just
got destroyed oh yeah if if H4 comes on
the board after H5 and you're you're
sure you should show the audience who
was late uh to our show that's right so
H4 I just simply take right now all I'm
also taking advantage of the fact that
my queen on d8 is going to be supported
on this diagonal the dhh4 diagonal by my
Bishop on f8 the bishop is not yet on G7
so I have the option of potentially
getting it to E7 with the move Bishop to
E7 that's going to kick the Knight away
after that I'm going to go H4 and take a
look at this variation Knight to F5
looks beautiful maybe uh storm around my
king with Knight to G7 nice check you
can take my my two Bishops as well but
take a look at this let's say you give
you take take and then you move and then
I go H3 then you're like okay I don't
want to see any age to HD2 any opening
of the H file and I go G3 whoops H2
that's a checkmate with a pawn because
of this what I called a force of nature
the bishop on D5 beautifully centralized
on the light squares controlling this
whole uh long diagonal this one is just
uh beautiful it's a beautiful mechanism
how to break White's position in this
instance so yes H5 that was the money
move he did not play it he did not play
the move H5 he played the move Bishop to
G7 after that he just found himself in
deep deep trouble yeah so but you know
we love the players of their great
understanding their great preparation
but their files are so intense Jovi one
slip or mislip and we suspect that's
what what Lavon did in this particular
case he kind of hot Fabby but then not
only did he let him go he in turn fell
in the Trap as the players get ready for
their elimination okay talking about
elimination it is game two of the
elimination bracket and we see Tata and
Naji getting ready tatev in a must-win
situation with the white piece is
basically everyone playing with the
white pieces in the elimination packet
has to win I was about to say the black
leather look at that leather dangerous
no no none of this white leather
Letterman's jackets I mean he brought
his uh hog is Harley to the game is
feeling dangerous today that's for sure
by the way I mean I know where all
veterans and stuff like that you still
get the butterflies in your stomach
right yeah like all the time on these
elimination games you can't you know
you're alive I feel sadness actually
when I see the players leave because you
know you are attached to these players
and their personalities they've come to
the studio and eliminated yeah and yeah
exactly and I don't like to see them
leave somehow I think it's a little bit
on
but at the same time makes for great
entertainment it is it is and in the
words of that gladiator I've gotten his
name Maximus are you not entertained
I love it Russell Crowe yeah go call him
by his name right Maximus there we have
a Chris a bird
and by the way we saw family but then he
just kind of rushed to the players area
probably wanted to get himself a coffee
or something as Chris bird you know
looking at his watch
uh he's not happy he's ready he's ready
Chop Chop let's go he's ready to start
the game
yeah well something
everybody else has got to go let's get
started but I mean
okay Bobby somehow I suspected Fabi was
like a tea person
he's a tea person but I think maybe not
in the rapid game
okay picked his water I need
yeah
Jovi yeah come to my rescue please what
am I supposed to be doing ah e45 okay
clicked yes
I don't know how I always okay
so they're off again Lavon needs a win
as weight he's uh
rule Royal Lopez Colin's favorite
perhaps he's taking some inspiration
from yesterday's match between Wesley
and Fabi because Wesley chose a similar
path to try to take the advantage out of
the opening against Fabi and he
succeeded in doing so yeah
I mean is this wise to repeat the same
line
there's a roommate and lost yesterday
there is a wrinkle I believe Wesley went
Castle first instead of D3
so he went directly with castle and
after that defended that pawn on e4 in a
different manner
now we see this D3 move D5 Bishop to B3
Bishop to sorry yes you have the
position right now on the board I think
I need to figure out how to minimize my
uh screen here
the analysis board is not perfectly and
that was the that was the question I and
they always have to ask is D5 playable
in those positions but uh
Bobby says no no no I'm going to follow
it up with this by the way this was
played yesterday because this is the
exact same position yes it was exactly
the same H6 Bishop takes F6 this is how
uh Wesley not yet I think it was A4
Bishop B7 first yes and then Bishop G5
take on F6 and Bishop to D5 to set up
that and people understand corrected I
think you were right A4 Bishop B7 Bishop
G5 is how Wesley got here so we have a
different game right now because after
age six he decided a guest Bishop takes
F6 but with Bishop to H4 maintaining
that pin and big moment right now when
you play G5 yeah that's the top move and
according to my understanding of this
particular variation you you go for it
right it's that kind of combative
opening you know you don't want to shy
away from those big decisions go for it
G5 but this is isn't this also what uh
yeah yeah and without hesitation Bishop
G3 no peace sacrifices for you
uh we we've all been on both sides of
those peace sacrifices but G5 Bishop G3
very very quickly Lavon I think is still
in his prep
and after
yeah that came just a second a 4K no uh
Bishop B6 A4 yeah and we're up to date
with the players now and uh still we are
in the Realms of theory not the most
highly played Theory I have to say but
the most popular move according to this
database
even Bishop D7 is is had a punter to
Rook B8 was the move chosen by Fabi
followed by Knight of dito immediately
responded by Lavon Knight aha that's
that's a little bit surprising because
in conjunction with the move A4 somehow
I I had it in my mind that he was going
to go a b a b night to A3 and maybe
start to swing it around to the night
around towards the F5 Square Knight D2
right away ninth wage seven Fabiano is
looking for something the question is
what is it King to G7 followed by F5 or
is it H5 H5 is an option as well
wow Knight to H7 okay we're the the
players are still in theory let's jump
to the game of Sam shankland and Lanier
as we know Sam is in a similar boat he
needs to win if he wants to stay in in
the tournament and of course we have a
Petrov on the board with 3d4 let's see
what Sam Shanklin has prepped for his
match uh game with Lanier all pretty
standard stuff Knight takes C3 is by far
the most popular move in these positions
this exact position and I tell you the
Petrov or the Russian defense if you
prefer
um is still giving white E4 players
headaches pissed off me is wow okay I
think it's a good choice Again Sam I
don't think it would have come as a
surprise I have to say oh
yes no that's Sammy on 26 minutes one
minute more than what he started with
and the linear on 21 minutes right yeah
I'm trying to find the ladies yeah not
successfully I must say not successfully
Arena Crush I'm just gonna take a quick
Gander at that well it's being very slow
played at this exact moment feels like
player still oh we do have Knight F4
interesting what happened I mean she
took with the Knight takes nights we
made the decision to take for the bishop
and Bishop so mature and I know she's
just 13 years old
wow but just to kind of resist
temptation right and not automatically
recapture in the center and then you
know make sure that everything is
correct that that's what I was saying
yesterday I think it's so unfair you're
13 years old you're welcome to be you
know a great tactician yeah I like that
that that's what you should be exactly
but you shouldn't be a strategic Master
as well as a positional player and you
shouldn't be patient either I mean just
I mean I just like the fact that every
single critical decision she takes a
pause and you know also we saw from her
analysis yesterday with Christian she is
fantastic at calculation sorry I I I'm
gonna need your your skill set to bring
up the ladies uh game if you don't mind
uh the elimination games for the ladies
like that and everything but their games
I I I don't know how to unminimize your
screen
we'll worry about that but could you
find the ladies game yeah I can find the
ladies games so you can so you can see
it right perhaps we can see the bird's
eye view from yeah one of the games
perhaps Naji versus tatev with
part of needing a victory in this one
and it's not going to be easy
let's take a look at what's happening in
that game
the way I see it we have
a caracon yeah on the board Karo Khan
with an early Knight to F6 and an
exchange that doubles
the pawns on the file for black this is
a very solid option
employed by Nation right now Queen to
situ
right putting some pressure on H7 and we
assume the natural response is going to
be Bishop to G6
that's such a beautiful block of Parts
if you do take on G6 and I managed to
take with the H Pawn and we see that G7
G6 F7 F6 I really like that block of
Pawn it's like the tank yeah it's really
really really solid it's like a Tetris
have you ever played Tetris oh I love
Tetris oh yes oh yes yeah touch
I guess I'm showing my age I say I love
Tetris wait a minute everyone plays
Tetris that's Tetris hey Christine you
know Tetris oh yeah yes I I do of course
exactly yeah
I mean um this is actually one of my
favorite lines of the car I don't know
if you enjoyed playing these uh very
very safe King positions you do give uh
your opponent the the center a little
bit uh I while we keep the bird's eye
view there I was just seeing the game of
um Lavon and Fabi again boldly stating
the obvious Levon needs to win and when
we left it it was just here and we had
seen the move Knight H7 and
um Christian was saying well is this a
Prelude to King G7 followed by F5 well
knows as man because yes it was F5 on
the board EF Bishop f593 this is truly a
Titanic theoretical battle between these
two players because and to my eyes Lavon
maybe has one the theoretical battle why
is that because he spent less time
it's very straightforward there's
nothing complex about this yesterday
wow okay I just spent less time
explaining everything with confidence
right and he seems to know what he's
doing
and what is Lavon doing by the way what
is his plan
Bishop G6 on the board on the board what
is he going to play for D4 is he
supposed to play for Knight D5 to try to
snack on that Bishop
um what is lavon's AIMS in the position
well it seems like Knight to D5
is appealing right let's go for the
bishop
that Bishop is always very annoying
whenever it's coupled with the action of
The Rook on f8 with an open F5 right
because F2 is quite tender right
um why not take it away from the board
Knight to D5 take it away take it away
now
A7 but it's loose well the one thing I
wouldn't want to do is I wouldn't want
to encourage white to play the move d4
which would open up the e-file uh I was
thinking that maybe I could turn the
Fate return the favor uh
um by pinning there was a bishop to G5
yeah follow pinning the Knight now it's
my turn to pin your night how about
Bishop H5 Bishop page five is nice as
well because it's annoying it's super
annoying because you know if you do
manage Bishop takes Knight which you
will then you've locked out the bishop
and then you go like okay let's play
Let's Play positionally please yeah I
mean I think it was the Kappa Blanco
Winter game where it was this bishop on
G3 which was hideous
it was like uh a piece down so maybe
Knight D5 needs to be prepped no 95 is a
great move and how do we answer Bishop
H5 then
you're going to lose the bishopon G3
this is what you need to understand
that's white uh you are going to take on
F3 H5 H4 now
what do I do to prepare for that I need
to open up the position your king is
pretty feeble on AJ okay
D4 let's go we open up the position you
don't take the bishop I'm not going to
take the bishop okay I'm going to keep
the Knight on D5 for the moment okay now
I agree with you that all I need is a
draw which is why I'm going to sacrifice
wait wait my piece
are you sure about that all right I'll
take your Facebook you give me the piece
I'll take it okay no yes
all I need is a draw why did I never
play for a draw when I need a draw
because that's a way of losing the game
exactly and you kind of change your
mindset it's a negative
disposition you don't want to be doing
that exactly
so what if I defend with the move
do we have the Knight on D5 yes you have
to see something in the centers yeah
yeah okay well that's your extra piece
but boy it was I was hoping to
intimidating you know these coaches
they're not easily intimidated uh I
would be fretful let's put it that way
if I had the Y position how do how do
you feel sorry let me tell you I'm
inspired by my peace sacrifice I am very
inspired but I mean I'm a little bit
concerned that he can return the favor
let me put the cap on your your fun okay
I'm not going to go to E3 you're not no
no take take you're gonna sacrifice your
queen no I'm going to sacrifice my Rook
Rook days yeah I was concerned about I
need to get to your king exactly wow I I
really need to get to your kingdom
that's my only goal in the position
yeah but Queen takes D4 is is
frightening so I have to take this guy
yeah okay and I'm assuming he's gonna be
taking yes yes and then I take this guy
and what if I continue taking and this
is the problem you you said my king was
feeble and it is
and boy did that ever turn out to be
prescient yes you're right you're right
well
you see my inner tactical Wizardry you
really did work
you guys are probably going to be
surprised by this but it seems like
white is in fact objectively winning
right now after the move 19.95 yeah wow
the engine is giving white a decisive
Advantage wow no way and uh just talking
to everyone this is exactly what Lavon
aronia needs you know he is in a
must-win situation exactly
so night so we were talking about the
theoretical battle and you had said you
know it was about the clock and so on
but it's it's shocking because what did
Bobby do in the previous 18 moves that
was wrong he chose the wrong plan of
opening up White's position and we were
discussing this and we were kind of uh
balancing between either F5 or H5 this
idea of Knight to H7 made a lot of sense
because you they want to support the
pawn on G5 he chose the wrong one he
played the move F5 H5 was the right
solution well solution just the right
content right right approach F5 was
wrong no terrible after F5 in fact white
is just much much better with
specifically the moves uh that Levon
made I2 E3 follow it up with the natural
move Knight to D5 jump in the center set
up all your pieces on their ideal
squares and right now the pressure is on
Fabiano caruana okay and we'll switch
quickly to see the game of Sam Shanklin
again
this this petroth boy I got to tell you
this Petrov is really putting the kibosh
on one E4 if you can just uh Yan and
nepo who will be playing for the World
Championship uh next month he comes to
his games and he says I'm going to play
the Petro after your worst
and he actually makes a draw and
sometimes he even gets a victory when
his opponent's overpress this moment I
don't see it I don't feel it for Sam I
don't see it doesn't matter yes sir it
doesn't matter look at his time what is
his clock 27 minutes for Sam he added
two minutes on his clock he's been
blitzing out every single move up to
this point and right now linear is down
to his last 11 minutes
and he played the best move okay okay
Sam must be what do I have to do to take
this man out right
um
well again I just don't see why this is
a can Queen takes B7 seems like a
suicide mission right it is Queen takes
B7 Bishop H3 and why on Earth did I
allow you know this queen to visit me on
E2 so it's time to develop the pieces
and here is good man
and that's what he wants and I'm just
trading off I was thinking Bishop
Bishop F4 okay
so once again it's like I'm
I'm I'm I'm
so anxious for that nobody is beating
linear in this position no nobody I'm
sorry yeah you have to do something with
Bishop D2 as you mentioned Queen right
um could it be
well I'm a little bit worried that if I
play Bishop D3 I may be the one who has
the more exposed hang on a second
there's a greedy right oh you can go
greedy Queen Dee Queen D3 set up a
battery threatened Checkmate perhaps the
only way to continue this okay if I play
G6 I kind of like understand where
you're gonna go right you you do get the
exchange in this particular case yeah
which therefore would more or less
oblige me uh to play the move F5
but then you'd have to do something
with you have to develop your Bishop
okay Bishop D2 yeah makes a lot of sense
Queen zooms down yep it says trade trade
as
yeah black just looks super super solid
I'm just having a little trouble with
the lady I wanted to bring up the ladies
elimination game but I'm going to need
some help from our marvelous production
team here uh it's the ladies uh game
between and Naji because they're
is really going full on for the attack
she's pressing hard she sees space and
she is pushing Naji so if Naji doesn't
do anything then simply Tata will
overrun
black on the e-line
it doesn't sound good
I don't want to get run over on the line
I mean I have a there's I've been
training on how to over dramatize
everything
standing
Bishop G6 and overrun on the e-line
okay why don't we continue with right
now it starts move why why don't we go
D5 I mean yeah V5 looks very very close
let's keep pushing
okay there's no way I'm going to allow
you ever to play D6 in the position so I
will take on D3
and if you take with the queen I was
going to go Bishop take C5 okay
so I've got a little tricky for you
there
what is that
is that freaky enough is the question
um let's continue I take the bishop C5
Queen takes F4
my take on f8 as well
say what I take on f8 I take your and I
recapture with what I don't know okay
well if if you go with the King then I
will pick up the pawn on each step
ah so you probably have to take a look
but then D6 is coming okay and that
d-pawn is super ultra dangerous which is
actually gone for a different plan she's
not forced to matter she's simply gone
B4 I like it well I like this one before
because yes exactly I mean and you know
there are those tricks with Bishop takes
C5 which have now just been completely
neutralized and you said okay done and
tested we're not worried about Bishop C5
anymore now having said all of this you
know I didn't even like the fact that on
the previous turn
she could have taken this was not bad
and you you get your your your tank
formation but this bishop finds
pretty nice diagonal there so I kind of
thought that uh B4
I if I'm in black shoes I'm capturing
exactly trade off the pieces exactly
and uh I feel a lot better with those
Bishops and the Knights off the board
let's go to uh your pupil uh begum uh
position and let's see what she chose
we'll go right out of the opening and it
was another Russian Knight C3 and look
at the players go
um all all part of the preparation coach
not so much not so much no no I think a
white deviate it quite early on okay
um even this move Queen to E1
is not what you're supposed to do you're
supposed to put the queen on C1 and
specifically for this reason you don't
want to have the queen on the same file
as The Rook on E8 I just played the move
work to E8 I'm going to follow it up
with what she did in the game Bishop to
f8 perhaps Bishop to F6 was a bit more
active but it doesn't really matter the
point being that I want to open up the
e-file and then I'm going to slowly
slowly push and create my own initiative
on the queen side that's what she's
doing A6 C6 with black pieces B5
potentially in the future
and where is your attack well that's the
question right is the King on B1 safer
than the King on G8 I wanted to play the
move F3 followed by
G4 which should then yeah
so she's dropping Back The Rook this
Bishop's a little awkward maybe I have
to go Queen D2 back right because if you
go G4 don't I have Queen E7 I know I
know that's like annoying right I would
love to exchange the Queens right I need
only a golden rule when your King's
getting attacked trade the Queens so
yeah I I I now now the difference
between Queen C1 and queen E1 is
especially noticeable the queen we're on
C1 I think everybody'd be playing G4
lickety split uh Queen to F2 oops Queen
F2 and now it's all about speed yeah you
look you've played C6 you've played A6
you've played so many you said A and B
and you have to go for it you have you
have to go V5 right and also the bishop
B6 is something that could be unpleasant
exactly yeah so you you have to do
something well now we've got the Donnie
Brook we really hope for with the two
with the Kings on opposite flanks who
who's getting there first with the
mostest right that's that's the big
question right that's the big question
but it is a huge question because often
means there's no way of letting you open
up my age the queen goes to a five we're
going to get the answer to that because
that's what they were playing B5 is on
the board B5 is on the board I was I
pushed on the G4 and put the bishop on
E6 I mean right now you have to go G4
right yes you have to go for the kill
that's the whole point I mean atusha has
to win yes so she she's and There She
Goes C5 right away without G4 by the way
pardon me C5 right away
I think this is actually a better choice
uh because now you're not allowed Queen
A5 and Bishop doesn't it just lose a
pawn after Queen E7
s
that was a timid yes but but it's sort
of like it's it's kind of it takes you
time to capture it and maybe I'm doing
something in the meanwhile like okay so
I'm just picking a move yeah Bishop D2
not inspired gift me the pawn yes G4 yes
and now no I still need a few moves
that's the I apologize I'm going to put
my Bishop all the way back you're going
to take I'm going to play here
although excuse me I apologize you can
play D5 you can play D5 but you know but
still oh that might be a much more
unpleasant recapture because it comes
with Tempo is this so is it so dangerous
okay let's go G4 anyhow your pupil
spotted a uh
a good trick a good trick yeah that's
that's Queen E7 we're doing this type of
double attacks in and out every day baby
yeah the training yeah training is
working the training is working
Queen E7
okay
so perhaps if you want to avoid this D5
Shenanigans yeah start off with Bishop
F4 agreed so that I do at least in that
case have a move like Bishop to D6 yes
and now after I take on C5 you go G4
right and finally you got what you
wanted well at least you're getting
closer to what you want yeah but even
here I mean it's like I have to play H5
Queen G3 G5 it's a very slow burning
attack and meanwhile C4 C3 and by the
way whenever you go H5 can I just stop
you from going
G5 with F6
yeah then I'm gonna have to after this
yeah it's long it's it's slow uh bacon
looks like she's got a very decent
position jumping to tata for just a
moment 96 we looked at Knight G6 but
this looks like
um
Naji needing only a draw she looks to be
the favorite at the moment let's go to
the uh open
um section Lavon when we left okay yeah
when we left it it was crazy well what
was really crazy was this idea that
Lavon was just winning I mean I didn't
realize that the position was so good
for Fabi oh he he just simply captured
that Bishop after Knight F6 yes and then
he played D4 and actually this bishop on
G3 is no longer
terrible in fact
that's a great Mission
that's a really really powerful if I
were white and I could play F3 here and
deny the E4 Square for the night I would
think that I'm winning yeah it is
winning yeah so in light of that can you
do something like for instance
you better do something five yeah I was
about to say you better do something in
the immediacy because I can see the
Rooks are ready to pounce that's that's
okay
I have said yes I've stated my
intentions okay now the queen
I really want to trade of some pieces so
I have to go
I understand
you want to trade Queens I want to trade
Queens but I can't do I say okay Queen
say it F6 uh
Queen F6 yeah but you just I play these
three easy block to Parry yes that is
absolutely true
yeah none of this will happen because
Fabiano is looking for an immediate
immediate counter shot and that is with
the move B4 which is what he played
after Queen D1 B4
but what about wow look to E6
doesn't that rookies
oh my goodness rookie six looks very
compelling even though
take take
C3
I think he must be a British thing
because I mean
I mean takes bomb takes even though
we're we're supposed to be algebraically
trained these days but yeah it still is
still part of our what about Bishop F7
right now
ah thank you
Bishop F7 Rook takes exchange Rook takes
sorry Bishop takes Bishop takes B3
apologies
okay which means the the highly
desirable Rook E6 let's go with your
move yeah sir I I think I really like
I'm starting to warm up to your idea of
4k7 Rook A7 or F3 okay okay seven let's
just invade I mean let's be aggressive
aggression
I must win I must win yeah
okay but you can just go ponte's pool
first
yeah night now just brings forward oh
wait do you have a queen B8 wait wait do
you have queen bee I'm I'm
a queen B8 that's a double attack right
well that training is sure pain yeah
yeah you have some tricks and that's why
he played B4
he's he's really really looking for
those conversations very instructive but
uh what is also very concerning on a
practical level I mean take a look at
love on a romance clock 20 minutes
versus Fabiano's under eight minutes
that's not good
let me fall back on the old you know
like I'm playing two Bishops I'm gonna
play the steinizzian uh way of
preventing the night from having a good
Outpost I'll play the move F2 F3 and
just give you the turn and say do your
worst how do you follow up your move
before
perhaps I will take on C3 yes he played
Bishop C2 but yes you would take on C3
in this case and and try to go for
Knight to try Knight H5 so now my my
Bishop can Lord over the position with
Bishop to C4 no it's really a very sad
position it is uh but having said all of
this bishop C2 uh Lavon had a very
simple idea he wants to
put his Queen on G6 that's right Bishop
takes C2 Queen takes C2 followed by
Queen G6 would be a dream for white so
how do you stop me from a change
that's what I wanted to ask Jovi
okay so you take I guess
yes and now you remember the fundamental
principles of three queens trade queens
and you get fabby's following the rules
so when the queen does
on G6 you're ready to go Queen G7 let's
trade I like it okay but in that case D6
is going to be hanging
I'm gonna take
and put the question to you would you
like to take with the Rook
and allow Queen G6 so Queen G7 I got
Bishop takes D6 at the end or do you
want to play with a pawn which looks
pathetic
yeah I don't want that so yes
um it looks like a nasty nasty choice
that Lavon can put to his opponent right
here with C3 takes B4
yes and I have to say if Fabiano loses
this one he will have to do something
different
in the next game whenever he's going to
have black because he's had problems in
this variation against West Wesley he's
having huge problems right now against
LeBron he needs to do something
different
and whoops
not this one first of all just remember
uh that in the classical game we have a
drone yeah
and uh
for
tomorrow's market and a very classical
game tomorrow if we decided and
and these two wow look at that wrap Wow
first of all 51
whoa 51 games of rapid play boy they
know each other very well under 17 wins
for Levon whereas fabi's had 11 wins wow
wow I mean yes uh shocking result
um the current position though Christian
if I can get you to jump in and uh tell
us what the engine thinks it really
looks like blacks in in trouble because
of his exposed King and lots of
weaknesses no no no it's bad he's just
he's completely lost it's toast it's
it's over yeah it's toast okay pass Four
Points by what four pawns right now a
pawn Advantage by the way C3 takes B4
Pawn takes and not Queen G6 but just
easy Central is the queen simple chess
go to D4
as well ugly F3 Bishop F2 put the bishop
on D4
oh
since the tournament began yeah yeah
that Queen on D4 okay
supports the Invasion on the seventh
rank with Rook 287 attacks the pawn on
B4 it does everything
well besides all that what have you done
for me lately yeah I agree that that is
a radiant radiant Queen uh Sam Shanklin
in a must-win situation anything good
happening for him no that one is not
even close linear has neutralized his
opening initiative and right now he's
his import position and take this one
and take the uh for take the match home
for tatv uh again uh she lost the first
game with the black pieces she needs a
win uh against Naji at the two-time U.S
women's champion she just played the
move Queen F5 I kind of like that movie
so she's saying go ahead you want to
trade pieces but do it on my terms I get
to put my Bishop
a little bit more frightening
um yeah and I was hoping that I'd have a
a severely good follow-up and I I don't
know I'm not I'm not a big fan of of
sopping off pieces because you know
there is one thing I will say I always
love these Pond storms you know where
you get to go Rook to be Rook the D1 B5
it's not fun and games for black to be
facing defensively speaking yes I'm just
saying I mean it's not draw
no it's not draw but at the same time
you know you black does have a problem
with this Pawn storm but white has a big
weakness on D4 and that's something that
you know I if I were playing Black I
would yeah
immediately yeah so for example you
would go here absolutely more or less
required yeah and then I would start to
you know start expanding on on the king
side something like the F5 yeah yeah F5
and I'll expand yeah and then come on
push push it back what's that G5 G5
okay this is my language and there come
on F6
well I'm fighting on everything yeah
you're really and here by the way is the
Elimination Brackets as uh begum uh just
needs a draw to see her weight into the
next match and that one is definitely
going her way because let's check out
the position right now okay
gotten anywhere close to her opponent's
king and by the way we name is on C3 we
didn't get an H5 we didn't get in G5 we
didn't even get an F4 G5 and we're
already seeing a black Pawn on C3 that's
not good no so and the race to the king
the first strike in and also you know if
you've seen B3 then A5 A4 is gonna
rattle down the board but it's uh Rook
E1 is an indication to me that White's
not a happy camper just the fact that we
can take and take on B2 means that
White's King is permanently damaged now
you probably don't even want to take on
people I know like that pawn the pawn is
such a wedge right so be sure maybe you
can take on E1 first and then go Bishop
36 you have so many options no this is
actually looking very very very good for
begum again now needs only a dream it
takes Pawn takes Pawn in the air I'm
yeah not only that but I have a feeling
some Queen D5 to force you to go B3 and
then A5 A4
Mike Checkmate you if you don't pay
close attention to it so if I
for argument's sake yes she's traded
once so H5
right then
and then Queen and then Queens Quincy
yes you can
my friends
open invitation agreed
yeah now this one is looking very very
good for vegan also on time four minutes
and 40 seconds for athusa 15 minutes for
Baguio right now
and she only needs a draw in this game
nothing like having a better position
and draw odds in your favor you just
feel really really good uh once again
let's jump to the game between Levon and
aronium because we may be seeing another
uh
uh playoff uh it should Lavon win then
they would play 10 minutes two games of
10 minutes plus five second increments
and if the match is still tied after
those two accelerated rapid games then
we go on to the blitz maybe two games of
three minutes plus two seconds and
finally I really am hoping foreign
faces I want to take chess back to the
streets right F2 F3 look at him go
because we mentioned that uh this bit I
mean queen on D4 is radiant yeah I mean
that's just such a gorgeous gorgeous
looking Queen but also with this move F2
F3 you know the bishop isn't going to be
too badly placed either on the Square D4
that would just be uh and recognizing
that The Rook was actually misplaced on
uh B6 Rook C6 but uh I see a slight
Shake of fabi's head there he's not
he's only got three and a half minutes
and it's going down Lavon has 16 minutes
so how do we do that until we go H4 or
yeah H4 makes a lot of sense Bishop F2
oh boy once you see that Rook you know
like tickling that pawn on G5 how do you
not play H4 but you can do it
because H4 allowed Rook to C5 and that's
why he played Bishop 12. H for a loud
route to C5 yes challenge The Rook on
the fifth rank wheat Tempo makes sense
okay so that was why Bishop F2 uh
Prelude to H4 yes
and Rook to E7
Jovi you have a golden rule when
attacking
don't trade Jesus no trades uh do we
like Rook A1 or do we like Rook D1 Rook
D1 Rook T1 uh you didn't he didn't give
us a chance to really get into the uh
Rook D1 looks good it looks good in a
Time the this Rook to D6 but also you
know H4 is on top Bishop actually I
don't mind last sewing at this Pawn
either like Rook this bottom B4 is a
real weakness and Rook B5 followed by
Rook takes B4
got got my vote what about Rook F5
followed by Bishop to D4 got my vote
Queen E6 okay Fabby says enough of you
this nonsense I need counter play
Queenie Queen E6
not going down without a fight stop your
okay Bishop to D4 right it it feels like
I have to get closer and closer to your
king it looks like a very good uh start
because you are
planning the desirable Rook F5 and that
would be
that would be huge can you survive if
you go Queen to E2
I doubt it right oh
it just feels like this should not take
on D3 and then be working play Rook to
E6 and try to hang on for dear life
yeah it just feels like it shouldn't be
working but okay
um
it
you know
King F1 Queen C4 golden rule number one
trade the queen right the queen
H4
H makes a lot of sounds softening up
okay exactly H4 I don't think you have
time for Queen E2 H takes G5
H4 and if you play G4 now
it's a a different uh kettle of fish
because the file can easily be opened
uh H4 looks like a very powerful move
on enjoying the moment
yes and one of the clock times and the
clock times I'll just bring them up for
you so they are
Fabi has just under three minutes
whereas Levon aronian has just under 15
minutes so lots of time it's stuck
difference in that
but still I mean he has to finish him
off exactly
who said that that is the most difficult
thing in chess is
no I mean it's such a a famous quote I I
think it's you you got to go back back
back back uh uh tarticover or something
like that you got to go way way way back
these guys are clever yeah I remember
the donut Court was like give me any
position give me a worse position give
me losing position give me and I'll turn
them around but give me
a winning position nah
the winning positions that really throw
me off the losing positions I understand
and completely drawn positions I get
those nice
uh really one of the great quotable and
he did play H4 and by the way very
quickly G5 takes H4 I mean cover your
eyes but uh wow that is really
ugly and I think we're just about to see
most likely the end of that game of two
sellers who's begging all right right
now he's down to her last two minutes
but I think the writing is on the wall
on this one yeah I was I was looking at
this game as well
I mean the only saving grace is that
there is a hiding spot for the white
king you know she can put herself on it
no she can't even do that I've got the
wrong position apologies that let me
just refresh my position
yeah no I just had to refresh Bishop D7
G5 H5 G6
d8 how do you continue the hiding
you don't
and bearing in mind that atusa is in a
must-win situation
it's just all over
yeah just Rook to D1 is coming and
there's no way to stop it this is the
Checkmate and there's no Queen G7
nope it looks like you're close to
delivering your own Checkmate but the
bishopone f8 is suing is doing such a
damn good defensive job so if we play
Queen G7 is this like a 50 50 you know
Checkmate
or does your opponent take your queen ah
I tried
I think that's what Chris bird steps in
he's like not a 50 50. you can still
continue the game right yes yes
um
just a reminder yeah so this is just to
remind you that if began wins or draws
she will move on to the next stage of
the elimination bracket and uh whereas
are still
writing it out between them and she will
meet the winner of that particular match
so we did ct5 takes on D5 Queen we
dropped back to F3 again Tata needs a
win but is she allowed whoa whoa whoa
whoa Queen E4 this is what it kind of
Tata stream is is that if you do play
Move by Queen E4 it's this uh attack of
these pawns on the flank that are really
um
powerful for tatel she's making uh well
I think she's
she's got a great position actually you
know she's done everything she should do
with the white pieces okay but we do
have this move Rook d8 right there there
is a check on the back rank that might
be nettlesome
so if I play Rook to d8 and let's see
what she did do no she that's yes she
did Rook d8 was my analysis apologies
so the idea that I was having for Naji
was any trades and I got Queen Shack and
there's a a B4 Pawn sighting there's an
F2 Pawn sighting
okay so uh tatev
yes what's the plan here guys
Bishop back to E3
King
well what she's done it she has played
Bishop back to E3 I think we should go
back to atusa because we're going to see
a handshake okay but uh this is uh not
convincing by tatev and we did see Rook
to d8 Queen to F4 and woof and that is
just handshake time 30 seconds for atusa
there yeah that's a that's a blow
uh B2 is hanging you don't have time for
Rook B1 because oops
Queen takes B1
and there's just no nothing to be done
and that means that Peggy moves on and
atusa is eliminated from she will be
back the American Cup she will be back
for the blitz yes
and we see it again congratulations to
begum and she moves up she moves on and
yes and uh not she's looking like she
should be able to hang on and draw this
let's go to uh big matchup between Fabi
and
pardon me Levon is white and Fabi we
left it he captured the pawn on H4 and
whoa whoa Bishops there's 2800s are
difficult too
that's right and I'm looking at this
position I'm thinking well hang on a
second not that easy anymore not that
easy anymore right what what what what
what what what
that I I was about to say it was nice to
be able to lasso that beep on maybe it's
time just to play Rook B5
make sure that uh
yeah what Rook P5 looks like a very good
move
and it does seem like Shanklin and
linear are repeating which means that a
linear moves on wins the match and
eliminates Sam Shanklin from the
competition well Sam certainly came
very very well prepared his preparation
uh really remains world class but uh
well linear yeah Lanier you know he
remembered in the competition and he
played a great first game you didn't
really when he saw the opportunity to
strike he took it and well he will be
awaiting lenia Dominguez will be
awaiting the victor of this particular
match up Fabiana carwana against Levon
aronian and this one looked like it was
completely in levon's hands he was in
full control but now not so easy and
Fabby
is playing with just over one minute
and those developments that you were
talking about in The Elimination
Brackets here they are yes and we could
see the first person through to the next
stage is begin talking Genova and she
will be awaiting the victor of the match
between Nazi pakiza and tatev abrahamian
and we also have lenia Dominguez also
making it through to the next stage and
Dave will also be waiting for the next
person the next winner of Carolina and
aronian we love this bishop coming to
the D4 square and I think Lanier
Lavon has found the the perfect setup he
wants to play the move Rook f8
tickling the night allowing therefore
when the night moves to play Rook to G4
and it's the black king that's going to
get netted in a checkmating attack so I
love this move Rook a rook A8 sorry
fight the bullet yes and go Knight H5 I
know I'm probably gonna check my age I
I'm probably going to get checked maybe
but I need to do something okay so check
I was about to say you desperate times
come call for desperate measures King G5
I would do G3 very quickly three there's
a back rank mate
so it's Bishop to E5 actually Rook to E6
is is that a move
absolutely continue tickling you like
that absolutely
this is not that easy anymore wait a
minute it might have been a blunder just
whoa at first I said I saw it and I
thought oh Rook f8 what are you gonna do
well we saw what he could do king G5
might have let him Escape huh wow Bishop
he forgot about that move King to G5
maybe rookie six oh I can move my Rook
he played rookie six I can play Rook to
B4 you can you can in order to meet Rook
takes with F4 check
and how the big question comes can I
play Rook takes
for Jack King G4
check King G3
with the I was just going to say there's
a rook check behind but there is one
right okay one is four uh King F1 King
F1 is also on the Move yeah because I do
have like you say I'm waiting for a
check from behind it does seem like
you're escaping with white and that
should give you the decisive Advantage
but again Lavon has to win so he can't
make some decision like Bishop takes F
pardon me Rook takes F6 and how are we
doing on time Fabiano how many seconds
does he have left he has 20
20 seconds against 10 minutes for Levon
Rook to D4 Rook to D4
not allowing The Exchange sacrifice
mentioned
but now the
it is still white
it's true it is it is a a dominant
position D4 is such a fantastic and also
he's gonna round up the B3 Pawn with
Rick B yeah but it's you know when he
when there were more pieces on the board
I think I think it was much more clear
now I I feel like we're defending
Champion wait a minute can I play F4 is
that is that winning a piece
you're absolutely right F4 check is
winning a piece because King G6 walks
into Rook A6 King F5 walks into the rook
f8 and after Rook to E6 I have G4
oh my word I I think that wins a piece
but hang on a second if you go
and G4 I mean I I I actually think
you're just winning the king and pawn
end game too yeah you know something as
simple and as a date as this and this
and this
you just trade Rooks and then bring oop
that was mine I'll slip my bad I
apologize and then you bring your king
and that must be uh yes that seems
winning so
it could be a click that that might be a
clincher yes
I suspect that Fabi sees it and he's
trying to keep the poker face you know
he's trying not to alert his opponent oh
they both see yes yes Levon is just
calculating the exact line that you just
showed right now to make sure that he
can blast off a sequence of moves very
quickly in the position
and that's going to mean if Levon takes
this one home that we're going to see
another let's another the playoff will
continue
um yeah excuse me okay 10 minutes plus
five seconds increment that's right our
apologies to Arena Crush Alice Lee fans
and he's missed it he missed he missed
Rook to F4 excuse me Rook to d8 is the
move that he chose which isn't terrible
I mean it freezes the night
and oh with one second on his side I
think H5 we saw this last year Jeffrey
Zhang at one second
and again F4 should be that winning
moment but he missed it the first time
he's probably going to play Rook to D6
yeah yes but
honestly that's such a good deal as well
there's no more
you don't even have Knight to H5 with
upon on H5 anymore six five five well
three
foreign but now we take a pawn we check
our favorite living condition yeah
are there any tricks with the king
I suspect not because the problem is is
that this bishop is ready to
you know defend the dark squares if you
will and he did in fact after Rook takes
D5 he moved back with the King to G6 not
that uh this is any great shakes
uh what's better than being one Pawn up
two points out that's right and uh Rook
to B5 okay but I have an idea for Fabi
you know you're thinking
it's it's obviously a pipe dream for the
time being yes but if he can somehow get
H5 sorry H4 Knight comes to G5 and then
H3 you know just to disturb White's Pawn
structure a little bit and yeah
but a good one and I think Lavon said
you know what the one thing I want to
avoid is h4h3 and so
and after Rook E7 I think it's inertia I
think that is F4 Wings right now keeping
uh Bobby playing F4 followed by Bishop
to F6
that finishes the game right
F4 King takes F4 Bishop F6 yeah
isn't there some no
you know I I'd probably at the board see
the move F4 and I couldn't bring myself
on the board you know I would probably
play King F2 and say you know like look
I'm just going to enjoy my I worked hard
for the two pawns but he did play F4 uh
well spotted Christian
yeah King takes F4 Bishop F6 and this
check is just it just goes to show how
powerful the bishop is in an end game
with an open Center and an open position
D4 was just simply hang on a second hang
on wait one second wait one second there
is isn't there Rook E6
and you you're gonna meet Bishop takes
Knight with King age six now
ah
that's why you guys are Grandma hey hey
you know it was close it was close
what he got his
oh
well he found a trick like you were you
you were trying as well but two pawns is
really sad it's too much yes okay
and I do have the table base in front of
me and it does say that it's winning
okay which doesn't come as much
well thank goodness for that right
King F2 Rook to D2 now every single king
move wins
King E3 gift me the pawn but
unfortunately the king is a bit too far
away from the action
I I'm sorry I would the instructor for
UK you gave up his extra Pawn well look
how he cut off the black king you know
he doesn't need to calculate anymore all
he needs to do is just B4 King run with
the King Teamwork Makes the Dream work
that's all you need to remember and then
Teamwork Makes the Dream Work you know
you just rush with the King
and like the king is just far away from
the airport but I would have I would
have nursed those two extra pawns for
quite the while I must say uh tatev uh
how is she doing as this game is now uh
technically winning
um
whoa holy smokes one two three four five
one two three four so somehow Naji
managed to keep her extra pawn and tatev
again obviously needs to win to lengthen
the match but after Queen there's no
more extra Pawn oh there is an extra
point double that porn hey I count them
all
Queen D6 yeah
and Lavon has won
and in an hour's time uh they'll play a
very quick Rapid or will it be a blitz
10 minutes plus five seconds
then and then you know if the match is
still tied then we are going to see
three minutes plus two seconds Tata
fighting for her life can she do a
Christian
well I I don't think it's very
encouraging in that position I mean that
uh Queen D6 followed by Rook to C7 it
just feels like nicely Pawn I'm going to
walk my own Pawn use that as a decoy
exactly and then you're going to
probably capture my deep one I'm going
to capture your C6 Pawn which is that's
it so D1 just says okay the match is
over yeah so now she can go Queen take
C6 Queen takes D4 and why not three C6
so that you cannot take with the Rook on
D4
good point uh you're right Rook takes C6
just because I want to force the queen
trade absolutely I
agree wholeheartedly with you not that
it matters too much because it does seem
like nausea right now has this one in
the back okay this game absolutely we do
expect it to be a draw let's pick up
number one versus number two we don't
want to lose sight of Arena and Alice
but before we jump into the game between
Arena analysis we have guest in studio
Lanier uh a difficult match against Sam
Shanklin the player that has incredible
theoretical knowledge what did you
expect from this match and how did you
get ready for it yeah I mean I expected
him to be as usual very well preparingly
opening so I uh was more or less
expecting than either that's what he
played against me the last couple of
times
and so uh yeah we got into some unusual
position after this 96 H3 and then
Knight F6 Bishop B3 E5 and then this
taken on C6 and a four is interesting I
remember
um this was kind of challenging for
black and then I think the end game that
we got is just slightly worse for black
it is but he was also speeding through
these moves he was playing very very
yeah he was playing very fast I don't
know if I mean I maybe he knew this
position but I mean I also knew that
it's a kind of pleasant for white so I
was just trying to make sure that I
don't uh blow it right away because
there were there was Bishop A5 ideas but
but yeah I mean I think the point here
Bishop to A5 or yeah I mean when I play
long castle if Bishop A5 uh no instead
of Bishop B6
but then I can just go Knight A4 and if
Knight E4 Bishop B6 and this should be
very good for white
stakes and then takes on C8 and takes on
A6 and there is Bishop B7 and okay Rook
HD1 just to interrupt you for one second
uh and Nazi did draw her game her second
game against and wins the match
eliminates Tate from the competition and
moves on to the semifinals
let's keep going
yeah this this wasn't good for black and
yeah here I'm slightly better I wasn't
sure about Knight H5 Knight F4 I mean it
looks active but the Knight is actually
not doing much on F4 and then there's no
pressure on on e4 so I can I think
Bishop of one was correct and I'm I'm
coming with Rook D6 and Knight C5 and
this was just I think a blunder yeah
this was the move yeah allowed you to go
G3 did he miss Bishop to B6 was this
maybe yeah I don't know yeah I think
maybe he missed the whole idea that I
can just move the bishop because even
after something like Bishop C5 is still
losing something
this is a much better version but I can
take play Knight C3 and on the 90s
anyway lost controls the D1 Square the
Knight is lost on H3 yeah this looks so
I think I missed it I can move the
bridge over here but still yeah that
easy yeah still a fight I mean I'm
completely winning but somehow this
pawns you never know where they might uh
arrive he gave you the man here yeah I
was trying to be very precise I don't
know I mean I I decided to play the the
really
uh brood move Bishop F2
but yeah I'm sure like they're like we
like this one yeah but it's very
practical just to get rid of the Bishops
I mean try one more
uh peace and yeah it's raining all along
I mean there are some tricks with H3 at
some point but it's just too obvious and
even though I had little time I came to
E3 yeah yeah this was the line H2 Rook
H1 and G2 there's rookies to check yeah
okay to check and then pick up the Rook
on G5 that's yeah or pick up the pawn on
G2 very nicely done linear and after
that
second game you play the Petrov a very
stable defense nevertheless once again
he was speeding he actually gained two
minutes on his clock at some point he
had 27 minutes oh yeah and he had 11
minutes on your clock did you feel any
pressure
um I mean of course I wasn't happy about
the fact that I was like uh 15 minutes
down but on the other hand the position
was a bit simplified I knew I mean this
cannot be so bad and I was very happy
with rookie E8 I thought this was a
precise move because I mean Bishop C6
feels wrong I mean queen D3 and then
there is Bishop H6 so Bishop d2k1 coming
but I think after Rook 88 uh my position
should be
um just just uh completely fine and even
though I had much less time uh again
it's a it's not such a difficult
position because now it's more or less
clear what I'm doing and that probably
like trading some pieces yeah
and and I think I was never really in
danger after that linear congratulations
is a very clinical performance from you
today you move on to the next match you
still have one life left in the event
who do you prefer from Fabi or Lavon
yeah I don't know it's of course they're
pretty pretty equal I mean and the match
itself it's it's just
um unpredictable what will happen so
yeah I'm happy to to face uh any of any
of them yeah guys any questions yeah
absolutely uh first of all our
congratulations to yourself Lanier but I
love the rebranding of your image I mean
the black leather jacket man this is
this is cool uh is this something new
yeah it works somehow so I'll probably
keep it going
well it sure makes you look like a tough
guy I gotta tell you
good luck in your next match thank you
absolutely wow and uh Alice uh she's
actually slightly worse I would prefer
to be white I mean after all the most
dangerous Pawn in the position is this
past part
course it's closer to a draw than it is
a win but if you if you force me to play
I'd rather have the whites yes I agree
with that conclusion especially because
you know I'm not just looking at that
pawn on B5 but I'm also eyeing up those
vulnerabilities on the king side right
you know you can imagine a situation
easily
for the attack oh yeah I'm such a cliche
H4 H5 I'm just doing this coming to F6
yep it's all well we'll see what happens
next wait for choice for the moment but
uh in the meantime we do have a guest in
the studio begging first of all
congratulations an important Victory
against a tough opponent you won the
first game with the white pieces and you
had to defend a very difficult game with
the black pieces how did you prepare for
this one and take us through the game
get a
perfect
sure like I forgot to check night and
night bt7 for some reason so I tried to
play a logical chess but unfortunately
after Queen E3 it's not that great
already I was going to play Queen C6 but
I was like let's be more solid my coach
told me hi there King and then you know
that was my main advice try to keep the
king safe yeah that was the thing but
then I mean I I try not to blunder the
pawn but unfortunately I was going I had
to develop my uh my Rook on H1 so I
decided that this position is not that
bad you still had some compensation yeah
I have a feeling
I thought Bishop on H4 is uh kind of
strong because Rook d8 she cannot play
which is a very important square and I'm
controlling and she cannot play G5 she
doesn't really have time for F6 too so I
was like okay as long as I can put King
H2 I'm not losing so I was confident
about the position and then I think
whatever she did is not the
like the best no she cannot take only
four because of Knight to E7 check ideas
so you got your Pawn back you outplayed
her in this game and then once again
let's get to the final game that you
played the Petrov defense did you expect
this from your opponent absolutely a bit
late actually uh like recently in
December Warden Blitz and then I played
a Blitz game with her I played Petrov
and I got a good position but I managed
to lose it like I messed it up totally
so I did expect it and I do believe she
did expected it and she repeated her
line with Bishop F4
and last time I played Knight F6 after
Bishop F4 line but this time I decided
to try Knight C5 I didn't know much I
didn't have like a lot of time to
prepare I had to check other lines too
so I was like okay I'm gonna just you
know this is the first time
you knew the plans you knew that she's
trying to attack him on this side and
you tried to do something on the other
side I just remember when I just started
to play picture of my teammate told me
the most important thing you should do
is to play rookie eight Bishop effects I
just did it yes yes that makes a lot of
sense Rook takes C4 Rook to E8 and at
this point you found this nice little
it's not easy to say is see it I think
she said okay B5 fishy automatically
plays C5 but like unfortunately she's
behind yes
that's why and I think we saw the game
after this move C3 we concluded that
your attack is probably going to be
successful which it was Becky
congratulations a big victory for you
tomorrow you will be facing Nazi paikiza
who won her match again started what is
your experience with her what do you
anticipate for that match I actually
really didn't play many games maybe just
a couple of so
we'll see how it goes I have no clue
guys any questions our congratulations
bacon good luck in your next match
nice and uh here we have it once more
the elimination bracket out of action
today I must say uh definitely and I've
noticed that none of the few none of the
women's matches has ever gone to tie
breaks it's like it's been decided by
this decided by the Rapids right in the
classical encounters and we see that uh
triumphant today were naughty pie kitsa
and begum took in Genova and they will
now meet each other and they will then
face whoever wins this encounter will
then face the loser of the match between
Arena and runner up oh sorry my
apologies
and when it comes to Champions bracket
we still have the best game are still
going still going Arena crash against
Ellerslie and we see arena is trying her
best and in the meantime we do have a
guest with Christian
it feels like a highlight of this
tournament for you has been your opening
preparation you're just getting better
position uh positions out of the opening
in pretty much every single game did you
do anything specific like how many hours
were you preparing before this event yes
every single day last year at the U.S
Champs I did really badly so I took my
time to come prepare this time I don't
have a coach or anything but I did spend
really a lot of time and today I got a
special Lucky in the first game because
I had this position on the board in my
room in your preparation yes all the way
up until you got the decisive Advantage
yes I expected in like earlier C5
instead of 97 and A6
um perhaps it wouldn't be foreign but I
think she just exactly is
um I think she just blundered upon her
to maybe on do you take C5 at least you
should take with the Knight yes but I
should still be better you can take on
D5 get the isolated Queen spawn and that
should give you an advantage
yeah so this game went about as well as
it could have gone did you feel like
you're letting it slip away or did you
feel in full control the whole time I
felt in full control and I made sure to
not give her any uh counter-attacking
chances because she's so good at that I
made sure my king was safe
um yeah it's fun it uh felt pretty
smooth and how about the second game
there was some pressure coming from her
side in the second one yeah I was not
happy with Queen C7 as soon as I made
that move um
my idea was that if she ways C5 I'm
gonna go Bishop H to check King H1
Bishop takes E2 and then Bishop F4 but
then I immediately realized that she can
take with the queen on E2
um
okay maybe it's still fine but and that
doesn't allow you to go beach by four
because take take and then two ropes I
can take on D4 but
honestly didn't want to play this in uh
rapid yeah yeah absolutely especially
with the King stuck on the eighth rank
looks dangerous right yeah any sort of
imbalances you don't want to see that
exactly so I ended up in this very
passive position and I think after
Knight F4 Bishop G6 if she went
immediately E5 here I was pretty worried
yes yes that was in fact the best one
according to the engine as well you had
some ideas to tame the position but it
wasn't easy at this point yeah so I was
happy when she delayed D5 and won P4
that gave me time to improve my position
I think I'm still slightly worse but at
least I felt like I could hold this yes
and it did feel like finally you managed
to be accurate and not let her get a
dangerous passport
this one on C5 most likely and you did
find a way to do just that were you
worried at all about this long diagonal
I was I was repeating to myself if she
goes Queen E3 don't allow Queen E5
yes you don't want to see the queen land
on E5 that's for sure which it didn't uh
and this was the position and after that
at this point I would assume once you
took on C6 you understood this is it the
match is mine here I could relax finally
yes absolutely tomorrow you will be
facing uh
do you have I will ask you the same
thing as I asked for do you have any
experience against her how would you
assess that imagine what are you going
to do special for it I think I've played
her twice in the last two years
championships Only In classical games
uh
I don't know her that well but I'm gonna
continue preparing as well as I have and
we'll see what happens guys any
questions yeah absolutely first of all
our congratulations to you Naji uh you
mentioned that you don't have a chess
coach you don't have a chess coach so
how do you train yourself like a lot of
young ladies out there would like to ask
you the question how do you train
yourself you don't have a coach somebody
telling you what you're supposed to do I
don't like people telling me
that's why I don't have a code that
explains that one yeah I haven't had a
coach since I was 16 years old
mainly because like I said I'm pretty
stubborn I like to play what I like to
play and I don't like to compromise and
the way to study on your own is just
if you love The Game and you're
disciplined we all have computers chest
based engine it's pretty easy
there you go stubborn I like it you see
you you you you yeah you you keep to
what you know oh congratulations good
luck in your next match thank you
you like our answer there that's how you
do it you just you got your engines yeah
I mean it's very much just a personality
thing for me I really enjoy studying
with other people I enjoy that
connection I enjoy that kind of hive
mind mentality where we just share and
you know also there's like a not an
element of competition but you can play
again
the whole yes absolutely
uh oh uh by the way uh in this match uh
well our number one versus number two we
do this move Queen A3 was a nice move as
Alice wanted to play the move Queen F3
just what what what uh now as you were
saying don't allow Queen E5 don't allow
Queen E5 Irena is saying don't allow
Queen ever he don't allow Queen after it
and we do have a a repetition going on
at the moment which means we're only
going to have one match left the match
between Levon aronian and Fabiano with
the playoff yeah the playoff
and once again to remind everybody
they're going to play accelerated rapid
and uh Fabi and Lavon are yeah they're
gonna play here we go we can see the
rules so they are going to now play two
games at a time control of 10 minutes
plus a five second increment now if the
match is still tied after two games we
go on to a faster time control where the
games are three minutes plus two second
increment and if they're still tied
after these four games what we're gonna
see is my personal favorite I really
hope that someone is gonna get that it's
an Armageddon game where we have the
draw agreement repetition
look that's uh that's a good game by
Alice if I'm not mistaken she lost both
of her games in last year's finals
against Iraq in fact she might have lost
twice against Irina she lost twice last
year but I don't know the score yeah as
in two matches exactly
um and right now she's starting off with
black pieces makes a draw that's the
that's a really good result well
obviously it is and when you think about
the fact that Arena has been scoring so
well she actually scored three and a
half out of four she did make a draw but
she made a draw yesterday from a
position of strength against uh begum so
uh yeah I mean Alice making a draw with
the black pieces as you say
comparatively to the last year's match
good result for Alice everything to play
for
and here's the championship women's
bracket yes and we can see it's a big
matchup at the top between number one
and number two Arena crush and Alice Lee
played a very eventful draw but a draw
it is and tomorrow that is when
everything will be decided there'll be
another classical match and if the match
is still tied we are going to see
playoffs
it's on your first game
we're gonna go on a quick break and
we'll be back for the playoffs we hope
that there'll be uh shortly but it could
be that we're gonna be doing some
storytelling
and anyway in any case get your
questions ready we're going to need some
some some really good ones we'll see you
on the other side of the break
chess and St Louis is back with nine
major tournaments throughout the year it
all kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
thousand dollar prize fund beginning
June 3rd seasonal Classic Events are
back starting with the spring chess
Classic on April 5th the summer chess
classic August 2nd followed up with the
St Louis Norm Invitational and the
winter chest classic wraps up the year
in December September brings back
everyone's favorite chess night Alex
where some of the world's best don't
even know what's coming and compete for
a 150 000 prize fund 30 players across
three Fields come together in St Louis
for the U.S juniors girls and Senior
championships starting July 15th in
partnership with U.S chess the best in
the U.S fight to be the nation's best
and a four hundred thousand dollar prize
fund in October as the U.S and U.S
women's championships takes place in the
chess capital of America a year full of
action-packed Chess is just getting
started all broadcasts are available on
our St Louis chess club YouTube and
twitch.tv channels
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its ninth trip around the world
inspired by former world champion Gary
Kasparov the grantchester hosts the top
players to compete for top prizes eight
of the world's best joint tournament
wild cards and travel to four different
countries to fight for a 1.4 million
dollar prize fund the tour kicks off in
Bucharest Romania for the super fat
chess classic then things speed up as we
move to Warsaw Poland and Zagreb Croatia
for the first two rapid implants events
the tour then makes its way to St Louis
Missouri for the final two events we're
back in November for the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and the illustrious sinkfield
cup when points are up for grabs the
best players show up who will be crowned
the new Champion find out when the grand
chess tour returns
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back one game remaining and
whilst we wait for that game to begin in
a few minutes we are going to revisit
the Champions bracket and in the women's
section we saw Arena crush and Alice Lee
play out a very exciting draw very even
and talking about Arena she is actually
with Christian right now
welcome uh back to the show a difficult
game today with the white pieces against
Alice Lee you know her so well you've
played two matches in last year's
Edition you started off with a win both
of those matches today a much different
story tell us about that
we had a kind of
variation that quickly
uh got into something that I think
neither of us were very familiar with I
was um a little surprised here by the
move G6 when she refused to capture the
pawn back
um and refused to take home yeah right
so G6 of course it's you know kind of
it's a move that makes sense it exists
and then it's kind of like a hybrid
right because normally white would be
having like a Pawn on D4 in these
positions you know because to keep the
D5 Pawn white is often you know playing
Queen A4 check right so basically it
seems like logically the G6 would not be
as good because I didn't even have to
commit my queen to A4 to keep this Pawn
okay so I played Bishop C4 then the one
thing I wasn't so sure about is word by
night should go instead of yeah E3 or F3
right like I kind of was second guessing
myself I mean I I mean of course I
played it to E2 because I had some
thoughts that like it would go to F4 one
day protect the pawn but then I realized
it really didn't need to I didn't need
my knife for that like I could always
just go Queen B3 so maybe the Knight
could have gone to F3 but okay 92 92 is
one of the main moves Knight F3 sure
maybe a bit more uh games in the
database now but 92 is a very decent
move as well castle Yeah Castle okay D3
is like I mean here I was you know
pretty happy I was like okay have an
extra Pawn
um
not clear how she's gonna play she came
up with this interesting plan of A6 and
B6 right and the thing is like I was I
was definitely aware of these B5 ideas
like in the game and the game would look
like I just kind of blundered it which I
I kind of did but I also was aware of
these ideas and I mean I have to say
like yeah I wasn't so impressed with my
play in this part like like H3
um yeah before it felt like it was a bit
off well I did age three in order to
play Bishop F4 and not have like Knight
H5 so maybe because of Bishop yeah maybe
I should have gone for that I'm trying
to remember so what made me change my
mind that was one of the main lines
Bishop to E3 was also a very good move
for the same idea with B5 yeah it
doesn't come with as much power with the
pawn on yeah D4 I mean I was trying to
restrict that night but honestly I
walked right into B5 and that did not
feel good because I knew actually well
like that here I just had to hold the
game because you know how you get the
sense of danger it's like I knew this
was not this is not a position that uh
you know white is veteran despite the
extra opponent it's a position you gotta
just hope that you can neutralize
Black's activity and I mean she has the
D5 Square the play against the d-pawn
and my B Pawn is just completely
irrelevant so like you know from this
point on I was just trying to be very
careful to not let my position
deteriorate
um and you know fortunately I wasn't you
know really made and it's not like you
you didn't yeah now one question
considering Knight takes what was your
response yeah Queen A4 Queen was your
plan yeah and actually that's what I was
a little surprised by Bishop D5 that she
let me you know have Knight F4 with
Tempo
um but I thought I was like oh maybe
she's like you know playing for a win
like this because she doesn't want to
allow Queen A4 which seems like it's
going to force the queen trade and I
probably could equalize right like I was
something like this Basics yep it should
be three and it kind of petering out to
a draw so I did think that her decision
was interesting even if it did Leave the
Night On B6 kind of not in the best
position did you feel at this point that
she was trying to play for more I mean
it depends on I guess it depends exactly
what she's thinking and playing this
move because she was saying that she
played that on Bishop D5 she was
actually surprised by Knight F4 so then
I can understand why she played it
because
she was saying that she thought like
Knight F4 would eventually get hit with
G5 and I would have problems on G2 but
you know after rookie one it didn't turn
out that way so then in a way then maybe
what was the problem with yeah well I
could go like you know Knight age five
and I mean it's also very double-edged
yeah like here I mean okay I was gonna
say the not only Knight G7 there's even
Queen G4 is a move that you can look at
um I mean so it definitely is dangerous
yeah it doesn't feel like black is the
one playing for anything here so she she
couldn't go for these ideas and that
means kind of well you see I never
wanted to put my Pawn on F3 right
because it's just so ugly so ugly to put
that pawn there weaken the E3 Square the
D4 Pawn would check
um so this way at least I got to play
carefully I see the computer likes my
Bishop F1 oh he does it it certainly so
careful yeah
I mean like we were looking at after the
game with her after this move Queen A4
instead of Bishop takes E3 because I was
thinking it's like her only chance I can
show you the line that we looked at and
see what the computer thinks after
Bishop E3
yeah I thought like Queen A4 was you
know something that she could try to
make it a little bit unpleasant for me
and then there's this line so Queen
takes A4 Knight A4 Rook D1
and E5
and and here we looked at Knight E2
Knight takes B2 and Rook B1 like and we
were like looking at this position it's
kind of amazing because it looked like
white was holding on yes and white is
holding on yeah
Bishop takes D4 and it's going to be a
draw
so
um I mean but I would have had to kind
of find something make a few decisions
still after Queen A4 yeah it's also not
unclear that this is actually just a
draw yeah right
um but you know when she took on E3 then
I knew okay I was definitely out of
danger
um I was going to be able to move my B
Pawn up and she has to trade the knights
otherwise you know she might get some in
trouble yeah it felt like after this uh
after you missed this move B5 you kind
of set your mind on just equalizing and
pulling the brakes yep is that how you
felt as well and even towards the end
you didn't even try for more yeah well
it's hard to try for more because you
could lose you know
um I didn't I mean we can look it at the
end
um since we have so much time Christian
until the the match between uh Favi and
aronian resumes but like uh King I
thought she might try queen of Fate here
yeah Queen E5
Queen D6
and yeah well here I was planning to
trade the queens and I thought like okay
um it was more like I was thinking yeah
I was thinking could I be better could I
you know or not so I mean I'm not
surprised you didn't go for this one but
it's hard for me to to play for a win
when she has his diagonal and always F3
squared D5 square with the queen so
um it felt like a normal point to wrap
things up at absolutely now talk to us
about uh Alice Lee you know her from
last year what changed in this one year
period
oh wow
experience
a lot
had a really good season in the protest
League you know playing against a lot
stronger players uh really successfully
um so you know I mean she was young and
talented a year ago and she's like young
and talented and more experienced now
after a year
um I mean it's nice to see her progress
I'm looking forward to her playing on
the Olympia team you know in Budapest in
2024 I think we definitely need some
young players joining the team
um and yeah I mean I'm also enjoying the
match with her and you know hopefully
we're gonna play even more exciting game
tomorrow you are the one Grand Master in
this competition do you feel like she
has Grand Master potential as well yeah
definitely of course yeah I mean if she
just keeps doing what she's doing and
playing at the at the rate that she's
playing at and just seeking out that
stronger competition and working on her
game I mean I don't see any reason why
in a few years she couldn't be a GM guys
join join the conversation we still have
a few minutes before the big match
starts oh first of all uh Irina I
couldn't agree with you more I think
Alice Lee is just one of the great
talents of America and watching her gain
experiences you said is marvelous I see
her as a future anchor of the Olympic
team so definitely uh all the way there
so I would offer you the advice of
Victor Corson or beat him while they're
young
absolutely
Jovi
yeah I know I didn't really have too
many questions for arena but uh
I'm kind of interested about how you
approach this tournament though as a
whole
like oh how I'm approaching it as a
whole okay that's the question um
I mean I would say I approach it the
same way I approach all my tournaments
obviously I'm you know doing my best uh
trying to be
you know kind of clever in the
preparation what kind of um you know
openings I'm choosing against my
opponents you know and I feel like
overall I've played you know pretty
decently like a pretty decent level of
Chess you know this game seems a little
bit bad from you know compared to some
of the other ones I've played
um but on the other hand like even here
you know once I saw there was a problem
like you know I just kind of I mean I
was able to take care of it before it
devolved into anything serious you know
it's kind of like when you have a little
bit of a leak and you just you know plug
that leak and it doesn't get any worse
so from that point of view I think I did
my job in this game of course you know
it's a different story that I didn't
make anything of the white pieces you
know and completely um
played rather
you know lackadaisically for a couple of
moves there in the opening
um but you know okay there's there's
going to be a second game and hopefully
I'm just going to be able to like
play some good good chess now Irina
you're uh also a coach a teacher but you
also have a new YouTube channel oh yeah
correct let's give it a shout out what
do you teach there all right Christian
yeah you're my my fellow YouTuber yes
you know I also watch your channel
Christian with uh with Fabiano
to get all the latest test news and um
yeah a couple of months ago I started my
channel it's actually like my first time
talking about it publicly like you know
the reference I made at the beginning of
the tournament as well but up until that
point I haven't even let people know
about it
um because I was just trying to add more
content do more videos and yes I do use
my coaching experience like really
because I you know work with people
every day so I get to see what are the
common mistakes mistakes and thinking at
this level that a lot of casual players
are at you know and and I try to
um you know focus on that in the videos
like every video has some sort of
instructive takeaway Point Irina thank
you very much we'll see you tomorrow
yeah
congratulations Arena good luck tomorrow
uh in your game
we're going to take a very very short
break Jovi yes because uh we have
playoffs looming between Iranian and
Fabiana carrona and we'll get our
technical all together we'll see you on
the other side
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
we are back and we have one match
remaining but it is the playoff we have
been waiting for it is between Fabiana
karona and Levon aronian and in a few
minutes they are going to be seated in
that table that we just saw and here we
could see the match up because it was
one point a piece
victories by both players in the playoff
scenario what are we facing now yes and
we are facing two games
players will play a 10 minute plus 5
Second increment and if the match is
still tied we are going to move on to
Blitz playoff where time gets slashed to
three minutes plus two second increments
and finally if there's still nothing to
tell the two apart then we move on to
Armageddon where there will be a winner
absolutely and for me in this match uh
it's been a tale of the white pieces
um both players have been winning with
the white pieces as we see their rapid
match-up uh 17 wins yeah and lost his 23
draws that's a lot of games in Rapid but
uh Bobby's gonna have to work on his
black pieces what he played against
Wesley and what he played against LeBron
today it didn't work not at all not at
all and actually the players actually
followed the same pattern with the black
pieces I mean both of them played a very
sharp line both of them found themselves
in trouble with their King super early
on and uh Christian what is your take on
this whole match well actually the way I
see it is that Levon has done everything
perfectly except the fact that he didn't
play that move H5 so with the black
pieces in fact he got a better position
it is still Fabiano caruana who needs to
change something he needs to change
something with the white pieces and he
definitely needs to change something
with the black pieces he lost in that
our hungers against Wesley saw yesterday
we've seen that that is his weakness it
seems in this event levonaronian took
full advantage of it and here's a game
with the white pieces and right now it
seems like Fabi needs to change
something with both colors this is going
to be a very very interesting playoff to
watch and this is the bracket of the
elimination yeah tournament the players
are fighting for survival so whoever
wins this matchup will move on to the
next stage whoever loses we say sadly a
big goodbye and whoever wins we'll be
facing Dominguez with open arms exactly
will be a very exciting match but is
this going to be a match that fulfills
your promise of an Armageddon yes no
I want to see an I know
but I want to see one I know but I'm
just thinking they're so evenly maybe
these guys could take it all the way but
I have to say I mean it really like
Christian kind of says you know it
really depends on the black pieces I
mean how they handle that we saw
yesterday Fabiano crashed out to Wesley
so you know because he was very shaky
with the black side of an archangel what
is he gonna do now players already
Petrov I think Fabiano is going to go
down to his lost love the Petrov right
and he had such great games in the
pattern of such great results back in
the days in the Battle of recently he's
more of a rui Lopez Italian or hangouts
and a lot of iterations of the Roy Lopez
but who knows he can still play the
petrol I can guarantee you that
the the players uh seem to be very
chatty with one another as they get
ready for this uh crucial elimination
playoff uh they're just like hey man
it's good to see you yeah you're looking
fine well it was interesting yesterday
uh we went to dinner with Bobby his
second uh beg him was also there my
student and
um we went somewhere close to levon's
place because he lives and he was
walking strolling around and he saw us
in the restaurant uh window he came
inside and he invited all of us to tea
and then Fabi said no I'm gonna play you
tomorrow I'm playing you tomorrow we
need to keep some distance right between
ourselves at least until this match is
over exactly and uh well Lavon has been
pretty stubborn with his one E4 in this
event he's uh tried his best we expect
E4 once again and will we see the Petra
yes no quick yes no oh
and look at this I mean I'm telling you
so those players believe in their
openings they're stubborn
girls
Bishop C5 right
and do you just play bishopy no Jesus
said okay
maybe borrowing a page from Shaq
lamidarov with his G7 G6 lines
yes yes why not and it works against uh
White C4 as well as White's C3 it's an
interesting wrinkle
right
Well normally in the uh Louis Lopez
white is not playing D3 D4 so oftentimes
when you're trying to play G6
fianchetto you you face a breakout in
the center with D4 which is a little
awkward in this particular case
you don't have such worries because the
Pawn's still on D3 Knight to D7
intimating that F7 F5 is on Black's
agenda right the same type of ideas
right that we've seen previously we've
seen uh those with the bishop on the
other side of the board in the previous
game and black Fabiano that is had huge
problems with his King's safety now with
the bispawn G7 the king feels much more
secure exactly and D3 D4
okay an invitation by the way that's
actually uh jumped out as a novelty
everybody up to this moment had played
the move Knight H2
which kind of everybody being only like
three players well there you go all
three I should put it like that but D4
very logical looking move and well I
played Knight D7 for a reason let me
guess that it's F7 F5
um by the way Bishop is trapped there is
a threat of F5 F4 trapping this bishop
be careful on E3 yes exactly be careful
yes it's true white does need to be
careful for the time being but Fabi
really playing very aggressively there
surprisingly so it feels like it's
playing right into levon's head
because E4 takes the F5 G takes I will
Rook takes F5 would just be a horrible
uh strategic approach and after Bishop
C2 you're probably just much much worse
he takes F5 renews the threat F4 and
sorry Christian you're about to say that
uh something about this position is good
for white well I just don't like the
approach the overall very very
aggressive approach that Fabiano is
displaying in this match so far because
I feel Levon is really embracing those
type of positions he loves when the
center is open he loves when there is
creativity available in the position and
this is what we're seeing right now
okay but he's facing an awkward threat
uh he's F4 so this Knight on D2 has to
move maybe we have to start with Bishop
takes E6 I mean how do we meet
the problem the problem Bishop takes
Knight seems to be to me quite natural
and then okay you need to make room for
the bishop so I would be tempted to move
the knight from D2 and move it to usage
okay Bishop takes C6 B take C6
okay so at least in this case we're
secure in case of f4 we don't
necessarily have to retreat we could uh
potentially Play Bishop C5 but it's two
Bishops uh aren't we happy is black that
we've earned the two Bishops it does
feel like black isn't just fine right
now right is it time to just play Queen
to F6 you kind of cover the pawn over
here maybe on a good day the bishop gets
to go to H3 with the queen on G6 we've
seen those uh things before and by the
way the players have followed this line
are we transposed to uh another players
are following us so they are like Fabi
is actually taking that same decision
right that you talked about you know
developed the queen is he going to push
forward with the pawns right continue
with his aggressive paths exactly quick
question for you F4 do you would you
retweet to d2c1 or would you go to the
C5 Square
yeah I would be tempted to go there but
okay this does need calculation yeah
I'll never Retreat
okay
exactly and it just feels like white
spaces are kind of loose and hanging a
little bit right I mean because E4 and
the bishop on C5
well sorry what's the bishop doing on C5
what's the Knight doing on B3 yes yes
yes yes and give it a time give it time
now now you're gonna do this I'm gonna
go Bishop to D4 and say let's trade
let's look at your king
I like it 95 let's go or Knight F6 now
if you go 95 I'm taking that pawn so you
have to go hmm
yes you are yes you are but okay let's
keep going 95 so I'm kind of curious F3
let's go
uh you want to start with F3 yes I I
want to test the waters
uh
G3 yes they wanted to test
you're really going for it one second it
doesn't work because I can Retreat the
bishop
okay Knight takes F3 yes that's my idea
only takes F3
rats but you're close I mean and you
don't have to go Queen H5 I know but I
was uh you could go King G7 and that did
look terrifying okay in F6 so Queen F6
is a preparation a preparatory move for
uh
F4 E4 it's all good knight B3
Queen F6 what I like
so quickly rookie one
rookie eight
okay so this kind of sidesteps the tempo
of Bishop C5 so it does mean that F4 and
E4 are coming quickly and now I
understand why previous games have gone
Knight H2 just kind of getting out of
the way of that uh what what if I
actually go Queen to D2 the very natural
but you were inviting yes you were the
poems to yeah
we sure did I mean
Head Over Heels or heels overhead
something like that Queen C2
okay now you can go F4
okay but at least I guess in this case
I've taken over the E4 Square so it
means that if I do have to move my
Bishop at least not uh facing
um but this feels very shaky because you
know you can see trades happening the
bishop on C8 will come to life
okay I'm thinking it's time to just
reroute this guy go play Knight f8
Knight G6 leave your pawns on these
beautiful squares E5 and F5 control as
much as the center as possible just get
your knight to a
good aggressive post on G6 I think
that's that that's the right plan I mean
I I agree I I gave up control over the
C5 Square I just say go ahead and use it
then he should do that after night Earth
hate you should come forward because
you've got to be ready with some control
over E4 right so
35. that's the common sequence of your
last movement yes but nothing I can do
about that one no the night's over there
but I can you do have a loose piece on
E8 so can I pile on the pressure
that's something crazy like Bishop to D4
yes well right now I've got that guy
defended once I've got E5 defended once
twice Thrice
but now I can go Queen F7 which is going
to actually uh
right okay that was not the intention
no it wasn't but I like the aggression
you know the aggressive intent yeah okay
but uh outside of knight f8 uh well he's
he's thinking about his uh he's thinking
for a very long time right now last five
minutes and 30 seconds just having to
refresh my board
he's down to what I'm sorry five minutes
and 30 seconds against eight minutes and
15 or 13 seconds by the way that was
really so overwhelmingly true in the
rapid game it was like 18 minutes for
for Lavon three minutes
I mean he was really burning clock uh
greatly I want to say and he finished
with 10 minutes or to live on in one
second or for Fabiano he played one move
with one second yes and at one moment he
was down to the scene also his last five
minutes this is not an encouraging sign
for Fabiano right now no
nope and he has to bear in mind that
he's getting less increment per move as
well because it's only five seconds
exactly well again outside of Knight f8
okay I was about to say
besides Knight f8 what could he play and
he found it Queen F7 was his alternative
well I must say not that inspired by
Queen of seven the problem with this
type of long things is that not only
that you burn your clock but your
confidence level kind of decreases as
well yeah I agree with that yeah because
you're like I'm not finding moves I I I
cannot make my decisions in time and
this guy is just blitzing his moves he's
making decisions so confidently what am
I doing wrong you start doubting
yourself you start asking these type of
questions agree uh why this move uh Jovi
uh is it what is it about Queen F7
that's attractive well I I liked it you
did I did like it for the primary reason
that I it's not very easy for white to
come up with a plan let's be honest
about that and the Queen on F7 does
protect the king very good news when
your king is exposed but also it can
transfer itself to age five which is
what I I have the Golden Rule yes and
the golden rule is you want to try you
you want to attack my my king so there
was this move Knight A5 with the idea
Queen B3 to trade queens and to tickled
the pawn on C6 Lavon played Rook D1 E4
Knight D4 right away now you're about to
explain to me that the queen can go to
H5 in certain moments yes absolutely
95. I'm I'm assuming or either that or
F4 well F4 does have a drawback right
yes
okay the pawn on C6 is hanging upon on
e4 is hanging but anything outside of f4
also well 95 no no now we understand
that the queen on F7 also has purpose it
did does defend the Rook I don't think I
want to do that though what do you want
I think I want to do Knight E2
Knight E2 and go to F4 he is me Knight
E2 beautiful
[Music]
now you're gonna sacrifice in exchange
probably have to because you don't want
to allow F4 I'm sure about that F4 F3
and Bishop takes H3 uh I mean I
understand if you get a knight to F4
you're happy but uh okay let's try to be
a bit more clinical right now what if I
go
Knight to C5 I don't want to allow you
to go too deep I like Knight to C5 it
covers D3 brings your knight which isn't
doing that much I must say
he's going for it it sure is
F4 okay Bishop to C1 we can anticipate
this one
quickly quickly and uh okay so the big
thing is obviously you've got to start
kicking with the white Knights what
about C5
indeed C5 everything with Tempo yep I
like it
C5 let me just pause here for a moment
because
um
okay uh 92. oh keep going yep F3 F3 now
the question is
am I
am I exposing my king or am I
uh
am I in trouble C5 is on the board it's
the most challenging reaction probably
down to his last two minutes and 49
seconds against six minutes and 50
seconds but don't you guys feel like
fabby's going all in on these last few
movies yeah like I mean there's no he's
Bridge burning there's no
recovering from this and he we do have
Knight E2 I think F3 is it's forced it's
forced at this point yeah yeah F3 is
forced and then you just went all in
if it works it's great genius yes
exactly but if it doesn't you're going
to lose it miserable strategical way I
mean that's just the way it is to quote
Luber laboyovic if it doesn't work
you're gonna lose miserably
miserably okay E3 not F3 not even F3 E3
whoa ah this this move has a lot of
point to it as well because you know
when I was like yeah F3 and also you
extend the line for the light Square
Bishop you can park itself on B7 is that
true just a second I take F3 Rook F1
Knight F4 I think
and kind of not Rook F1
Rook F1 I'm a bit concerned about
actually taking on E2 and taking on D1
and taking on F7 I've got Queen F35 or
queen ft three he played takes and he
has played F3 as expect again all in
all in uh these last four or five moves
by Fabi he's gone talked up at night
no funny business with Rook F1 that felt
like the right move to me as well and
what about Bishop bisa
but Bishop B7 I mean after all if you're
going to if you're going to put a Pawn
on F3 and you're going to take you might
as well put your Bishop on B7 as well
the desirable Knight Knight B Queen B3
how do we feel about the exchange
sacrifice oh then you're gonna try it
off Queens go to rule I I've learned
from the best
ladies commentator visually it doesn't
feel like Fabiano has enough attackers
to complete successfully this attack
what nobody is over on the king side
where the party's over right yeah
nobody's over there I mean yeah I get
the idea that you're attacking but your
knight your Rook on A8 your Bishop on C8
um you have to sacrifice another Pawn
with Knight D5 no Bishop to B7 he's done
and we we were looking at Knight A5 I
must fight I must say I'm attracted to
not move in order to trade Queens
there's a big opportunity right now
which takes D7 yes
let's calculate Route 67 Queen takes D7
no it takes Pawn Knight takes C5
Queen has to go to I guess C6 but then
you have a check C6 is probably no I
have to go to B5 B5 yes to stop yes
but this is
attractive because I'm looking at Queen
G6 possibilities this looks
like I guarantee you Levon is looking at
this as well
but you know hang on a second if you
calm down and you're like okay I gotta
restore connection between the queen and
the black king you can just make moves
like for instance Queen B6 but that's
three Pawns
for the exchange right now I've got two
if you just allow me as you were about
to say if you just allow me to take a
third Pawn I got a feeling I'm liking
white okay so there is this moment on
the other hand can I play Queen G6
I mean that is still a night hanging on
D7 right
I mean
and I wouldn't mind terribly trading
Queens
uh does look like opportunity here for
Lavon uh that's right that's why he's
thinking that's why he stops he's
thinking he feels the critical moment is
coming he's feels like he's Reaching
Forward G6
once every broadcast here it comes you
ready well these guys are good
they are so good
Queen G6
Jovi's golden rules when when you feel
your opponent's attacking your king to
trade Queens
and I must say that the more you look at
it it's not bad Pawn on C5 that's a very
uh tender Target
Queen takes G6 Knight takes G6 Knight to
F4 back Rook to d8 and the simple Knight
F4 back do we take on G2 or do we uh
yeah you have to extend the ambition
right
you have to take on G2 you just don't
want to see this Pawn even
going to E4 uh and somehow losing a
Tempo is why you don't you don't want to
see E4 on the board and uh talking about
the clock times yes Bobby is 47 47
seconds and it's ticking down and
remember he only get a five second
increment per move so basically right
now
they're playing a Blitz game yes in
which Levon has almost five minutes four
minutes 30 seconds again
wow that's not even on my radar I like
that move and I was wondering E4 is just
resigns E4 resigns no E4 resigns because
you can't take with the Rook why can't I
take with the bishop then I take on F3
and I take the rook and I take the
Knight five
okay just a second E4 Bishop takes E4
Pawn takes F3 Bishop F5 so I'm a pawn up
and
no no way of pinning and winning
you do have a knight takes C5 though
Knight takes no not right now but in the
instead of Mercury
uh
okay Bishop is on A8 so just a second if
you go Bishop back
I could also play 90 I don't know this
looks really attractive to me I would
play E4 by the way after E4 can I take
on G2 first like uh-huh E4 Pawn takes G2
I know your tactics already yesterday
you tell me how winning you are and no
this is so good every sign I mean come
on okay Knight to D5 Knight to D5 so
let's see E4 after HD2 put it on the
board oh sorry E4 F takes G2 Knight to
D5
and um finally Knight to E5 why not
Knight to E5 why not
and I have to take the I have to pause
I don't want to see Knight F3 check and
how can I go C4 followed by
Knight D3 if you allow me yeah but
you're not going to allow me this is uh
well uh it it's not as clean as I
thought I must say let's put it that way
I was hoping for something a lot simpler
uh
okay if I don't play
well one thing is for sure this moment
this bishop to A8 definitely forced a
pause from the one because now he's down
to his last two minutes he had four
minutes so he spent four minutes and 30
seconds now he's down to enormous amount
of time on this moment so he obviously
feels it's crucial
and it probably
is he's probably right but I mean I
think I would have played E4
several minutes ago uh just because I I
really wanted to close that diagonal and
to put a knight on D5 maybe he's looking
at the immediate Knight defense I was
gonna say 95
because you know if you provoke F6 well
yep
Oh you mean provoke C6 yeah sorry yeah
yeah that Bishop on a will hate you for
the rest of the game so that's
good what he took and immediately Knight
E5 this was in my book almost an illegal
move yeah you don't want it you don't
want to allow the night with it well you
got to go King F2 you have to yeah so
you kind of bit the night well yeah then
the Knight captures this is not what you
wanted with white
surely not
I mean because now the Knight has a
beautiful Square C4 C5 C4 okay well
Knight takes you for I mean Knight to C4
Knight is
I'll get there Knight to C5
and he goes for it
E6 is looking tender
still you have your your E4 ideas on tap
oh absolutely I'm Dreaming to close that
bishop and maybe on a good day even use
the G file that would be uh 20 seconds
F6 reminding white you got a king too he
takes and that come on e4
treatment to eat too wait wait wait a
minute you need to he's very fast and
he's showing that Knight H4 96 wait a
minute how do you defend no sorry Knight
h496 and the bishop on F6 is hanging the
other night
26. oh yes oh yes wait how how do you
defend now ten well there's a rook D1 as
Rook takes F3 of Five Seconds to find
out
D6 okay because there's a rook D1 if we
take twice Rook will come to D1 and it
will ensnare the bishop but then I go
92.
then that wins Rook takes F3 is a winner
and he's done it had did Fabi just like
uh black out on 92. I think it did oh he
just shook his head I must say signaling
the fact that he missed this yeah okay
but is this such a disaster I was
thinking
and he gives a check no but King G2 now
and then rookie one
and then when you play King F2 Bishop H4
check
oh maybe he lucked out
because this is so this is a draw then
the king not quite so fast so what if I
so I go King G2 rookie one Knight E4
inviting you to take my Nike in G4
rookie one perhaps not only four right
uh sorry he went King G4 immediately
apologies and maybe now is the time to
provoke that King to take a step forward
with H5 sorry what about this I go King
F3 back now I go King G2 yes then I go
King F2 I
force your Bishop to go to H4 and then I
go King F3 back okay and then when you
give me the check on F1 I go King G4 and
I attack the bishop which is exactly
what he's done nice catch there uh
Christian because then the bishop will
be hanging oh after Rook F1 he found it
this is over yeah two pieces will
overpower The Rook two pieces and a pawn
a very important part that e-pawn
exactly exactly by the way F7
[Music]
this was not a move he wanted to make no
it's just it gives gives white the
opportunity he needs to maybe play a
move like night to E4 and bring the
Knight to G3 like a very sensible move
Knight to E4 Knight to G3 just to
reinforce but yeah by the way E4 yes
liberate that Bishop
no indeed and Rook checking of boy did
Lavon jump at that opportunity to play
King
and Knight takes A6 why not give me that
pawn
Rook E1
and he's gonna do the same thing it's
like some sort of a triangulation
process it's almost a study it's
incredible and you cannot do anything
about it King to F to Bishop to H4 check
King to F3
so crafty what a concept that's art
right there exactly it truly is
and now we've got Bishop takes H6
potential you can take that you can take
on C7 well I'm just saying the bishop on
C1 has been such a horrifyingly uh
passive piece now you you took away a
crucial
uh counter play uh Pawn upon that might
have been for counter Play Bishop back
to F4 and now you're now you're home and
dry now it's very easy
yeah yeah this one is uh it's looking
like it might be close to over yeah
because we've got to pass a pawn two in
the position which makes it so much
easier
I'm still stunned by this King G2 King
F2 King F3 it's nice with only a few
seconds only exactly King F3 yep
by the way Knight E3 is ready to pick up
some more ponds over there and uh the
white king stepping forward I mean each
time that King comes to G4 there's a
bishop nicely waiting for the king to
arrive in the tempo Bishop E3 E3 again
very nice eyeballing this Pawn all the
squares stopping Rook F2 you're right
about that yeah
but also just let me take a look at how
protected
he can step back
okay not again he can move the knife
no but each time he wins a crucial Tempo
and picks up a pawn he can just move the
knights the bishop is protected but
that's not it's not only that
it also frustrates Fabiano oh without
question this is so frustrating right
now oh without question that is so true
you just feel like
you know you're on the wrong side of a
study
that's how it feels
now the bishop goes to D4 once again
finds this perfect square King goes to
F5 King in the middle King F5 is a
King F5 E5 Knight to F4 E6 to win the
game
wow well I I I will borrow what you said
this was Art very very very artistically
played and uh Lavon will be very pleased
with this game because that whole King
G4 we saw once twice I mean this is like
really good great stuff it feels so good
about himself right now right and once
again that's dangerous if you are facing
him in a must-win situation as father is
right right but then again Fabi had his
chances yesterday with the white pieces
against Wesley he surely will try to
find something in this match as well and
I was talking about it at the beginning
of this playoff he needs to do something
differently with the white pieces also
because
in their initial encounter Fabi did play
this move C for the floor McKenna's but
he didn't get much out of the opening it
was in fact Levon who had the advantage
Fabi will have to go back and understand
what he needs to do differently I'm very
very eager to see what he's going to
come up with for the and again and this
playoff of Lavon takes an early lead
against our defending champion and
probably will have to win to extend the
match for those of us joining as late uh
first of all shame on you but what
really really caught our eye Christian
was this beautiful concept right here
and it happened not only once but
several times King F3 Rook F1 check and
it's like this awkward thing your your
piece is you know like the night on E2
the bishop on it you see one or stuck
the King has to defend so then you go
okay but I have Bishop H4 check and then
the point is is that after Rook F1
uh you you get to pick up this Tempo
against the bishop with King G4 and it
was a theme that recurred uh several
times in this game here we go and here
we see it again Levon just being mean to
be honest it was unnecessary I thought
it was great there we saw it again
and
one more time you know that was like
it's not a three three move repetition
you know I picked up a few pawns yeah
nice nice nice we just tip our hat and
say uh and it was the only way out in
fact I was looking at uh at the end of
the engine right now it's the only way
to not have to uh accept the repetition
right with Rook F1 rookie one Rook F1
rookie one exactly it's King to have to
get the bishop to H4 and then go King to
F3 to attack the beautiful beautiful
this is Art yeah the one linear
Dominguez is certainly it is her in his
room uh watching this uh match because
the the winner will play against him
tomorrow tomorrow exactly in a rapid
match and of course it was a wild game
so just now and both players now need to
reset because there is a second game on
the horizon and this time Fabiano will
have the white pieces and when will that
uh game begin
any moment now
are we just a couple minutes away uh
sorry uh Christian you were saying that
the Fabi needs to do something more with
the white pieces he's not getting uh the
the good stuff yes and perhaps I should
show it uh let's see if I can find that
game this was the crucial game today he
started off with the move C4 Knight F6
this Knight C3 floor Mickey Mouse with
E6 D5 against E4 and we got to this
position Bishop to F5 by the way I was
explaining it's the most precise move in
the position D4 take take take the three
Bishop D5 but the problem is after
Knight to C6 Bishop to F4 H6 Bishop to
G3 G5
Queen 24 was the bat perhaps this is it
we found the answer as well Bishop to G3
was a good move instead of the move
Queen to A4 19. maybe this is what he's
going to try to come up with right to D2
and try to open up the position with the
move F4 transfer this Knight potentially
on the other side of the board but also
open up the discussion of maybe trading
off this force of nature on D5 the
bishop on D5 with the move Bishop to F3
this might be what Fabiano is going to
be coming back with let's see okay let's
see I do think that lives different none
of that none of that we have we have E4
no C4
we're going to see Levon try to batten
down the hatches and place something
solid
yes looking for
the game but I can't find it ah
we had the wrong the Berlin
Berlin with Knight to dito Bishop 36
Castle Bishop D6 back a very solid
approach by Levon we expect this he only
needs a draw to finish the match remain
in the competition
and kick the defending Champion out of
the competition right now a golden
opportunity for the honoronia
what is that Knight doing on B3 I must
ask it's allowing the bishop to get out
that's about it
not much else
see Queen D7 inviting Bishop F6
Fabi wanted no part of that and he
played Bishop H4
mm-hmm
Bishop two H4
I assume it's Bishop G3 Bishop G3 and
then try to play for C3 D4 is that is
that the plan well to take the pawn on
E5
and I'm presuming that the Knight is
gonna go to C4 and sit on E3 yeah I
don't like the queen on D7 but I do like
the queen on A4 funnily enough what do
you think about that you go Queen A4 you
kind of stop C3 you kind of stuff they
play B3 right yeah okay three and A4 and
put the Knight on C C4 and start looking
at the E5 Pawn okay Queen A4 B3 Queen B4
I'm just lurking
is on an odyssey exactly exactly it's a
closed position I mean in the close in
these type of closed positions you can
get away with Maneuvers like this
exactly
do you have that in a queen Sally yeah
Queen sortie well the sortie yes but
Sally yeah I've had it Queen Sally but
it's okay
I'm slipping here a knight G5 Knight H5
Knight G5
okay he obviously he wants to play for
night F4
mm-hmm
but Knight F4 was that
allow me to go a G3
G3 Knight to H3
well no wait a minute I mean G3 Knight
to G6
oh yes what have you done that's not a
nice way of treating a bishop I agree
yeah isn't um
fabiana's plan to trade off the night
yes bishop and then then swap off his
Knight for the light Square bishop and
say I've got good night against Bad
Bishop that's exactly the
the point he's trying to make now he
takes E6 I'm assuming Queen takes E6 and
then you say Swap this one off too
and then play Knight versus Bishop
nope he's played Knight takes E6 he said
maybe you did have the intention of
taking my knight on F1 Knight to C4 F6
the bishop on D6 is well and truly a bad
piece but they do say bad Bishops make
excellent Defenders and those uh are
good pawns that he is defending uh for
the moment this bishop on H4 which is
your good Bishop is exactly a great
diagonals like uh
how are we going to get eventually we're
going to have to play a break right
whether it be C3 or C3 D4 or F4 you've
got to get in a break and it very much
depends on where the Blackness castles
excuse me that was just well yeah I
agree with it you Christian but I mean
the problem is that if you go F3 I mean
the position is so closed that you can
even go G5 okay yeah let's play F3 A5 by
the way takes away another potential
break a3c3 B4 you're not going to be
doing that
oh okay he's gone age five
same idea what did he do after H5 and
now A4 A5 A5 A4 A5 A4 and H5 H5
whoa is that saying that okay I believe
racking is not going to Castle yeah
yeah well the same is completely closed
but I must say it's not every day that
you see A5 attacking on the queen side
followed by H5 it I mean you're trying
to take over the entire board you know
A5 H5
84. well he is trying to take away and
guess what he's he's trying to shut down
F4 and for the moment he's saying I
don't believe C3 and D4 will bring you
Advantage so I'm not going to allow you
F4
that's okay
H3 H3
okay so I mean if I'm
if I'm intuiting uh Lavon I'm thinking
he's going to play G5
G5 does give
R square great you have one good piece
well done me that's it right you you put
your knight on F5 and you know then you
can start working your way up with C3
you still have to break D4 again
I would say that I have more than one
good piece
I'll go see three after that
by the way
Colin who visited Us in the studio from
the Make-A-Wish Foundation kid he just
struggling with cancer he said I want to
go to St Louis I want to visit the St
Louis chess club and I want to meet
these guys
and he said very clearly that Hikaru is
somebody loves watching on the Stream
and he's wearing that beautiful American
Cup jacket yeah and then we do have oh
sorry we do have G5
oh that was very nice that's really nice
and you've made a big promise yes sir to
get his letterman jackets side
and look at Chris bird how attentive he
is
I mean that's that's a true Arbiter
right there
he's actually a chess lover
he's like he's got he's got a front row
seat he wants to enjoy it there was a
funny comment on Twitter of a picture of
Chris bird watching over one of the
playoff matches yes and the comment was
saying Chris bird more like Chris
vulture Chris Walter
yeah
yeah they're very attentive okay well we
have a development because LeBron has
castled Queen side which does mean that
Fabiano's job is now a lot easier he has
to open a line over there as yes as
indicator
I think this is a good news Aviano yeah
but good luck with that well first of
all D3 is hanging so it's going to take
preparation to play C3 and look at how
many times B4 has been defended so he's
basically said uh you know you've got
one good uh piece the Knight on F5 your
Rook on A1 it's not great on F1 I I
don't I don't disagree with you the only
thing is that the reason why I'm saying
is good news for Fabi is because the
plan the long-term plan has now become
clear he can just like improve his
pieces I mean he's simply going to move
his Queen now he has to actually drop
back to E3
I I know but you know he eventually the
plan is going to be clear this neither
five seems to have been a misstep though
yeah yeah was it mistimed I think so
because Knight D4 just forces the trade
and what do you trade on D4 with is the
question well if you take with the
bishop so yeah
Bishop takes C5 tags and the bishop will
go to C5 I might be strapped yeah
there's no way to get uh any play in the
position so he's gonna have to retrieve
93. even if it Retreats then he's done
it it's also possible for Lavon to start
thinking about breaking through or
playing solidly okay so he also Retreats
whoa now I would not have played that I
would have played King B7 and just said
deal with the Knight on D4 I would want
to provoke the move for C3 King H2 King
B7 King B7
situation both sides are very evenly
much
around the seven and a half and seven
minute Mark yeah
darkness in Norwegian does it yeah okay
wow
and uh well with your what is it six
months of winter
Mark's a favorite time of the year I'm
sure
Knight to C4 uh Christian I gotta tell
you this is a dream position for Lavon
all he needs is a draw to to knock Fabi
out of the tournament and it's blocked
as block can be yeah yeah it's great
yeah and I don't see the the plan is it
B3 Queen B2 followed by C3 and B4 if you
manage to get all of those moves sure
yes but whenever you go B3 queen beat y
just Retreat my knight to C6 and you
cannot play the move C3 because the pawn
on D3 is hanging so I just don't see the
active plan at the same time
take it down to the last minute right
make some waiting moves rookie one row
to D1 Shuffle the pieces pretend like
you're doing something like threatening
the flex exactly and then in the last
minute just throw the patties
it is what it is you might lose that's
fine you make a draw you're out of the
tournament no matter what right
yes I mean we saw Ray Robson beat Sam
Shanklin by making these lots of waiting
moves very very patient but he had the
the pawn in the pocket and uh Sam had to
you know navigate through all kinds of
ghosts in this particular case the
position is so blocked
you're gonna have to keep an eye on the
uh 50 move rule funnily enough family
enough in the middle of the game yeah in
the middle of the game it is I mean
because
I mean the 50 move rule is that if the
player doesn't make a poor move or a
capture for 50 moves then that they can
claim a draw at some point it has to go
B3 right yes B3 defend upon on A4 and
get ready to play the move C3 I'm a
little bit surprised by the move King B7
I myself would have probably played Rook
to A8 to absolutely absolutely
discourage C3 and B4 because then The
Rook on a queen on C6 would be attacking
the a pawn but
possibly a king walk to the king side is
the king side safer than the queen side
King D7 King E8
so the way I see it you have to put the
Rook from D1 on the C file
okay and then put the real Chrome A1 on
the B file okay and then go B3 and C3
and B4
okay give up the pawn on D3 and I think
in anticipation of exactly what you're
saying Christian uh Lavon is going to
say whenever you play C3 you're going to
make the pawn on D3 a Target I'll have
to give you that pawn I I will have to
say what part of my my hearings you're
going to give me what
yeah how do I sign up well eventually
that I mean Kristen is Right eventually
that's what's going to have to happen
you have to if you want you need to roll
the dice because objectively this
position is draw exactly
that's the problem
that's the problem and I was saying that
he needs to take LeBron down to his last
minute the problem is LeBron has six of
them he's slower than Lavon right now
Fabiano and he knows
d8 I don't like this doubling up let's
let's hit first mm-hmm
okay Queen to C2 defending upon on D3
now maybe B3 is going to come next B3
has to come next but that's such a slow
uh you have to defend the night on
C4 really protects everything over
protect everything are you considering
F5 I am I'm ashamed of myself but yes
you you you caught me you caught me
thinking about it don't break the
harmony yes I know I mean I shouldn't
all he needs is a draw and he's through
and I'm playing F5 trying to attack uh
fabi's King side he did play Rook d8
Rook D2 so
uh piling on the pressure but easily
thwarted with the move Rook D1 now
I'm not very pleased with the black king
on C8 there is a possibility of Queen B3
and Knight takes B6 check so
um he did play King B8 by the way which
makes sense
not only that but with a king on C8
after you open up the C file D4 exchange
on D4 and the C file opens up I have
ideas of Knight takes B6 right
fair so King on B8 seems to have found
the perfect place for black
but okay five minutes and 10 seconds
against 5 minutes and 57 seconds time to
shuffle with the bishop I think put it
back to G1
as wide that's what you know just
okay
I think he heard you and he shuffled
back with his Bishop Bishop f8 Queen B3
there's some tactics
you know Queen B5
I think say five yeah oh Knight takes A5
yeah very good
big trick on the board Lavon of course
has to be aware definitely I've noticed
that
yeah maybe it's time just to defend the
queen
uh Rook to E8 perhaps
make sense Queens can we go D4 now I I
after Route 38 maybe you can step back
D4 how many
I'm failing to calculate how many
attackers you have versus how many
Defenders I have
uh keep going yes yes yes so I think I
think it's okay but at the end of the
day
my Bishop isn't so bad you know that
right yes but I have coming to D5
finally at least I got something right
right well you got an imbalance I'm not
sure it's that favorable but you can
break out with F5 Queen he played Queen
to E8 not Rook to E8 sorry sorry Queen
to B3 Queen to E8 yeah and so Knight
takes
right
Knight takes B6 takes now the queen will
defend C6 exactly
and the attack is completely refuted No
sacrifice there
do you invade with a queen queen B5
where am I going after King B7
probably nowhere
I mean we it's sort of like we we have
the standoff yeah I mean you you've
achieved basically maximum you can draw
I'm a big fan of dropping the bishop
back to G1 okay just to kind of
be around the king and have everything
overprotected and also clear the E3 is
on the trick guys
now I go
D4
David four yes
wow
Queen E6 he actually played
um so the trick was there was something
hanging on E8 there's Knight takes A5
whenever you take with a knight on D4
working on B7 well I would be taking
pieces right yes you would be taking
pieces and I was hoping that I will be
able to Checkmate you somehow
Queen E6 as are the times a factor yet
not really both I mean levonne aronian
has lower time he's under four minutes
86. where is he going no no he's just
being uh annoying annoying
uh Queen back to E8 just saying I don't
believe is B4 a threat right now
uh quite possibly Rook F7 Rook F7 look
at some point I have to be able to go D4
now D4 starts to look far more
attractive right oh your queen could get
could your queen get top card after
takes and night before
hmm
it's a great point that is maybe the
queen B5
and C6 right Queen takes B6 and Rook B7
Queen takes d8 not that one
but I was also thinking that they're
awesome ideas of going Bishop
takes
I must say Fabby is somehow finding
something being more than irritating
he's he's getting something so now the
queen come to C8 to C8 uh Queen to C8
Queen to B5 you can't trade Queen to B7
Knight to E3 something no no look at
this no Queen to see it and one says he
has faith in his
that's exactly what he's saying with
this mover of D7 that he's he's as solid
as he can be 93 95
something
and did that
that took him down to three minutes
though yeah and they're all sacrifices
in the air like for instance if black
were to get careless and move the Bishop
from f8 Bishop C5 is just very strong
okay
and that's the way to do it right just
wait once again until one minute and
then play D4 and there we go Knight back
to A3 I was actually expecting the
Knight to go the queen B3 is that an
invitation folks
is
my Spidey Sense tingling so he's trying
to set up this bind with an item B5 it
looks ugly but
so if I drop in yes you go Knight B5 you
want to take and no yeah let's go D4
nobody believes you with your Rook on D
that's one handing that's okay I'm only
trying to open up the C file so that I
can play Rook to C1
and attack the Knight on C6
yeah that's fine I'll take it okay
gotcha
I'll take it
take this yeah
that's the idea
cool so he does not want to allow that
bind he plays Knight D7 I think that's
the right decision
Knight to A7 to stop Knight B5 stop the
night going to B5 I must say that's a
solid choice
yes
a funny looking position would come
after Knight B5 Knight takes B5 a takes
B5
uh that's not a nice way to treat a lady
the queen on A6 would really look
offsides but okay
it's so wow it might be fun that would
be
highly unusual to say the least
maybe Queen to C8 will come in that case
yeah
yeah no it's a it's not a good idea
well I tell you I have 16 pawns on the
board this light laid into the game
seems very unusual to me uh I'm Rook to
a one
okay
Bobby's doing his best to try to conjure
up some magic here but I just um I'm
having a hard time but I was also
wondering about
setting up a bishop takes C5 sacrifice
or is this too obvious
because you know you follow that through
with B
B4
and then just
give everything up
okay his last move is quite funny but
maybe that's exactly what he wants to do
Queen to see six kind of side step and
queen C4
the very very quickly played by Fabi as
he's sort of saying okay I've won this
diagonal maybe that is a useful diagonal
and maybe maybe you're right maybe he's
going for some Bishop C5 B4 type of
sacrifices Lavon down to his last minute
and an important number
to take a note of is the last porn move
was on move
33.43. okay so he's inviting to look
interesting he certainly is starting to
look interesting now Knight takes B5 a
takes B5 Queen to D7 gift meet upon
and now it's time to break through now
or never how do we do it that's my
question before I was going to take on
D3 and say you know do your worst but
this is why
I only won so your king would be
interested we'll be safe there's no
check so then I could just move my Rook
to A2 right
and there would be no check to yeah
how do you not play Queen D7 instantly
he might be worried about Bishop takes
porn about Bishop takes part precisely
so Queen D7 Bishop takes C5 let's see
how this one plays out well
if he was worried about it he's asking
Fabi are you interested
fabby's saying yeah I'm interested
because I've got to win
I've got to win Bishop takes C5
you know this might be his best chance
Bishop takes C5 and Rook takes A5 and
you're trying to hope that Queen A4 will
will net you a king thank Queen
like when I look at that kind of
position where white has sacrificed the
piece the queen can just like snake her
way to the B7 square and hold everything
off for the time being that's a really
good point yeah
Bishop C5 is actually the best move
well again I just feel like you're just
not going to get a better opportunity I
don't see B4 is bringing home
um and I don't think Rook D1 Rook A1 D1
you're just not going to get a better
opportunity than Bishop C5 right here
right now you got to go for it
if you are fobby and you need a win in
this position you have to go for that
exactly apologies is like no he goes
from D4 D4
whoa that happened oh that's a secret
super fast what a sequence that was
and well Fab he is opening up the lines
I wrote D7 Rook to D7 what is the action
of the bishop Bishop to B4 is coming
okay so B takes A5 Bishop to B4 what
else
and Lavon
I mean you know sometimes when you're
begging for the draw you really
sometimes just simply overdo efficient
before push up to B4 I take on B6 and if
you take my Rook I go Queen A3 and I
think I'm breaking through finally so
you can take on B6 you take on D2 and I
go Queen a3m but you don't need to take
off I feel there is a mate there you can
actually play Queen takes
Queen takes B6 and use the queen as
protection but of course you've got a
Facebook A2 so you I do but hold on
could I just see this because this is
actually pretty funny In This Moment
uh is it meat I don't know
because if your Bishop was on G1 you
would have Bishop H2 oh my goodness yeah
I know oh but I don't know if this is me
do you have moves like Bishop takes
well right now I'm threatening Bishop A5
his if it was my turn I played Bishop A5
so
uh but I I didn't think that this was a
mate I don't see it I don't see the mate
I just kind of like get them my running
shoes and
hightail it out of there oh boy okay so
Bishop B4 on the board what's the times
41 seconds for Fabiano and Counting 38
seconds these guys are neck to neck not
much separating the two uh Rook a two is
that no that's too slow is it is it too
slow I want to sacrifice an exchange and
play Queen A1 perhaps you have to go for
it it's 23 and tickets down to 20
seconds
Rook A2 Bishop A5 Rook A5 ba5 Rook A5 D3
Queen A1 he's done it he's done okay too
he wants to sacrifice A5 Bishop E1
sorry say that again please
Bishop they say five yes Bishop E1 oh
Bishop E1 thank you that clears some
cobwebs Bishop takes A5 Bishop E1 I
don't have to sacrifice my attackers and
maybe fabby's not out of the tournament
yet 15 seconds for both players oh and
kicking down Bishop E1 immediately
played
that is a gain of five seconds for
Fabiano that that's huge that means the
a file is going to be open he's looking
for his countershot
and no time on the clock
guys guys is Queen C6 a move yeah no D1
is coming with check
oh you're taking the Rook I beg your
pardon Queen C6 is a move it's Queen C6
six seconds
is the passive approach but he's
threatening Rook takes A5 and Rook A8
that's a huge and he's stopping D2
whoa whoa whoa five seconds and he's
ready to draw oh that is clever Basics
oh that was clever by Lavon
Queen to E5 what a move Rook to B8 and
King B7 he's gonna hide the king to B7
oh my good right now yeah that's what
he's B6
you want to hide on C8 no way no no no
no way five
and Lavon but having to take these
decisions with no time on the clock it's
all about nerves now I don't know this
is starting to look good for Fabiano
guys he takes D3 and that King is wide
open
truly
so you don't survive these type of
positions with 16 seconds on the clock
in general no you don't I mean you don't
survive them but look at that king walk
I mean that King is getting all the way
to G6
he's running he's a runner he can run it
to King E8 what now you can put your
queen on A7
okay I think he wants to go Rook to d8
to make sure that there's always a rook
D1 checks I will take that pawn on B6
yes oh I'm sorry but still you can
why not I mean I mean and might as well
take a pawn right Queen G7 okay
okay actually you're right why didn't he
take the pawn uh B5 he wants more B5 he
really wants more B5 no Queen F4
we cannot go to C7 threaten Checkmate
because you get checkmated first right
exactly The Rook is on priest
well B5 uh you need a decoy
Queen E5
Lavon you got five seconds
Lavon why didn't you go Queen E5 you
just attacked The Rook attack it again
E5 whoa what is going on I don't know
Queen takes E5 Queen takes E5 he doesn't
go for it he goes for Queen to have fate
what how much time did that take two
seconds for Fabi he needs to make a move
one second
check
this yeah
you gotta go Queen E5 now no that's a
check on A7 what is that a check F6
oh this is when I found it he might have
oh that move Queen f8 no time no time
king of five and goes hunting
who who knew the King was on B8 10 moves
ago what the heck okay Queen
okay King steps back these surprise no a
move
oh
where's the killing block well there's
no Rook D1 check now so all of those
ladder checks have been meaningful but
okay F6 Rook H7 perhaps or Rook B7
okay I kind of like seven seconds for
Levon he needs to find a cure against
King E5 the King goes no Queen E4 check
no that looks weird I don't know he
doesn't make he doesn't find it oh my
god oh Queen E4 check
what a gig Queenie for check and Rook G6
will win the game oh that's it for Fabby
that's that's it oh he didn't see Queen
E4
okay this is just nerves
oh but you're hunting the black king
this
oh this must be me Queen E4 check but
then King C5 yes
you have to go Rook C6 King C4 would
have been made not that clear guys okay
now the king will just dance on B5
yep you're right about that
time time that was seconds we're talking
about Fabi has just 10 seconds
isn't this so clear Christian no no no
no a moment ago I thought Queen E4 would
I don't see it anymore Queen to E4
followed by King 2 B5 that King is just
like running away amazing
no I mean I mean oh Rook C5 Queen B3 is
that is that it yeah I think
not yet not yet oh Queen A4 Rook a five
Queen C4 you can Queen D3 check I've
gotta play B5 yeah
no my Rook is hanging can you intercept
with the Rook Rook B5 you have to
King A5 Rook okay seven stuff okay seven
King B4
this is a wild king no oh
no okay one Queen takes A1 check oh my
goodness
but okay goodness how is this King how
is it possible I don't understand how
this game is Dead 20 moves ago oh my God
she's still alive King
D5 where is five Rook D7 perhaps that's
correct but then I queen queen D1 didn't
see that one
why did he play that move okay he saw
something but well the king king E5 and
otherwise it's going to be Queen to D7
checkmate but I don't see the truck made
even then I know no after Queen kingy
five as it was the only move to stay in
the position okay is there any Queen to
E2 right
you know in those moments when he just
doesn't see the maybe he's got these
lovely Quiet Moves 24 queen queen of
five
The Rook is protected on C5 that's a
huge unbelievable okay and now he's
threatening rookie eight oh that's
that's a nice spot oh
Rook D5 I was expecting King F5
wow
what a game we were on the edge of our
seat to the very end that one
defending Champion refuses an exit I
know and that means only one thing the
players are tied and the match will now
go on to Blitz
I have to say if there was a heart rate
machine on that one I think the
commentators would have been you know
like higher higher than the players what
a game what a game Christian
wow and the scenario Jovi first of all
yeah and you can see that we have just
had a two-game rapid playoff that was
tied so this means we are now going on
to the Blitz and this means the players
will be playing with three minutes plus
two second increments
I think we're back closer to Armageddon
I think we might see an Armageddon in
this wow not much between these two
Christians how do you cool down after
this type of match after this time
I'm sorry you have two or three minutes
or however many Chris bird decides that
he's going to give you right how do you
cool down right now how do you slow down
your heartbeat it's a difficult question
right you just play this especially for
Fabiano for Levon okay it's some sort of
a disappointment there are some hints of
disappointment because he knows he was
so close right that close position it
didn't seem like there's any
breakthroughs and that's exactly what
Fabi did what we were anticipating that
he will do he will take him down all the
way to the last minute and then open up
the position and that's exactly what he
did he played that D4 at the right
moment he had the option of also
sacrificing the piece with Bishop takes
C5 he decided against that D4 kept it
super complicated and won the match won
the game
and the match continues
we're very very intriguing we're going
to take a very short break because we
know the the game is coming up but boy I
gotta calm down yeah I got to take those
deep breaths and I will see you on the
other side
[Music]
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
it's 2023 and the grand chest tour is
back for its ninth trip around the world
inspired by former world champion Gary
Kasparov the grantchester hosts the top
players to compete for top prizes eight
of the world's best joint tournament
wild cards and travel to four different
countries to fight for a 1.4 million
dollar prize fund the tour kicks off in
Bucharest Romania for the super fat
chess classic then things speed up as we
move to Warsaw Poland and sagreb Croatia
for the first two rapid and Blitz events
the tour then makes its way to St Louis
Missouri for the final two events we're
back in November for the St Louis rapid
and Blitz and the illustrious sinkfield
cup when points are up for grabs the
best players show up who will be crowned
the new Champion find out when the grand
chess tour returns
well we are back faster than we expected
my colleagues are just temporarily and
disposed and they are repeating their
earlier the same opening from their
earlier game with Knight D7 uh last time
there was a rook on E8 and this time
Fabi says I don't need to play rookie
eight I'm going to leave my Rook on f8
as we are in the blitz three minutes for
both players with only a two second
increment so we're playing the world
Blitz Championship time control for this
one obviously the players will get white
and black the winner moves on the loser
eliminated and in case of a tie we'll
have an Armageddon
yes
well but the Rook was on E8 and there
was a rook on E1 and that the difference
is that the Rook is probably better
placed on f8
so it takes takes and we'll expect
something similar to the earlier game
with ef and GF yes yes and uh
whether we have to include Bishop C6 or
not we're about to find out but is this
a better version for Fabiano or for
Levon is the big question I'm gonna say
it's a better version for Fabi because
in fact The Rook on E8
wasn't so well placed and The Rook on E1
was very well placed yes yes I agree I
agree yes
we we thought we were going to have a
five minute break and the players were
like let's go let's go
but uh hello okay well the players now
playing in the blitz playoff and they're
playing at a much faster time control of
three minutes plus two seconds
if this match is tied then we're going
to go on to the final stage of
Armageddon and guys we have the same
position we do we've absolutely
transposed to the earlier game and I
thought that the earlier position
strongly favored levonne so I'm kind of
stunned quite frankly that uh
[Music]
um fabby's happy with his current
position and his side to change it up a
little bit he put his name he's going
with your idea of Knight to f8 Knight to
G6 right
previously
he played if I'm not mistaken F4
followed by E4 followed by E3 yeah and
he went all in on the king side yes now
he's taking a much more timid approach
but perhaps wait a minute I played
Knight f8 you you meant to say
courageous
activities you see what I have to deal
with around here I mean just like they
just pound me
[Laughter]
a modest man with much to be modest
about yeah
well okay when it comes to the clock
times we can see that Lavon aronen is
the one who is has lower time than a
Fabiana caruana
A5 wow I mean a flash through my mind to
consider the move Bishop takes H6 and
Knight takes E5 just because the queen
side pieces on the on the piece of
fabby's pieces on the queen side
I can get to it are not active and white
ooh this move is an indication to me
that something's not copacetic about the
position for black well I guess do you
defend right now he has to go for it
right yeah exactly are we going to see
E4 and for uh
previously played go forth
Knight G6 first then
this is the Knight G6 you have to deal
with Queen takes pawn and there's some
but I want to folks your queen on to C6
so that I can go Rook to B8 and he's
done it he's done it he said the Pawn's
all yours if you want it that's fine
because I go Rook B6 and after that I
transfer The Rook on the other side of
the board once you defend the pawn on
beetle you have to defend that pawn on
B2 I don't think you can allow me to
invade with a rook like that yeah I'm
thinking I actually want to duck the
whole E4 F4 uh hits and I'm thinking uh
Bishop C1 carpovian defending the pawn
on B2 prepping Queen takes C6 yes so
maybe I can go Queen C6 Rook B8 Bishop
C1 Rook B6 and let that Rook slide
across nope first okay I can I I'm a
supporter yeah I like this move the
bishop was in the way of the E1 Rook
and well you've made this great
demonstration on the king side Knight to
f8 to G6 you're investing a lot of time
over there I mean at certain moment
you're gonna have to go E4 Knight H4 and
Press Your Luck but I was thinking it
maybe it's not E4 that you want to play
maybe it's more along the lines of move
the king to age eight okay I like this
Rook B8 and then get the Rook to G8 and
then F4 and unleash unleash the dragon
the Kraken yes
inviting the a inviting uh Queen it
takes a I like this move Knight D2 but
take a look at lavon's clock time
under 30 seconds that's not good or
pieces now Rook to B5
um I must say that I like my knight on
C5 I'd probably want to support it with
the move B4
Knight B3 but it just feels like those
pieces are going on wait wait wait
a minute the King has no Defenders
exactly Now's the Time Bishop f8 Knight
to D3 Knight comes back into playing not
happy by the sequence for Lavon Rook to
D5 The Rook went from A8 to D5 It's
Magic and it's funny after C4 probably
it would go back to d8 and Levon playing
with seconds on the clock he's just nine
seconds Knight takes A5 well he's
inviting
F4 yep I told you and he's accepting the
invitation
and there is nobody at home on the king
side I I would be shocked if you know F3
and Bishop H3 doesn't know
arrive like a ton of bricks do you do it
now or do you take on D1 first well yeah
I I probably will not want to sacrifice
it which has to come back okay at least
somebody's back at home yeah age four
this is starting to look dangerous
your king h8 Rook G8 ideas
it's not too shabby and well he just
simply goes forward with his pawns and
move on
he gets just an extra two seconds how
does Knight takes G2 not win here
Knight takes G2 King takes G2 F3
loose looks convincing
good move on
look at that
just in time
the golden rule of Jovi yeah but no
there's still a lot of danger I mean
look at that Rook h
a Checkmate was being threatened and now
the players playing so fast we see Lavon
is an exchange down but he's up on time
check do you want to wish by three is he
going to take that yes yes he had to
Knight to F5 Rook G2 check King F1 you
don't want to be stuck in the corner
he found it I think he found it oh wow
wow wow with his back to the wall
needing to win on demand he did it and
our defending Champion with the black
pieces
well now he's pushed to live on Iranian
wow and Levon is like no break no let's
just get it wow is now in a must win a
situation but with the black pieces
truly uh I thought leaving the king all
by him is Lonesome
was was terrible uh decision making by
Lavon after Bishop D6 King King G1
and that moment we see Lavon
and here we go
this was all intuition right because you
don't know whether there's going to be a
Checkmate or not on that side but you
have to go for it right
here is Checkmate so now I guess he
needed to play something like Bishop to
D2 or something allowing Rook G allowing
Bishop G1 that was terrible yeah
I need uh need help as we get a new game
coming up
and uh
Abby now in the driver's seat all he
needs is a draw with the white pieces
how these matches change on a dime
seriously right
thank you Jovi
as we're getting ready for uh
if we see an Armageddon I hope it would
be unbelievable it would really be
unbelievable just you know use every
resource that they have you know show
every single ounce of grit and
resilience to take it to the next stage
you know we've seen LaVon in a must-win
situation Fabian a must win situation
incredible I know
and this will be their sixth game today
and Levon I feel exhausted and I'm just
calling the game
actually playing a very risky opening
it's a modern right yeah well a perk
defense or in in the Northwest we called
it a rat uh one of my all-time favorites
uh as a junior player I loved uh playing
these positions today I think
they even calling it the black lion or
something
you know you go H6 and G5 and it's it's
crazy what they do uh these days with
the modern engines and it feels like
right now it's a kind of a hippo defense
you know I think the black lion is with
E5 right yeah I apologize I think you're
right and Jovi probably knows much
better because one of our good friends
right uh Simon Williams oh you're
putting me on the sports you didn't read
the book sorry I apologize
your one chance uh to to to
loud him and to say yeah yeah it's a
great call you are a great course great
stuff yeah
Russian read
uh whoa E5 and wait a minute wait a
minute he didn't jump to
d57 putting pressure on E5 that's okay
he has to win he he does and so he's got
to take some uh extra he's not trying to
equalize things no no you can't equalize
but on the other hand give black just
one more move Bishop B7 and Knight takes
E5 and black will be the one for choice
so Bobby actually has to come up with
something very consequent
94 it should be seven an invitation to
drop in that was an enterprising id4
yes 96 let's go with six yeah and then
the bishop will move but then I take on
A6 right
correct that's important the the
question I would have is can I take on
F3 Bishop F3 Bishop F3 something like
well Rook A7 Knight B5 how about America
wow but okay if you let the A6 Pawn drop
that's not a problem because you do pick
up the e45 pawn
I don't think you can give up the light
Square Bishop I I think you have to keep
the light Square before
well this is where he got himself into
trouble in the previous game he burned a
lot of clap in the middle game where he
ended up which is seconds and uh did uh
live on yeah yes is he is he is he
dropped a minute on the clock he's at
one minute and 40 seconds while Fabiano
is at two minutes and 12 seconds okay
that's already getting significant
Bishop C6 same move faster was better
how do you continue right now do you
defend the pawn on E5 with Bishop D4
or do you take on A6
um
um I probably take on A6 and look
forward to the trades by the way the
young gentleman and the back ground
there Colin uh is from the Make-A-Wish
Foundation as his wish was to come to St
Louis and watch his heroes in action
he does and and what a match to watch I
know
talk about good timing Colin
okay here I'm probably going to play A5
and look forward to an opportunity of
playing Knight to D5 and somehow
undermining but a594
I apologize Knight to D4 I'm not sure if
it's a good move I'm just saying okay
you have to be careful so maybe I have
to start with Knight D5 id5 maybe bishop
G5
okay
Rook to E1 Rook to E1 increasing the
defense of the Pawn on E5 well the nice
part about B5 is it does prep the square
D5 as c2c4 would not be a move in the
near future Queen C7
I like this I like this I again if you
have to win with black
you couldn't ask for a better
opportunity because this is already uh
three results no question a lot of
pieces on the board and that's what's
important right now opportunities for
black still remaining in this game right
yeah there's some danger though in the
position
is you can't just put a rook onto d8
because Bishop G5 but Knight D5 is is a
nice move is there any Bishop h6s in the
air let's go Rook d8 right oh you want
to provoke me yes okay no because Bishop
G5 I have 1965 yeah okay so you think
Rook today I I like your move Bishop H6
I must say that
yeah I'd be six nine to B6 played with
only 16 seconds on his spot right now
86. wow I don't really like this move
and I think your Bishop H6 so I find it
very concerning actually that's exactly
what I'm saying B6 and don't like
levonne just 16 seconds on the clock and
it only gets two second increment per
move and again uh the boldly stating the
obvious all Fabi needs is a draw and he
might be getting it from a position of
strength after this move Knight D4 that
night on D6 seven six no oh it's so
difficult to come up with good moves and
the position is still crazy it's still
got a lot of tension in it C3 Bishop F4
he just goes page four piling on the
pressure I like it I like it in night on
D6 I like this
I would probably play Knight to E4 I
like this Knight on C8 you you you you
can keep it on C8 yes and Fabi says uh
94 Rook D I like C3 I like my pieces
being protected but H5 Fabi is fabi's
playing like he needs to win
he has to well now you have to get wait
a minute but hang on a second no he
doesn't need to draw but there's a
problem with the Knight F6 there's two
nights under attack
what yeah right on D4 and then I don't
know he has to go Knight D6 unless he's
actually gonna come in with he just
squeeze upon uh
uh he can jump in with an blundered
something here he missed can I can he
play Knight FC whoa whoa Knight E6 look
at this queen F4 Knight F5 Knight G5 oh
my goodness six seconds five seconds
and Lavon needs a win and fobby is
playing like he needs the win he's a
piece down right now I know but are we
going to see an Armageddon guys that's a
long way away with seven seconds oh
Bishop takes G2
what a shot
a queen takes E6 is uh lavon's idea you
take the bishop on G2 Queen E6 the
weight one section Shelby this is crazy
Knight
g57 Queen he's getting ready to go to C6
and Rook is coming to f8 this is winning
Bishop C4 Bishop to C4 was a winning
move at that point no he missed it he
everybody missed it
five seconds
Queen E5 Queen E5
no
what's wrong okay
good quick Queen E5 is not Checkmate the
the the the G7 square is defended by the
Knight what am I saying goodness no but
Rook day C7 was oh
I think he made the move with one second
and this is just pure Instinct right now
it certainly is seven seconds and that
Forks the queen in the night forces more
trades I yeah this one I have no words
right now should be winning Queen DC
Queen episode
he could play E7
why didn't he goes Queen takes yes he's
done it he's gotten rid of the pawn now
it's easy yeah B5
Bishop V5
uh very nicely played by Lavon what a
crazy game we're gonna see Armageddon
guys Armageddon
oh my word where are you going with your
Kids Corner okay
just to get a few extra Tempe and queen
to D7 Bishop to E2 Bishop
yes
bravo bravo Lavon okay now the bishop
just comes into E2 absolutely or checked
oh don't don't allow
yeah Queen F2 F2 no no take the last
Pawn exactly perhaps the right solution
the queen G8 check is not the problem
here for for black there is no problem
yes it's a check but not much more than
that wait
wait a minute just when you thought it
was safe he just blundered that's that's
another and sweet oh I mean he's still
winning for sure of course
he just made his life much more much
is Just or the tension that the board
must be palpable oh
is there a way picture right now with
knife
is there a way of picking up this fish
you have to go with the H Pawn
okay Queen H7 check is not an issue five
and that takes away the final score of
the king do you threatening Knight G3
mate I don't think there's a way out
Knight G3 mate
on demand seconds left on the clock the
emotions the tension oh
wow we are gonna go to the next stage
yasa and Christian it is gonna be the
tournament very first
Armageddon which means that the player
with the white pieces will be playing
with five minutes yep and the player
with black pieces will be playing with
four minutes right that means that they
do get draw odds but there is a nice
little twist at move 61 of the players
will get a two second increment so it's
guys hold on to your seats we're in for
a bumpy ride I I hardly believe what I
just saw this game had had so many
Twisted turns it seemed like a novel
that just wouldn't stop I mean it was
like that was crazy
that was really I mean oh my word I mean
good how how would you sum up that game
uh Christian yeah good luck with that
chaotic yeah it's chaos chaos on the
board but this is what we expected when
Lavon had to win with the black pieces
right he did what he had to do
complicate the position create as much
chaos as possible
Fabiano did get a winning position
he was completely winning dominating H5
H6 get the king to f8 get close to the
Checkmate and then forgot about those
two knights being attacked at the same
time and after that despite the fact
that our producer was saying that white
had a winning position at some point it
doesn't matter because once chaos is on
the board anything can happen and this
is the only thing that Levon was
interested at the beginning of the game
just make it as messy as possible
wow and just to see the magic of
Television just a little bit at the end
here as uh pieces have been flying
blunders Galore but at the same time
I I felt that Lavon kept
uh the win in his pocket I mean even as
he wasn't playing all the best moves
this one right here and H4 H3 we're very
very impressive as he sets up a mating
attack with Knight G3 Nate
H3
so we're going to get the coin toss
right now we're getting it are we going
to see that coin toss is that the way
they decided with the coin test I
believe we're getting a coin toss and
whoever wins the coin toss decides
yeah
okay so guys right if if you won the
coin toss what color would you pick
white white white so you would take
white in another circumstance of course
I would take black in the draw odds but
in this match
it's victory victory victory yes
nobody's making draws yes it's crazy so
I have to go I'm taking black are you
taking black I'm gonna Buck the trend
and I'm gonna say black and the best
thing about the playing with the black
pieces you just have to make the moves
as quickly as you can because in move 60
you're going to get the extra two times
yeah
um boy uh hardly believe it but the
crazy part about that game that we just
witnessed was uh
yeah yeah this is a different view right
in five minutes versus four minutes uh
like you don't see that the clocks are
always uh the same this last game that
we just witnessed it was like Bobby was
playing for the win yes yes he was and
maybe that was his mistake but
how can you slow the pace whenever your
opponent throws everything at you right
you you have to accept it yeah and here
we go as we see our
Chief photographer there uh Leonard
Otis C4 with Knight F3 no more nights
whoa we're inviting D5 take C4 there yes
yes Bobby wants a long game there's no
increment this is
letting game can't offer white anything
D5 takes yeah but it does allow white to
play lots and lots of moves
so instead yes what we're gonna get is a
position with some tension and already
we see very extend on the king side I'm
not a fan I'm not a fan right uh that's
you feel that might be too much I like
the I like creativity but I don't like
bad moves that looks bad and the
difference is that white hasn't
developed on the queen side while black
has done everything in the position all
his pieces made a connection between the
Rooks it just feels like
black is slightly better yeah
something along those lines exactly
because A6 controlling the knights
circuit but we have to be a little
careful because if E5 comes I could just
have some space in it
and be happy is white that's true
because E5 hits the F6 points four four
he's putting on the pressure
everything throwing caution to the wind
right well I mean he's been throwing the
kitchen sink at him since that third
game
how many games H4 let's go
their seventh game
oh my goodness and what a match these
two have put on for us uh
and black
black and everyone does Dodge or odds
yes it means if the game is a draw yes
Levon remains in the competition and we
say goodbye to Fabiano okay after this
move B5 isn't that an invitation for E5
we're all ready to go we're dressed up
Bishop takes age six first okay I like
that move too uh just to break open
Black's King side a little bit but he'll
give me the opportunity of playing B4
now and kicking the Knight away
and he goes for it you're absolutely
spot on with that one Christian
or do you pass by with the move G6 I
wouldn't pass by yeah G6 and Knight H5
and he does and that that puts up a
pretty good Fortress over on the king
side I don't like that Knight on D1 that
night on D1 just has no good uh uh yeah
the conjunct anywhere as well I mean the
move that I really wanted to be met to
make for quite a while was actually E4
E5 indeed
um and uh right now to E4 and okay but
okay Club situations so Fabi has three
minutes
[Music]
Knight H5 is such a a deadly kind of
threat and that's why he played Bishop
Bishop F3 stop the move Knight to H5 you
cannot allow the Knight to jump on that
particular Square okay how about bishop
f8 and Bishop takes H6 good move
good idea
he's not going to touch that pawn with
the King he just wants to no no no no no
uh Bishop again Bishop f8 Bishop takes
H6 would be on my agenda but a knight H3
and Knight G5 is coming
Knight H5 now that
is remarkable what a move nevertheless
the difference has been re-established
right now one minute difference oh
pardon me Rook the G6 yes I can play
Rook to G6 if Rook G6 F5 F5 is illegal
so we Rook to G6 with the King on H2
that move is illegal indeed yeah Rook to
G6 followed by Rook on A8 to G8 and
black has the initiative but wait one
second you still can neutralize it by
going Bishop E3 and then Rook G1 he just
missed that move what ah you cannot take
on H6 because if Queen takes F7 yeah but
I can play Bishop takes eight no Bishop
takes H4 he could play Bishop takes H4
but now Rook to G8 threatens the move
Rook takes H6
that's a big threat ah
how do you defend against it
can you defend the guest yeah it is
illegal F5 is illegal can you just throw
the knight in nine H3 yeah four is
hanging
yeah I don't see it guys I I really
don't see it
how do you stop Rook takes H6 you cannot
stop Rook H6
to
burn the time and time and so he drops
the queen back I think this is a good
decision I'm not sure it's inviting F5
it's inviting
Bishop H4 as well as Rook H6 the problem
is there's too many tempting choices
here for live on and he's chosen F5 a
move that I really love because that
Bishop on E3 is now crying now you have
time
and try to do something
yeah but then you can go Queen G3 and
just try
stage four yeah I think yes
Rook H6 very very quickly played Levon
and the participants is that Bishop E8
is coming right now so you try to hide
that pawn on the light squares good luck
with that I have two Bishops
one on the board you call it Bishop to
EA threatening Bishop H5 and
discovered checkmates I think this is
going lavon's win by the way is up on
time right now
and all he needs is a draw and he's my
he he might be knocking out our
defending Champion with this incredible
play by the way Bishop takes H5 what is
that
that's upon that's yeah
wow
that's it
I can't believe what I just saw
I mean Lavon just won three in a row
right I mean he did he did Back to the
wall no wait a minute what what am I
saying I need one too and no he he won
in a must-win situation so he's had two
must win situations and he must yeah
yeah and he's he's done it he did it
with the white pieces yeah the black
pieces and now he just had to draw he
had to survive and he
so that means it is Lavon aronian who
goes through to the next stage against
we say goodbye to defending Champion
Fabiana caruana and no don't show it
come on WOW
you know I mean
professional commentators and in the
ladies and the ladies I'm still in there
everyone is silly I had a good day
Serena crush and artists
on over and naisy paikitsa managed to
stay alive in the comment in the
competition in the elimination bracket
but boy what an adventure I know I feel
like as a commentator like like I
managed to survive yeah yeah you hear
what you were saying my goodness and as
we wait for our winner to come over and
join us uh Lavon
let's go through the brackets please
let's do it and in the Women's Champions
bracket
um Arena crush and honestly started off
with a very exciting draw everything to
play for tomorrow as it will be decided
who will go down to the elimination
bracket well let's see about that
elimination bracket shall we and the
Elimination Brackets we saw some huge
matchups between Nazi pakiza and tatif
abrahamian Nazi one and it was toke a
jonova who defeated bokashian very
convincingly and these two will now face
off against each other tomorrow tomorrow
and whoever wins will be meeting the
loser or runner-up as we like to say of
the Champions bracket and in the Open
Championship bracket and in the open
Champions bracket Hikaru Nakamura Wesley
so two legends of the game they agreed
quite a tame draw I would say but it was
an elimination bracket where things went
wrong they got wild they got Furious and
Goodness Me Wow Let's have a look I mean
as a commentator you just dream of days
like today because there's just so much
to talk about and uh well Lanier and
Lavon really brought the heat yeah they
did bring the key to the table and uh
Dominguez was simply resplendent against
Sam shanket but wow it went to
Armageddon between Fabiano Carolina and
Lavon aronian and it was Levon aronian
who emerged triumphant in those last
seconds yes what a game I remember a
match I remember a world championship
match between Boris girlfriend and this
one upon Anan and the uh com the
journalists for sure why did you win
like because there was nothing between
them and then she said I won because I
won
he didn't have an explanation for it
either you know and today this is what I
felt between Lavon and Fabi like at any
single moment a
a different move here or there could
have easily thrown the decision to the
other player quite the match as lavon's
in in studio and getting set up
and Christian take it away
they pay us for it but right now we are
sort of speechless how do you feel right
now sum up your feelings for us I think
at some point I started shaking
and I'm still I'm still in a kind of a
tilt
you were in a must-win situation twice
today then Fabiano was also in a must
win situation and managed to come back
then at the end of it you just threw
your hands up in the air and you made a
sign like this what were your feelings
no I was very happy I just uh you know
at that moment when you achieve
something
as my psychologist told you you have to
kind of celebrate at that moment who is
your psychologist
but no the thing is I'm I mean no
disrespect yes to Fabiana his close
friend of mine yes but at that moment
it's just you know I want to
be happy
do you ever feel whenever you're on the
other side any bad feelings or what do
you nothing right now no I mean of
course he feels upset and I would be
upset if I lost to him but at the same
time you you cannot just blame your
opponent if they're celebrating a win
I think this is a natural feel and
unless they're doing something excessive
laughing or doing something right this
you know there there are ways to
celebrate things I think there are ways
to say red wins and I don't think I ever
you know past that threshold where where
celebration turns into disrespect and as
you guys were getting ready for the
Armageddon we saw you laughing with
Fabiano chatting a little bit about the
upcoming game what do you what are you
guys telling yourselves I told Fabiana
that we're creating content I've been
laughing about it with him I was saying
nowadays uh you know
really playing chess is not as lucrative
as creating content
uh you know it's just an inside joke
you're playing a linear tomorrow that's
how you started the tournament with a
match against linear how do you
anticipate that one to go well I
definitely need a need to rest a bit
today and uh you know it's actually
playing against Lanier and playing
against Fabiano is a great joy for me
because they're my friends they're from
Saint Louis
and uh you know look I don't mind losing
against them
absolutely guys join the conversation
any questions for our Victor uh I'm kind
of in shock myself I need to recover too
I would just say uh Lavon uh you put on
a both of you put on a fantastic display
and uh
I just enjoyed everything about today
and and just simply congratulations it
was a great match it really was but tell
me yes sir this H6 H5 and G6 Knight H5
is this something you you enjoyed seeing
no I was ashamed
no I did actually I like your G6 and I
liked your knight H5 especially I
thought that was really really really
creative uh well done I mean what a
match Jovi what a match yeah what a
story and I the only thing that I want
to know is how on Earth did you quickly
recover
ah when you play too long and you know
the thing is when you play idiotic moves
this is something to be expected
but then you suddenly Play Good Moves
you get happy because this is something
unexpected so you get good emotions
I want to ask you about one particular
moment in this match when you found that
triangulation King G2 King F2 King F3
you did it three times that must have
given you an extra boost of energy I
didn't think it was working I think it
was the only way out yeah yeah otherwise
the only way but I felt it's still a
draw no it wasn't no that was that was
the winning but that game was ridiculous
because I blundered and he could take on
G2 and Rook D7 doesn't work because of
Rook F7 there was a big shame in that
game for me and I was uh yeah I think I
kept on blundering a lot but it's only
natural when you play against somebody
as strong as for piano who always poses
problems Levon congratulations we'll let
you go get some rest and get ready for
tomorrow's match thank you very much
definitely our congratulations wow I
just I'm still in stunned by it all that
was that was great stuff I mean come on
I mean uh this is really a championship
Chess at its best in the American Cup
this whole format I have to say for me
as a commentator it delivers uh it comes
with a a wallop I think it was epic you
know it was beautiful we want to see
right the emotions we want to see
players you know Play Beautiful chess
but at the same time you know play
Scrappy chess you know just hold on dig
deep you know exactly and do everything
possible just to get through to the next
stage and yeah chess is brutal I admit
that on times but this was just a
spectacle and it was loved it bring it
home for us with your final thoughts I
mean guys it's so difficult to add
anything to this story to today's story
just an incred incredible day full of
Chess and I'm left speechless and I am
left inspired and I do want to see what
the players are going to bring once
again back to the chessboard in
tomorrow's matches stay tuned absolutely
thank you everyone for sharing your day
with us be sure to join us tomorrow same
time same channel as we have more
America cup 2023 to share with you
[Music]
foreign
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited